ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD COPY AT ALL
[inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
THAT ALSO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG HILL [inaudible]
HUESO -- TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
I'M BURKE [inaudible]
WHY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LEAD
IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY OUR
GUEST CHAPLAIN.
SISTER LIBBY FERNANDES ARE SPM
EXACTLY DIRECTOR MERCY PADDLERS.
AFTER WHICH REMAIN STANDING AND
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE BY
SENATOR BATES.
WORDS FROM A SISTER OF MERCY.
IF WE WERE UNDER THE WORD MERCY.
MAYBE WHEN IT TAKES FLIGHT INTO
DEED AND KINDNESS JUSTICE AN
EFFORT.
IT WILL EFFECT A HEALING A HOLE
AND A BLESSING.
IT MAY CALL THE HOMELESS HOME.
IT MAY COAX TO HOPE THE BETRAYED
IN BROKEN.
IT MAY EASE THE BURDEN EARTH.
LISTEN FOR IT.
LISTEN FOR ITS NEIGHBORLY
DIALECTS AND GLOBAL EDM.
IMAGINE THOSE WHO LIKE YOU.
ARE SAYING IT ALOUD AND THOSE
WHO NEED TO HEAR IT TODAY. ONE
WORD. ONE DEED OF JUSTICE. ONE
KIND EFFORT AT A TIME.
AND LIVING GOD GIVE US COURAGE
TO SAY AND TO BE MERCY TODAY.
A MAN.
HANDOVER HEARTS READY BEGAN I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE ARE YOU.
A SUMMER [inaudible] ONE NATION
[inaudible]
VISIBLE [inaudible]
THE SONG.
ART MEMBERS MOVING TO PRIVILEGE
OF THE FLOOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDED.
I MEAN AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
[inaudible]
SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX SP ONE SEVENTY FIVE
TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
THANK YOU DULY NOTED.
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO THE DAILY
FILE WE HAVE TWENTY ONE ITEMS
THAT WERE HOPING TO GET THROUGH
THIS AFTERNOON.
AND WE ABSENT AT THIRD READING
AND WE'RE READY FOR OUR FIRST
ITEM ITEM NUMBER SEVEN IS THE
AUTHOR READY.
FOR CENTER LEFT LABOR ARE YOU
READY FOR YOUR ITEM.
SEVEN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
ROUTE SENATE BILL FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR BY SENATOR LEYVA AN ACTUAL
IN THE COSMETICS.
SOONER OR LATER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS.
SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR REQUIRES
THE DISCLOSURE OF FRAGRANCE AND
FLAVOR INGREDIENTS IN PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS THAT APPEAR ON
DESIGNATED AND AUTHORITATIVE
HAZARDOUS CHEMICAL LIST. TO
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS BILL DOES NOT BAN PRODUCT
INGREDIENTS OR REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL PRODUCT LABELING LET
ME REPEAT THAT THIS BILL DOES
NOT BAN ANY PRODUCT INGREDIENT
OR REQUIRE ADDITIONAL PRODUCT
LABELING.
SB FIVE SEVEN FOUR ALSO PROTECTS
TRADE SECRETS INCLUDING PRODUCT
INGREDIENT FORMULAS SO THAT WE
ARE PROTECTING VALUABLE RECIPES
AND FORMULATIONS.
TODAY IN CALIFORNIA THE PUBLIC
KNOWS MORE ABOUT THE FRAGRANCE
INGREDIENTS IN CLEANING PRODUCTS
THEN THOSE THAT WE USE TO CLEAN
AND PERFUME OUR BODIES.
PUT ANOTHER WAY WE KNOW MORE
ABOUT THE FRAGRANCES AND FLOOR
CLEANERS AND DISINFECTANTS THAN
OUR SHAMPOOS DEODORANTS AND BODY
SPRAYS.
WE ALSO KNOW VERY LITTLE ABOUT
THE FLAVOR IN CHOPSTICKS
MOUTHWASH AND LIP GLOSS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
SO MEMBERS MY LITTLE LIP GLOSS
HERE THAT I LIKE TO USE IT IS
STRAWBERRY FIZZ FLAVOR I HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT THE INGREDIENTS ARE IN
IT TO MAKE IT TASTE LIKE
STRAWBERRY PHYS.
CURRENTLY NO STATE OR FEDERAL
LAW REQUIRES THE DISCLOSURE OF
FRAGRANCE OR FLAVOR INGREDIENTS
TO CONSUMERS OR REGULATORY
AGENCIES NOT EVEN THE FTA.
THIS LOOPHOLE ALLOWS CHEMICALS
TO HIDE UNDER THE WORD FRAGRANCE
FOR FLAVOR ON THE LABELS OF
BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS WAS LITTLE REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT.
OF THE SAFETY OF THESE
INGREDIENTS.
YOU CAN SEE FOR YOURSELF ON THE
LABELS OF THE PRODUCTS YOU USE
EVERY MORNING AND EVERY NIGHT.
THOUSANDS OF CHEMICALS ARE USED
TO CREATE THE FRAGRANCES AND
FLAVORS THAT COMPRISE THE BEAUTY
AND PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS THAT
WE USE EVERY DAY.
SOME OF THESE CHEMICALS HAVE
BEEN LINKED TO NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS RANGING FROM ALLERGIC
REACTIONS TO REPRODUCTIVE HARM
AND INCREASED RISK OF BREAST
CANCER.
ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE AT RISK OF
EXPOSURE TO HARMFUL FRAGRANCE
AND FLAVOR CHEMICALS A RELATED
CHRONIC HEALTH CONCERNS.
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS SUCH AS CHILDREN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
PREGNANT WOMEN.
SB FIVE SEVEN FOUR I KNOW REYES
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS BILL I
APPRECIATE THAT.
SB FIVE SEVEN FOUR WILL EMPOWER
CONSUMERS TO MAKE EDUCATED
DECISIONS ABOUT WHICH PRODUCTS
TO USE WITH THEIR CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
WITH THIS BILL WE ARE
RECOGNIZING THAT CONSUMERS ARE
WORKER AND WORKERS HAVE A RIGHT
TO KNOW WHAT INGREDIENTS ARE IN
THE PRODUCTS THEY BRING HOME TO
THEIR FAMILIES. FIVE SEVEN FOUR
WILL ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ONCE AGAIN A NATIONAL AND GLOBAL
LEADER ON PUBLIC HEALTH.
MEMBERS I AM COMMITTED TO
ONGOING GOOD FAITH DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE INDUSTRY AND WITH
ADVOCATES TO DATE WE HAVE WORKED
WITH THE INDUSTRY TO TAKE
SEVERAL SEVERAL SUBSTANTIVE
AMENDMENTS.
TODAY I AM COMMITTING TO SEVERAL
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE
ADDITIONAL TRADE SECRET
PROTECTIONS COMPLIANCE TIME AND
IMPROVED IMPLEMENTATION.
THESE COMMITMENTS RESPOND
DIRECTLY TO THE WRITTEN AND
VERBAL AS CONCERNS OF
pI WERE THE RESULT OF COUNTLESS
HOURS OF GOOD FAITH NEGOTIATIONS.
MEMBERS SB FIVE SEVEN FOUR IS
BROADLY SUPPORTED BY LABOR
PUBLIC HEALTH ENVIRONMENTAL
MULTI ETHNIC IN CANCER
PREVENTION ORGANIZATION.
THIS MEASURE IS ALSO SUPPORTED
BY DOZENS OF BUSINESSES THAT ARE
FINDING SUCCESS IN DISCLOSING
FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR INGREDIENTS.
AS WELL AS UNILEVER THE SECOND
LARGEST BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COMPANY IN THE WORLD
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
MEMBERS I RISE IN OPPOSITION SB
FIVE SEVENTY FOR THE BEAUTY
INDUSTRY IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY EMPLOYING
MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE IN JOBS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHILE
CONTRIBUTING. TWENTY EIGHT
BILLION TO THE STATE'S ECONOMY.
UNDER FEDERAL LAW PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COMPANIES DISCLOSE ALL
INGREDIENTS ADDED TO A COSMETIC
PRODUCT INCLUDING.
ADDED FRAGRANCE AND FLAVOR.
AS EXPRESSED BY FEDERAL LAW
FRAGRANCE AND FLAVORS ARE TO BE
LABELED GENERICALLY AS FRAGRANCE
OR FLAVOR ON PRODUCT LABELS.
WHY BECAUSE YOU WANT TO PROTECT
THE PROPRIETARY SECRETS OF THESE
COMPANIES FROM?
COUNTRIES LIKE CHINA THAT WILL
THINK.
TWICE WON'T THINK TWICE ABOUT
COPYING.
OF THESE FRAGRANCES AND FLAVORS
AND AND MARKETING PRODUCTS AND
COMPETITION TO THOSE IN THE
UNITED STATES AND HAVE.
PATENT PROTECTION.
THIS IS A REFLECTION ON THE FACT
THAT FRAGRANCES OF FLAVORS MAYBE
COMPRISE A SPECIFIC RECIPE.
AGAIN WHICH COULD BE COPIED.
EFFECTIVELY DESTROYING THE VALUE
OF THE PRODUCT.
IN MY COMPOUNDING PHARMACY AYE
COMMONLY USE FLAVORS SELECT AND
GET CHILDREN TO TAKE.
BETTER DRUGS -- ESPECIALLY IN
CASES OF SOME VERY.
RARELY USE ANTIBIOTICS THAT
COULD SAVE THAT CHILD'S LIFE.
THESE DRUGS ARE VERY BETTER IF
YOU DON'T FLAVOR THEN THE CHILD
IS NOT GOING.
TO TAKE THEM IN ADDITION TO
CERTAIN FRAGRANCES POWERSOFT
FRAGRANCE -- CERTAIN --
FRAGRANCES THAT -- MAKE PRODUCTS
MUCH MORE.
APPEALABLE.
IN ADDITION TO THE FEDERAL LAW
THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
INDUSTRY FACES FURTHER
INGREDIENT TRANSPARENCY AND
CALIFORNIA UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
SAFE COSMETICS ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND FIVE SB FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR DUPLICATES.
THE WORK ALREADY BEING DONE
UNDER THESE EXISTING CALIFORNIA
UNITED STATES LAWS.
AND SHOULD BE REJECTED.
YEAH MY FRIENDS -- AGAIN THIS IS
ANOTHER [inaudible]
ANOTHER HIT.
ON MANUFACTURES NOT ONLY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT THE
COUNTRY.
THE DEATH OF A BILL LIKE THIS IS
TO BE PROMOTED AND PASSED INTO
LAW -- THE LABELING REQUIREMENTS
ARE GOING TO BE SPECIFIC FOR
CALIFORNIA BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
THESE TRADE SECRETS ARE GOING TO
BE LOST BY UNSCRUPULOUS
COMPANIES -- THE DIDN'T DO THE
THE RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT TO
GET.
SOME OF THESE -- FRAGRANCES AND
FLAVORS ON THE MARKET -- TO ADD
VALUE TO THEIR PRODUCTS -- FOR
THESE REASONS I URGE A NO VOTE
IN SB FIVE SEVENTY FOUR THANK
CENTER SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT -- BUT LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TO HEMA.
I TO IN MY DISTRICT SPECIFICALLY
CULVER CITY REPRESENT A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF COSMETIC
MANUFACTURERS I'VE I'VE TOWARD
THEM -- I USE THEIR PRODUCTS.
BUT I THINK WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM TO HUMAN MISSED IN HIS
POINT ABOUT HOW THIS BILL --
WOULD HAVE A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
THE INDUSTRY.
IS THAT THIS BILL OF BILLS LIKE
AT OUR MEETING A DEMAND THE
PUBLIC DEMAND THE PUBLIC WANTS
TO KNOW.
WHAT ARE IN THE COSMETIC?
THAT WE USE.
ON AND THAT STRUCK ME FROM.
POIGNANTLY THIS YEAR IN HEALTH
COMMITTEE WILL WE SAW BASED ON
ONE BILLS SIMILAR TO THIS HAVE
BEEN INTRODUCED IN THE PAST.
THE SHEER NUMBER OF NEW AND
EMERGING A NEW EMERGING INDUSTRY
IN THE COSMETICS INDUSTRY THOSE
WHO ARE CATERING TO THAT PUBLIC
DEMAND. FOR ORGANIC -- AT ANIMAL
FREE TESTING AND ALL THE
EXAMPLES ON THAT REFLECTED IN
COMMITTEE THAT DAY AND SO WHILE
WE THINK IT'S IT'S ONE SIDED TO
THIS SIMPLY VIEW THESE.
DISCLOSURE AND SAFETY BILLS AS
INDUSTRY KILLERS WHERE THE
INDUSTRY IS CLEARLY ADAPTING
ACCORDING TO PUBLIC DEMAND -- I
CAN'T REMEMBER FOR IN THAT LANE
OFF THE BILL OR FIVE SUPPORTED
IT HAVING EXPRESSED SOME CONCERN.
AND I WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING OVERTIME -- WITH
MANUFACTURERS MANY OF WITH MANY
IN THE INDUSTRY MANY.
MANY WHO WERE IN OPPOSITION OF
THE TIME -- AND WORKED ON SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT I ARTICULATED
SPECIFICALLY IN COMMITTEE.
I AM CLEAR THAT POST HEALTH
COMMITTEE SOME ADDITIONAL --
ISSUES HAVE COME UP BUT I HEARD
YOU SAY IN YOUR PRESENTATION --
SENATOR THAT YOU ARE CONTINUING
THE CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE
DEFINITION OF INGREDIENTS AND
THE DEFINITION OF TRADE SECRET I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO GIVE YOU
AND THE INDUSTRY THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTINUE THIS DIALOGUE TO
ALLOW THIS VEHICLE TO CONTINUE
THROUGH THE PROCESS.
BECAUSE AS I SAID THERE IS A
GROWING VERY VOCAL PUBLIC DEMAND
FOR INFORMATION CRITICALLY FOR
THOSE OF US WHO MAY USE MORE OF
THESE -- ITEMS IN PRODUCTS THAN
OTHERS -- FOR THOSE REASONS I'LL
BE SUPPORTING SB FIVE SEVEN FOUR
TODAY AND WILL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR -- THE PROCESS -- AND
HOPE TO CONTINUE TO BE ENGAGED.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DESCRIPTION A BIT ON THE SIDE ON
SITTING HERE NINE SOONER LABOR
WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WANT TO THINK THE SENATOR FROM
LA FOR HER COMMENTS AND JUST
ALSO SAY THAT YES I HAVE A LIST
OF EIGHT COMMITMENTS.
THAT WE HAVE AGREED TO WORK ON
OVER AND TAKE OVER IN THE IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM -- TEMECULA I WANT TO
REASSURE YOU THAT THIS BILL DOES
NOT APPLY TO ANTIBIOTICS THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT HAVE A
LABELING MECHANISM AND IT.
AND I ALSO WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU YOU'VE BEEN GENEROUS IN
SHARING WITH US ABOUT YOUR
FAMILY.
SO MATURE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY
FAMILY -- ONE OF OUR DAUGHTERS
IS PREGNANT WITH OUR FIRST GRAND
CHILD AND I WOULD LOVE FOR HER
SHE'S A PERFUME ME GAL SHE LIKES
TO USE LOTS OF DIFFERENT THINGS.
I WOULD LOVE FOR HER TO BE ABLE
TO GO ONTO A WEBSITE AND SEE
WHAT IS THE INGREDIENTS ARE THAT
ARE IN THE FRAGRANCES OF THE
PRODUCTS SH USES.
JUST TO BE A 100% SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT HARMING THAT UNBORN
CHILD SO MEMBERS WITH THAT I
ASKED RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR THIRD PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
HI BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL.
HI PORGES.
NO BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
THEY'RE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HI HI HILL [inaudible]
HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON.
BY JONES.
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER.
BY STERN BY STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER [inaudible]
BLACK OWSKI [inaudible]
BY WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
COPY AT ALL [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH NO [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HI -- TADO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ROOM -- BURKE [inaudible]
HI WILK [inaudible]
LOOK NO.
MISTER MISTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL
OUT TO MEMBERS WARMER JOHN COPY
AT ALL [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER -- TADO [inaudible]
RUBIO.
MARCH TWENTY THREE KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM.
NINE SENATOR JACKSON ARE YOU
PREPARED WERE PASSING
TEMPORARILY.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM.
ELEVEN SENATOR RUBIO ARE YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE UP THE SIDE.
WE'RE GONNA PASS TEMPORARILY ON
THAT AS WELL NEXUS FILE ITEM
TWELVE BY SENATOR DORADO.
ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP THIS
ITEM SENATOR DORADO.
WE'RE GONNA PASS.
ARE YOU READY OKAY.
MR PLEASE RATE SENATE BILL
TWENTY NINE TO SENATOR DORADO
AND ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
SENATOR ALSO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
FEDERAL LAW EXPLICITLY.
AN UNJUSTLY EXCLUDES
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS AS WELL
AS DHAKA.
AND TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS
TPS RECIPIENTS FROM RECEIVING
HEALTH COVERAGE THROUGH MEDICARE
ALL [inaudible]
AND THEN.
FROM SELECT THE AND I HEALTH
PLAN OR PARTICIPATING IN COVERED
CALIFORNIA.
WHETHER THEY PAY FOR IT
SUBSIDIES ARE NOT.
AN OVERWHELMING MAJORITY ARE NOT
PROVIDED HEALTH CARE BY THEIR
EMPLOYERS.
AS A RESULT A MILLION AND A HALF
UNDOCUMENTED BILLS ARE STILL
LEFT WITHOUT COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE.
THEY CAN'T GET PREVENTATIVE CARE
FOR ASTHMA DIABETES OR OTHER
PREVENTABLE CONDITIONS.
THEY RELY ON EMERGENCY ROOMS
WHICH IS WHAT WE HAVE TO PAY.
FOR THEY RELY ON LAST MINUTE
CARE.
THAT IS NOT AN EQUITABLE WAY TO
TREAT PEOPLE WHO WORK THEIR
WHOLE LIVES REYES FAMILIES AND
PAY THEIR SHARE IN TAXES.
THEY WORK HARD TO MAKE OUR WINE
INDUSTRY SUCCESSFUL.
THEY TAKE CARE OF OUR CHILDREN.
LANDSCAPE OUR PROPERTIES TAKE%
CARE OF THE ELDERLY AND THE SICK.
AND THEY BUILD OUR HOMES AND OUR
SKY SCRAPERS.
THEY WORK IN TOURISM
[inaudible]
RESTAURANTS HOTELS THEY PICK THE
CROPS FOR FRUITS AND FOR
VEGETABLES.
CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT BE IN THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD WITHOUT.
THEIR HARD WORK AND
CONTRIBUTIONS.
I WAS LISTENING TO DOCTOR KING
WHEN HE MADE A STATEMENT.
ABOUT THE WAY AFRICAN AMERICANS
WERE TREATED IN THIS COUNTRY HE
SAID WE TREAT THEM AS A THING.
NOT LIKE A HUMAN BEING TO BE
RESPECTED.
ALMOST TWO THIRDS OF
CALIFORNIANS OF THESE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE LIVED IN THE
U. S. FOR MORE THAN TEN YEARS.
PARENTS OR GRANDPARENTS CAN TAKE
THEIR CHILD OR GRANDCHILD TO SEE
A DOCTOR WHEN THEY ARE SICK.
BUT THE PARENT OR GRANDPARENT
CANNOT DO THE SAME FOR
THEMSELVES.
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS MAKE UP
NEARLY 10% OF OUR WORKFORCE THEY
CONTRIBUTE OVER THREE BILLION
DOLLARS AND LOCAL AND STATE
TAXES.
YET THEY ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE
LIFESAVING SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
THE DATE HELP. TO PAY.
FOR HAVING HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
MEANS FINANCIAL AND ECONOMIC
STABILITY FOR ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES HIGH RATES OF
UNINSURED ENDS IN A COMMUNITY
CAN'T EVEN AFFECT THOSE WITH
INSURANCE.
AN INSTITUTE OF MEDICINE STUDY
SUGGESTED THAT FINANCIAL
PRESSURES ON HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES.
COULD LEAD TO LOWER INVESTMENT
AND LOCAL HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS AS
WELL AS LOWER CONCENTRATIONS OF
PROVIDERS.
BOTH OF WHICH HAVE A SPILLOVER
EFFECT UNINSURED RESIDENTS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WE ALL
BENEFIT WHEN EVERYONE IS INSURED.
PROGRAMS THAT INCREASED COVERAGE
RESULTED IN REDUCED PREVENTABLE
HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS AND LOWER
DEATH RATES.
HEALTH CARE FOR ALL SHOULD NOT
BE JUST A SLOGAN.
SB TWENTY NINE BILLS ON OUR
PROGRESS TOWARDS COVERING THE
REMAINING UNINSURED AND IS A
BUILDING BLOCK TO ACHIEVE
UNIVERSAL HEALTH COVERAGE IN
CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO COVER THE
REMAINING UNINSURED.
THIS BILL WILL COVER A SMALL
NUMBER OF UNINSURED.
BUT IT'S AN IMPORTANT NEXT STEP
THIS BILL IS A SMART APPROACH TO
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM SENATOR Mà AND
SENATOR HUESO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE TO SUPPORT SB.
TWENTY NINE YOU KNOW AS A AS A
SON OF AN IMMIGRANT WHO CAME
HERE.
NINETEEN FORTY NINE I CAME INTO
A COUNTRY WHERE THERE WERE NO.
LIMITATIONS ON IMMIGRANTS
ABILITY GET HEALTHCARE.
OR LIMITATIONS ON ABILITY CAN
EDUCATION OR QUALIFY.
FOR OF GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS.
YOU KNOW I I'M SAID THAT TODAY
<c.red>N CALIFORNIA WE WE HAVE A BODY</c>
OF LOS IN OUR COUNTRY THAT
TARGET SPECIFICALLY IMMIGRANTS.
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS TO
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR ECONOMY THESE
ARE INDIVIDUALS TO PAY TAXES
THESE ARE IN INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE INTERWOVEN WITH THE FABRIC
OF OUR SOCIETY AND A WAY.
THAT CANNOT BE UNDONE.
BUT IN THE HISTORY OF OUR
COUNTRY THERE'S NEVER BEEN.
A HARDER PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP.
THEN THE IMMIGRANTS OF OUR OUR
MODERN DAY -- UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT WE HAVE
MAKE IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO LIVE WITH DIGNITY WITHIN OUR
SOCIETY.
BUT WE REQUIRE OF THEM.
LONG.
HARD WORK HOURS WE REQUIRE OF
THEM [inaudible]
OF REALLY.
YOU KNOW IN MANY CASES LAWS
DON'T APPLY TO THEM BUT THEY'RE
OUT THERE TRYING TO MAKE A
LIVING FEED THEIR FAMILIES.
LOT OF AMMAR POLITICAL REFUGEES
LOT OF MORE ECONOMIC REFUGEES.
YET WE WE TREAT THEM AS AS HAS.
WE TREAT THEM AS IF THEY WERE
CRIMINALS AND THEN WE WONDER WHY --
GANG SPRING UP IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THERE ARE SO MANY
HARMFUL EFFECTS TO THE WAY WE
TREAT IMMIGRANTS IN OUR SOCIETY
TODAY.
THERE ARE SO MANY OF HARMFUL
CONSEQUENCES THAT COME OUT OF
THAT.
IF WE WERE ABLE TO GIVE THEM A
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP OF WERE
ABLE -- TO PROVIDE THEM WITH.
A DIGNIFIED LIVING AS A WORK IN
OUR COUNTRY.
LOT OF THESE INDIVIDUALS COME
HERE SIMPLY TO EARN A LIVING AND
THEY'RE HELPING TO DRIVE
CALIFORNIA'S AMAZING ECONOMY
THIS IS A WONDERFUL BILL I
WANTED.
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HAVING
THE COURAGE BRING FORWARD AND I
WOULD HOPE WE ARE NOT ONLY US
SUPPORT THIS BUT ALSO FUNDS
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS.
IT'LL MAKE OUR SOCIETY A BETTER
SOCIETY MIDDLE MAKING SURE.
THAT WE HELP CONTROL BAR
HEALTHCARE COSTS AS WELL.
SO THANK YOU MISTER MISTER
PRESIDENT FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SHARE SOME COMMENTS AND I URGE
MY MY COLLEAGUES PLEASE VOTE FOR
THIS BILL SO THE VERY IMPORTANT
BILL.
IN CENTER HUESO CENTER MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWENTY NINE I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS.
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT.
THE LEADING EMPLOYER IN THE
SEVENTEENTH SENATE DISTRICT IS
AGRICULTURE.
THE SECOND LARGEST EMPLOYER IS
HOSPITALITY TOURISM.
THOSE TWO TOP EMPLOYERS IN MY
DISTRICT RELY PREDOMINANTLY ON
IMMIGRANT WORKERS. TO PRODUCE
THE BOUNTY -- IN THE SURPLUS IN
THE PROFITS THAT MAKE THE
DISTRICT STRONG ECONOMICALLY
[inaudible]
THIS BILL. SIX TO EXTEND HEALTH
CARE PROTECTION IN A MANNER THAT
WON'T JUST SERVE.
YOUNG ADULTS AND ELDERS.
IT'LL SERVE ALLRESIDENTS FROM A
PUBLIC HEALTH PERSPECTIVE.
HAVING ACCESS TO PREVENTIVE CARE
INCLUDING.
IMMUNIZATIONS AND PREVENTION
PROTECTS THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
GERMS AND DISEASE DO NOT CHECK
IMMIGRATION STATUS [inaudible]
THEY SPREAD OUT WILL.
COME IN IT'S THE INTERVENTION
THROUGH PREVENTION.
IN PUBLIC HEALTH -- THAT
PROTECTS OUR BROADER COMMUNITIES.
AT ALSO JUST CLOSE BY SAYING.
THAT THE U. S. IS A SIGNATORY TO
THE UNIVERSAL DECLARATION OF
HUMAN RIGHTS. ONE OF THE FROM
THE NUMERATOR HUMAN RIGHTS IS
THE RIGHT TO HEALTH CARE.
BY THE SUPREMACY CLAUSE THAT
BINDS US IN U. S. DOMESTIC LAW.
SO VOTING FOR THIS IS ALSO A
STEP FORWARD -- TO REALIZING OUR
CURRENT LEGAL OBLIGATIONS TO
EXTEND HEALTH CARE TO ALL I URGE
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THIS IS --
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE SSUES THAT --
IS RATHER CONTENTIOUS FOR FOR
SOME OF US -- YOU KNOW THE
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND UNITED
STATES FOR THAT MATTER -- EXISTS.
THERE IS A LEGAL PROCESS THAT
ONE'S GOT ONE GOES THROUGH.
HOW TO BECOME CITIZENS LIKE MY
GRANDPARENTS MY GRANDFATHER FROM
RUSSIA MY GREAT MY GREAT
GRANDMOTHER FROM POLAND MY
GRANDMOTHER FROM CANADA?
THEY CAME TO THIS COUNTRY LIKE.
MANY OF THE HARD WORKING.
IMMIGRANTS SO WE SEE THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY TO TO FIND A
BETTER LIFE FOR THEMSELVES.
AND THE FOR THE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES.
BUT I STILL HAVE SOME SOME
CONCERNS.
ONE WE HAVE A MEDIC HEALTH
SYSTEM I HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM THAT IS COMPLETELY
DYSFUNCTIONAL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
AND WALLEYE.
VERY PROUD OF SERVING ON BUDGETS
OF THREE WHERE WE MADE THE
RECOMMENDATION -- TO REYES THOSE
FEES THAT WERE.
CUT DRAMATICALLY -- BACK IN OUR
GREAT RECESSION.
WHAT WE PAY OUR PHYSICIANS TO
TAKE CARE OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS OR A MEDICAL PROGRAM?
IS STILL STILL SO SUB STANDARD.
THE PHYSICIANS WON'T SIGN UP. TO
TAKE THE PLAN MANY TIMES WE'LL
SEE PATIENTS MANY OF OUR
HUMANITARIAN POSITIONS AND IT
ACOSTA MORE MONEY TO BUILD MEDI
CAL THEN THEY'RE GOING TO GET
BACK FROM MEDI CAL.
AND AND CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THOSE HUMANITARIAN GESTURES.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL NOT TO BE --
HYPOCRITICAL [inaudible]
AND SHOW FAVORITISM TO PEOPLE.
THAT ARE NOT HERE LEGALLY AT THE
EXPENSE OF PEOPLE THAT ARE HERE
LEGALLY. ONE OF THE BIGGER
ISSUES THAT IS GOING TO BE VOTED
ON IN THIS LEGISLATURE IN THIS
LETTER LEGISLATIVE SESSION IS.
RE INSTITUTING A STATE VERSION
OF THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE.
NOW I COULD UNDERSTAND IF.
IF WE WANTED TO IMPOSE A SON.
WEALTHY PEOPLE TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE [inaudible]
APPROPRIATE PREMIUMS.
THROUGH OUR COVER CALIFORNIA BUT
KNOW WHAT ARE WE DOING.
WE'RE CHARGING SIX HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE DOLLARS TO THE LOWER
MIDDLE CLASS AND THE WORKING
CLASS CITIZENS OF THIS STATE.
THAT ARE ALREADY LIVING PAYCHECK
TO PAYCHECK.
WHEN WILL WE RECOGNIZE THAT OUR
CITIZENS THAT ARE HERE IN THE
COUNTRY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA?
DESERVE THE TOP PRIORITY FOR THE
FUNDING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT WE CAN'T
BE PHILANTHROPIC AND TO GIVE
SERVICES.
CAN HELP TO OTHER PEOPLE BUT MY
FRIENDS WE NEED TO TAKE CARE OF
CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE HERE
LEGALLY FIRST.
WE HAVE ROUGHLY A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND HOMELESS PEOPLE
ABOUT SIXTY THOUSAND HOMELESS
PEOPLE JUST LOS ANGELES ALONE.
WE HAVE 25% OF THE NATION'S
HOMELESS VETERANS WHICH TO ME IS
SHAMEFUL.
THERE SHOULD NOT BE A HOMELESS
VETERAN AND ANYWHERE IN THIS
COUNTRY LEVEL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE TEN THOUSAND HOMELESS
VETERANS.
IN AND SPENDING A BILLION STEP
OF SPENDING A BILLION DOLLARS ON
PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT HERE LEGALLY
TO GIVE THEM HEALTHCARE WE
SHOULD TAKE THAT TEN BILLION
DOLLARS.
AND AS A FIRST PRIORITY TAKE
CARE OF THOSE.
TEN THOUSAND VETERANS.
THAT PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
FOR US THEY GAVE A BLANK CHECK.
FOR GOING TO WAR AND ULTIMATELY
POTENTIALLY GIVE THEIR LIVES TO
THE FREEDOMS AND LIBERTIES.
THEY WILL CHERISH.
IT'S BEEN MENTIONED THAT THE
PROCESS OF GETTING IT
CITIZENSHIP IS A VERY ARDUOUS
PROCESS.
IN THE UNITED STATES WELL THERE
WAS A DIFFERENCE WHEN MY
GRANDPARENTS AND GREAT
GRANDPARENTS CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY THE THEY CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY THEY THAT ALL THE LEGAL
PAPERWORK THAT WAS NECESSARY TO
COME IN.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE SEEN WHAT WE
HAVE WITNESSED AT THE BORDER
OVER THE PAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
IS NOT A MIGRATION OF PEOPLE
INTO THIS COUNTRY BUT IT'S BEEN
AN INVASION OF PEOPLE COMING
INTO THIS COUNTRY.
AND HI.
SORRY IF I OFFEND PEOPLE WHEN I
SAY THAT BUT IT IS AN INVASION
OF OUR COUNTRY WHEN YOU DON'T
PROTECT YOUR BORDERS.
WHETHER IT'S PEOPLE FROM THE
SOUTH PEOPLE FOR THE NORTH
PEOPLE FROM THESE PEOPLE FROM
THE WEST.
AND PEOPLE THE STATE
CALIFORNIA'S COUNTRY ARE UPSET
ABOUT AND THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT
TO BE UPSET ABOUT IT.
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH MONEY TO GO
AROUND.
AND WE SHOULD BE PRIORITIZING
THOSE FUNDS. FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE
LEGALLY HERE IN THIS COUNTRY AND
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE.
THAT WANT TO COME TO THIS
COUNTRY. TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS IS LIKE OUR FOREFATHERS
DID IN COMING HERE [inaudible]
LEGALLY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE.
WE HAVE TWENTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN REVENUE COMING INTO
THE STATE.
MONEY THAT WASN'T ANTICIPATED.
AND WE THROW OUT PROGRAMS.
TO HELP THE HOMELESS THE POOR
BROOKS OVER PEOPLE'S HEADS TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE.
AND I THINK IT'S VERY NOBLE THE
WE ARE TRYING TO TAKE CARE OF
PEOPLE LESS FORTUNATE THAN
OURSELVES.
BUT IF WE GO WITH EVEN THE
ASSEMBLY IS VERSION IT'S GOING
TO COST THREE BILLION DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE ANYONE WHO WANTS TO COME
INTO THIS STATE.
WITH FREE MEDICAL CARE.
WITH EBT CARDS TO FEED THEM.
WE ARE GOING TO BE [inaudible]
A MAGNET.
THAT IS GOING TO FURTHER ATTRACT.
PEOPLE. TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS RUNNING TO
WILLING TO WRITE A BLANK CHECK.
TO ANYONE THAT WANTS TO COME
HERE.
AND WHEN WE DELUDE.
OUR ABILITY TO TAKE CARE OF THE
LESS VULNERABLE THAT ARE LEGALLY
HERE.
I BELIEVE THAT WE ARE DOING A
DISSERVICE. TO THE CITIZENS.
THAT LEGALLY CALL CALIFORNIA
HOME THAT ARE NATURALIZED
CITIZENS OF THE UNITED STATES.
I BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD BE
GIVING THOSE CITIZENS THE FIRST
PRIORITY.
DID TWENTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
AND OUR BUDGETARY ACCESSES.
AND IF AFTER WE SPEND THAT MONEY
WE TAKE CARE OF OUR HOMELESS
POPULATIONS WE TAKE CARE OF OUR
VETERANS.
AND WE PROVIDE QUALITY
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
OUR RESPECTIVE OF THEIR OF THEIR
NEEDS THE THEN WE SHOULD.
CONSIDER OUR HUMANITARIAN
EFFORTS.
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT I
RECOMMEND A STRONG NO VOTE IN SB.
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU SENATOR
ATTILA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
WELL AS A VETERAN.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AS THE AS MANIC AMERICAN.
MEXICAN AMERICAN WHATEVER YOU'D
LIKE TO COLLEGE THESE DAYS WE'RE
ALL AMERICANS AND WE WE ARE
AMERICANS WOULD REACH DOWN WE
HELP THOSE THAT NEED HELP.
THAT IS THE FOUNDATION OF THIS
COUNTRY.
AND I THINK THAT WE ARE HERE IN
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THINGS ABOUT EQUALITY INEQUALITY
THINGS THAT ARE FARE THINGS ARE
NOT FAIR BUT WE ALL UNDERSTAND
THIS ONE THING THAT'S ACROSS THE
BOARD WHEN YOU HAVE POOR HEALTH.
IT'S GOING.
TO MEASURE INTO SOMETHING ELSE
POOR HEALTH IS GONNA RESIGNATION
THE SOMETHING ELSE WE HAVE
PEOPLE WHO NEED HELP WE NEED TO
HAVE PEOPLE THAT.
WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT FACT
THAT THEY'RE HERE AND WE'VE GOT
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT TAKING
CARE OF THEIR MEDICAL NEEDS IN
THIS BILL WILL OPEN UP THAT DOOR.
MEDI CAL IS SO IMPORTANT.
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT PEOPLE FROM
NINETEEN TO TWENTY FIVE AND WE
HAVE THE SENIORS THAT ARE SIXTY
FIVE AND ABOVE.
THE THE FACT IS THAT.
THIS BILL WILL START TO FINALLY
DO SOMETHING AND I APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR STANDING UP AND HAVE THE
INTESTINAL FORTITUDE TO FACE THE
OPPOSITION THAT'S GOING TO COME
NO DOUBT.
BUT OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE SO MANY
MORE OF US THAT REALIZE THAT
WE'VE GOT TO TAKE CARE OF SO
MANY.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT WE'RE
RESPONSIBLE AND WE NEED TO TAKE
THAT RESPONSIBILITY SERIOUSLY.
AND I KNOW IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO
BE AN AMERICAN THERE'S NO DOUBT
BUT WITH THAT PRIVILEGE COMES
RESPONSIBILITY SO LET'S TAKE
THIS ON AS A RESPONSIBLE BILL.
AND I KNOW THAT A MY CONCERN AND
I WILL SHARE THIS IS THE THE
ESCALATION OF TIME.
BUT THAT ESCALATION WILL BRING
IN SOME OF THE OTHER NEGATIVE
WHERE EVENTUALLY I HOPE THAT
WE'LL BE ABLE.
TO INSURE EVERYONE AND WHEN
WE'RE ABLE TO DO THAT AND I
THINK WE CAN ACTUALLY SAY THAT
WERE COMING TOGETHER.
AND SO I HOPE ALL OF US CAN
EXPLORE THE OPTIONS OF LATER
EXPANDING THIS TO INCLUDE
EVERYONE.
AND AND I THINK THAT THIS IS OUR
TIME.
THIS IS THE TWENTY NINETEEN
THEIR ISSUES OUT THERE BUT
THERE'S NO GREATER ISSUE THAN
HEALTH FOR CALIFORNIA POPULATION
IN THIS IS THE FIRST STEP.
SO I URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL.
MISTER PRESIDENT I HAVE TO SAY
THAT I AMNEVER CEASE TO BE
AMAZED AS A SITTING MEMBER THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
AND THAT EVEN IS LIFE AS A BLACK
WOMAN FIFTY FOUR YEARS FIFTY
FIVE IN SEPTEMBER.
I HAD TO COME TO THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE. TO HEAR SOME OF THE
MOST RACIST CLASSES BANTER IN MY
ENTIRE LIFE.
THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT
PROVIDING HEALTHCARE TO ALL IS
NOT NEW.
IF YOU REFER TO THE FLOOR NOW
SINCE WE AT LEAST SINCE I'VE
BEEN HERE HAD THE SPECIFIC
CONVERSATION BUT DATING BACK.
TO TWENTY FOURTEEN SO WE CAN
SEPARATE THE DISCUSSION.
BETWEEN WHAT'S COST EFFECTIVE
AND EFFICIENT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WHO'S WORTHY.
I APPRECIATE MONDAY WAS VETERANS
DAY -- AND WE LIKE TO SPEND A
LOT OF TIME TALKING ABOUT WHAT
VETERANS SHOULD BE DO.
AND ISUPPORT THAT BUT DO YOU
REALLY THINK THAT ANYBODY
DESERVES TO BE HOMELESS.
VETERAN OR OTHERWISE.
I'M NOT GOING TO PRIORITIZE A
VETERAN OVER ANYONE ELSE'S
HOMELESS.
POINT BLANK.
HOMELESS IS HOMELESS.
AND IT'S MORALLY OFFENSIVE.
THE TO THE ISSUE OF SB.
TWENTY NINE WE ARE TALKING
COLLEAGUES.
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE OF FORTY MILLION.
THIS BILL WILL ADDRESS.
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND OUT OF FORTY MILLION.
PEOPLE WHO ARE ARE NOT IMMUNE TO
GETTING SICK THEY WILL GET SICK.
THEY WILL SIX SERVICES WE WILL
PAY FOR THEM.
THE QUESTION IS WILL WE PAY FOR
THEM AND PROVIDE THE SERVICE.
IN THE MOST APPROPRIATE.
LEAST COSTLY SETTING.
WHAT'S THE EMERGENCY ROOM AND
YOUR COUNTIES IS NOT.
WHAT ARE WE DOING FOR THE
CITIZENS THE MIDDLE CLASS
CITIZENS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'LL TELL YOU WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO IN THE IN THE
SENATE BUDGET? ONE POINT THREE
MILLION OF THEM.
WHO ARE OF MIDDLE CLASS INCOME
WE'RE GOING TO RECEIVE A SUBSIDY
TO HELP THEM WITH THEIR COVERED
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
WICKS PREMIUM. ONE POINT THREE
MILLION ARE GONNA GET HELP OUT
OF YOUR CALIFORNIA BUDGET
[inaudible]
AN INVASION.
IT'S INTRIGUING TO ME THAT
AGGRESSIVE WORDS LIKE INVASION
ARE ONLY USED IN REFERENCE.
TO IMMIGRANTS COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY TODAY AND I'M ASSUMING
WE'RE REFERRING TO PEOPLE OF
COLOR COMPARED TO WIN SOME
PEOPLE FOR FATHERS IN FOR
MOTHERS CAME THE LEGAL ROUTE.
IT WASN'T AN INVASION THEN.
THAT'S CURIOUS TO ME.
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW THIS COUNTRY
WAS BUILT. TO THE INVASION OF
PEOPLE FROM OTHER COUNTRIES.
MISTER PRESIDENT I WILL GO BACK
FOUR HUNDRED YEARS BUT IT WAS AN
INVASION OF BLACK PEOPLE WHO
WERE BROUGHT HERE AGAINST THEIR
WILL.
THAT WAS INDEED INVASION.
SO.
I TRIED TO TEMPER MY VISCERAL
RESPONSE TO VISCERAL WORDS.
SO LET ME SIMPLY SAY.
THAT I WOULD ARGUE AGAINST THE
NOTION.
THAT THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM IS
COMPLETELY DYSFUNCTIONAL IT
SERVES ONE IN THREE CALIFORNIANS
WHICH MEANS IT'S SERVING PEOPLE
IN ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS.
BABIES ARE BEING BORN -- UP
PEOPLE'S CONDEMN THE PEOPLE
BEING HOSPITALIZED OF PEOPLE ARE
RECEIVING TREATMENT THROUGH ONE
OF THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE
[inaudible]
MEDICAL.
PROGRAMS IN THE COUNTRY.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LARGEST
MEDICAID SYSTEM IN THE COUNTRY.
COULD BE IMPROVED YES ARE WE
DOING A BETTER JOB EVERY YEAR OF
DOING THAT ABSOLUTELY.
ARE WE NOW TO THIS BUDGET ADDING
BACK IMPORTANT SERVICES TO FOR
MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES WE ARE.
IT SERVES ONE IN THREE WHICH
MEANS IT SERVES YOUR
CONSTITUENTS.
AND MINE.
THROUGH POP OF THE SIX AND THE
WORK THAT WE'RE GONNA DO WE GET
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
WE HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED THE FACT
THAT MEDI CAL PROVIDERS ARE AN
INTEGRAL.
PART OF THE DELIVERY OF THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM ACROSS THE
STATE.
THEY TOO ARE RECEIVING -- THE
BOUNTY OF A HEALTHIER GENERAL
FUND AND THEIR REIMBURSEMENT
RATES ARE INCREASING.
SO WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE US IT
LEADS US BACK TO THE POINT.
OF WHO IS WORTH THE INVESTMENT.
THIS NOTION THAT ONE GROUP OF
IMMIGRANTS IS MORE WORTHY THAN
THE OTHER IS A PHENOMENON TO ME.
BUT LET'S BE CLEAR IF YOU HEARD.
OF THE OFFICE PRESENTATION ABOUT
WHO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA WHO WORK
EVERY DAY -- WORK WITH US FOR US
ON BEHALF OF US.
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM IN IT IN A STATE
OF FORTY MILLION THAT NEEDS ALL
THE HELP WE CAN GET.
SO SENATE MITCHELL YOU BE
SUPPORTING SB TWENTY NINE I WILL.
WHY SENATOR MITCHELL?
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT
HEALTHCARE IS A FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT.
AND THAT WE'RE EXPANDING.
SERVICES TO A POPULATION THAT
BUT FOR THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS
WOULD QUALIFY FOR THE PROGRAM
BASED ON THEIR INCOME.
I WOULD LIKE TO BE OPTIMISTIC
ENOUGH TO THINK THAT WE COULD
INVOLVE AS A PEOPLE AS A BODY.
TO THINK FACTUALLY.
ABOUT THE NEEDS OF THE RESIDENTS
THAT WE ALL REPRESENT IN SIR.
THE THING FACTUALLY ABOUT THE
HEALTH NEEDS OF ALL OF THE
RESIDENTS WE SERVE.
WE'VE HAD VERY HEATED DEBATE ON
THIS FLOOR AROUND [inaudible]
BOB IMMUNIZATIONS.
AND AND VERY.
HEATED DISCUSSION ABOUT
[inaudible]
WHAT?
PORTION OF THE POPULATION NEEDS
TO BE IMMUNIZED PROVIDE MASS
COVERAGE FOR EVERYONE ELSE.
DOES ANYONE HERE HAVE A GENERAL
IDEA OF THE WILL OF THE STATE
WORKING BUDGET OF OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
IT'S NOT AS HIGH AS IT SHOULD BE.
THE ONLY TALK ABOUT PROVIDING
COR.
HEALTH BENEFITS. TO A SEGMENT OF
THE POPULATION THAT WORKS EVERY
DAY.
HERE IN OUR STATE A SEGMENT OF
THE POPULATION AT ONE POINT IN
TIME WAS INVITED TO THE STATE TO
COME WORK BECAUSE THERE WEREN'T
ENOUGH PEOPLE DO THE WORK.
WE SHOULD BE MINDFUL.
OF OUR OVERALL RESPONSIBILITY
ABOUT PROVIDING.
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. TO
INCREASE THE OVERALL HEALTH
STATUS.
OF EVERYONE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. FOR THOSE REASONS
AND MANY MORE -- I WAS PROUD
THAT.
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS WE
INCLUDED EVERY ELEMENT THAT'S IN
THIS BILL I UNDERSTAND THE
AUTHOR AMENDED HER B. L. AFTER
THE SENATE VOTED ON THEIR BUDGET.
THE SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE VOTE
ON THE BUDGET AND SO IT'S IN
ALIGNMENT TO WHAT CAME OUT OF
THE SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE. FOR
THOSE REASONS I'LL BE SUPPORTING
SB.
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU SENATOR --
TODDLE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB --
TWENTY NINE WITHOUT THIS BILL.
MY CONSISTENT MY CONSTITUENTS
WILL BE DEEPLY IMPACTED MY
COUNTIES FRESNO TO LARRY KING
AND KERN HAVE THE HIGHEST RATES
OF MEDICAL ENROLLMENT.
MY CONSTITUENTS ARE CONSISTENT
CONSISTENTLY RELEGATED TO
EMERGENCY ROOM CARE AFTER BOTH
COMMUNITIES WITH AND WITHOUT
COVERAGE MANY ARE FORCED TO
TRAVEL OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
CARE.
WE CANNOT GET THE CARE THAT THEY
NEED IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
BECAUSE OF LACK OF DOCTORS
WILLING TO A SET MEDI CAL
PATIENTS.
SO I AM CLEAR THAT.
THIS WILL NOT ADDRESS OUR
NETWORK ADEQUACY ISSUES BUT IT
WILL HELP MY CONSTITUENTS GET
THE PREVENTATIVE CARE THEY NEED
TO HELP AVOID A MORE SERIOUS
HEALTH CRISIS.
I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU ALL THAT
HEALTH COVERAGE ACTUALLY HELP
STIMULATE OUR STATE'S ECONOMY AS
IT DID IN THE PERIOD AFTER THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT RECESSION
WHEN THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
PASSED.
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO THINK ABOUT
YOUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HOW NOT
COVERING THIS POPULATION WILL
IMPACT OUR HOSPITALS.
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY ONE PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS ARE THE
COURT THE STATE'S HEALTH CARE
SAFETY NET DELIVERING HIGH
QUALITY CARE TO ALL.
WHO NEED IT REGARDLESS OF
ABILITY TO PAY OR INSURANCE
STATUS?
MOST PATIENTS IN A PUBLIC HEALTH
CARE SYSTEMS ARE EITHER MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES OR REMAIN
UNINSURED.
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS
PROVIDE NEARLY THIRTY AND 40% OF
HOSPITAL CARE TO THE STATE'S
MEDI CAL AN UNINSURED
POPULATIONS.
RESPECTIVELY AND PROVIDE OVER
TEN MILLION OUTPATIENT VISITS
EACH YEAR.
ALTHOUGH WE'D LIKE TO COVER AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE COVERED
EVEN A PORTION OF OUR
UNDOCUMENTED SENIORS OR YOUTH
WOULD BE COMPARABLE TO THE COST
OF COVERING CHILDREN UNDER THE
AGE OF NINETEEN LIKE WE DID IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN OR WHAT WE PAY
FOR AND COUNTY COMPENSATED CARE.
AND FOR THESE REASONS.
I'D LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR.
FOR TAKING ON THIS.
THIS BILL AND TRYING TO EXPAND
HEALTH CARE FOR MORE PEOPLE IN
THE STATE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BILL.
MEMBERS SO WE OUGHT TO LOOK AT
THE SPECIFIC PROPOSAL THAT WE
ARE -- CONSIDERING HERE TODAY
[inaudible]
AND TWO CLASSES OF UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS WILL BE ELIGIBLE. FOR
OUR MEDICAL SYSTEM [inaudible]
THE SENIORS.
AND A YOUNG ADULTS.
AND I WANT TO ADDRESS -- HER TO
GET FROM -- FISCAL STANDPOINT
BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION.
THE FIRST THING I TO SAY IS THIS.
IF YOU'RE A SENIOR AND YOUR ON
DOCUMENT YOU ARE NOT GETTING
MEDICARE.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING MEDICARE
[inaudible]
HOWEVER.
IF YOU ARE A SENIOR.
AND HAVE LIVED IN STATE A
CALIFORNIA UNITED STATES.
AND HAVE WORKED.
YOU ARE PAYING IN TO MEDICARE
[inaudible]
AND THEREFORE.
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH A LOT OF
THE SENIORS THAT ARE NOW.
BEING REQUESTED TO RECEIVE OUR
MEDICAL SYSTEM.
IS THEY'VE BEEN PAYING INTO THE
MEDICARE SYSTEM. FOR ALL THE
REST OF US.
WE ARE BEING SUBSIDIZED BY THEM.
WE ARE BEING SUBSIDIZED BY THEM
THEY ARE PAYING FOR OUR MEDICARE.
BUT THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
RECEIVE MEDICARE.
SO I HINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE LOOK AT THINGS IN A VERY --
LOGICAL WAY.
SOME PEOPLE THINK THAT THE
ESTIMATED [inaudible]
UNDOCUMENTED.
REVENUE COMING INTO THE MEDICARE
SYSTEM IS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THIS PALES IN COMPARISON TO THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IN THIS
BUDGET. TO PAY FOR THE SENIORS
AND THE YOUNG ADULTS COMING INTO
THE THIS MEDI CAL SYSTEM.
IN FACT WE'RE ALSO ALREADY
PAYING FOR THE HEALTHCARE.
AS POINTED OUT BY.
THE WORK THAT WE DO IN OUR LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS ARE
EMERGENCY ROOMS RE.
CLINICS WHICH OFTEN TIME WITHOUT
CHARGE PROVIDE THE MEDICAL CARE.
THESE ARE ON COVERED OF
UNREIMBURSED EXPENSES BY THESE
CLINICS WHICH IS NOT A GOOD
THING.
SO I HIRED SUPPORT FOR THIS I
THINK THAT.
THE MONEY THAT IS PAID INTO THE
MEDICARE SYSTEM.
BY PEOPLE THAT ARE UNDOCUMENTED
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED.
HAS THERE PAYMENT OF TAXES.
THAT THEY ARE NOT GETTING ANY
BENEFIT FROM.
AND THEREFORE WE ARE OBLIGATED.
TO REIMBURSE THEM.
BY CREATING A SYSTEM OF HEALTH
CARE FOR THEM.
THAT SAVES NOT REALLY THEM MONEY
BUT SAVES US MONEY AND RESULTS
AN A A STRONGER HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. FOR ALL OF US.
YOU KNOW THIS OF LAST WEEKEND
WAS MEMORIAL DAY AND AS USUAL --
OUR FAMILY WENT TO MY YEAH IT'S
A GREAT.
AND YOU KNOW MY DAD WAS A
PARATROOPER AND MORE WORK.
TO AND HE TOLD THAT HE FOUGHT
WILL WORK TO FOR LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
AND HERE I THIS ASPIRATIONAL
VIEW [inaudible]
AND SUPPORTED.
TAKING CARE OF ALL THE PEOPLE IN
UNITED STATES.
THAT'S WHAT A TRUE PATRIOT IS.
AND WE THINK ABOUT IT WE DON'T
TALK ABOUT INVASIONS ON OUR
BORDERS WE DON'T TALK ABOUT --
IN A PATRIOTIC SINCE INVASION ON
OUR BORDERS.
BECAUSE INVITATIONS ON OUR
BORDERS IS NOT THE KIND OF
PATRIOTISM.
THAT MY FAMILY OF SCRIBES.
TO AND MY FAMILY.
GOES BACK TO THE OFFICER THAT WE
HAD IN MY FAMILY DURING THE
REVOLUTIONARY WAR.
WITH GEORGE WASHINGTON.
SO OUR FAMILY OUR FAMILY IS A
VERY PATRIOTIC FAMILY.
AND WE BELIEVE IN LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL [inaudible]
PEOPLE.
AND WE DON'T BELIEVE IN GETTING.
OUR HEALTHCARE SERVICE ON THE
BACKS OF OTHER PEOPLE.
AND THAT'S THE ISSUE HERE I URGE
AN AYE VOTE.
LET'S PASS THIS MEASURE
[inaudible]
SENATOR ALL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
WE TAKE A QUESTION SENATOR
RUSSELL YES GRETA.
THING WAS PRESIDENT CENTER YOUR
BILL CONTAINS SOME ASPIRATIONAL
LANGUAGE ABOUT.
EVENTUALLY HOPEFULLY --
EXPANDING COVERAGE TO THOSE IN
THE TWENTY SIX TO SIXTY FOUR
YEAR OLD GROUP.
AND I JUST OF YOU MAY HAVE
MENTIONED THIS AND PERHAPS I
MISSED IT I JUST WANT.
TO MAKE SURE I'M CLEAR IS IT
CORRECT THAT.
ANY SUCH EXPANSION WILL REQUIRE
FURTHER.
ACTION BY THIS LEGISLATURE IN
THE FORM OF A BUDGETARY
APPROPRIATION ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU ON MY OWN TIME.
GRETA THING WAS PRESIDENT -- I'M
A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS -- OF
THIS MEASURE -- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY.
AND I CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE OF THE
REST OF YOU TO DO THE SAME THANK
YOU [inaudible]
Q. [inaudible]
SENATOR PAT.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
SENATORS SITE TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND I WANNA THANK
MY GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS ANGELES
FOR BRING IT FORWARD -- WE WE
LOOK WITH CERTAINLY WE'VE TALKED
A LOT ABOUT THIS -- THIS BILL
AND WE'VE HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS
HERE ON THE FLOOR OF THE SENATE
AND IN OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE IN FACT -- THE
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE UNINSURED -- ACTUALLY DIE.
AND EARLIER AGE THEY'RE MORE
LIKELY TO GET ILLNESSES -- BUT
CERTAINLY IF THE HUMANITARIAN
REASONS AREN'T THE ONES ENOUGH
TO COMPEL PEOPLE TO VOTE FOR
THIS BILL ALTHOUGH I HOPE
CERTAINLY THAT IN ITSELF SHOULD
BE.
ENOUGH OF A REASON I WOULD ALSO
ARGUE THAT YOU SHOULD VOTE FOR
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT IS IN YOUR
SELF INTEREST IN THE SELF
INTEREST OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS --
AS WHEN WE EX WELL FIRST OF ALL
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY IN AND IT'S
BEEN RESET HERE BUT I JUST HAVE
TO BRIEFLY SAY AGAIN IS IS THAT --
PEOPLE WHO HAVE HEALTH CARE
NEEDS -- WELL EVENTUALLY WE WILL
EVENTUALLY PAY FOR THEM NOW
USUALLY WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT WE
PAY FOR THEM TO GET A LOT WORSE
WE PAY THEM FOR THEM IN A MUCH
LESS EFFICIENT MANNER -- FOR
EXAMPLE -- I USE OF EMERGENCY
ROOMS -- HOSPITALIZATIONS --
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO AS MUCH TO PRIMARY CARE TO
OTHER -- PREVENTIVE MEASURES
THINGS THAT WOULD ALLOW PEOPLE
TO GET CARE IN A MORE COST
EFFICIENT AND HIGH -- AND AND
MORE EFFECTIVE MANNER.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE DOING IS IS
THAT WE'RE NOT REALLY.
REALLY SAVING MONEY PER SE TO
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS IS THAT WERE
BASICALLY.
SAYING THAT WELL WE'RE GOING TO
THE NIGHT CHAIR UNTIL YOU GET
REALLY REALLY SICK AND THEN --
WILL SPEND A LOT OF MONEY TRYING
TO SAVE YOU -- AND I'M NOT SURE
THAT IS NECESSARILY THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY OF GOING ABOUT IT
IN FACT IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
WE ARE READY HEY.
THROUGH OUR BUDGET THROUGH OTHER
MEANS -- WE COUNT ON WE HAVE A
COUNTIES REQUIRED THROUGH --
THERE'S INDIGENT CARE PROGRAMS --
TO PROVIDE CARE OUR CLINICS --
ACTUALLY OUR FELLOW QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS THE HAVE TO TAKE
ALL COMERS ALTHOUGH ON A SLIDING
SCALE -- AND THIS MAKES THE
HOWARD [inaudible]
BASICALLY.
THIS IS A BAY AREA THOUGH TO
PEOPLE GETTING CARE UNTIL THEY
REALLY NEED IT.
THE A IN ADDITION OF COURSE WE
TALK ABOUT A LACK OF SPECIALTY
CARE ACCESS AS WELL SO THAT
SOMEONE GETS BUT YET THEY WILL
GET IT EVENTUALLY -- WHEN THEY
SHOP THE MERCHANTS ROOM WHEN
THEY GET HOSPITALIZED AND THEN
THAT COST BECAUSE IT CANNOT BE
BORNE BY THAT INDIVIDUAL OR THE
FAMILY?
HARD AS IT MAY TRY TO ACTUALLY
DO THAT THEN GETS DISTRIBUTED
AMONG ALL OF US.
IN FACT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS
BEFORE WE IMPLEMENTED THE ACA --
WE WERE LOOKING AT HOW MUCH DOES
EACH.
PRIVATELY SHIRT PERSON -- HAVE
TO PAY TO HELP PAY FOR ALL THE
CARE FOR THE PEOPLE ARE
UNINSURED -- AND THAT TURNED OUT
TO BE ABOUT A THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER PERSON -- WHO HAD PRIVATE
INSURANCE?
SO WE ARE PAYING FOR THAT I
SHOULD ALSO POINT OUT BY THE WAY
THAT ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE
UNINSURED -- ABOUT 40% CURRENTLY
AFTER WE INFLATED CA ARE A
DOCUMENT SO I SEE MAJORITY OF
UNINSURED ARE ACTUALLY NOT THE
UNDOCUMENTED.
BUT CERTAINLY IT IS IN OUR SELF
INTERESTS TO SAY YOU KNOW WHAT
MAYBE WE SHOULD MAKE MORE
EFFECTIVE USE OF OUR HEALTHCARE
DOLLARS.
WE SHOULD ALSO THINK ABOUT THE
SOCIETAL COSTS THAT HAVING
PEOPLE LEAVING.
THE NINE CARE TO PEOPLE LEAVING
THEM UNINSURED ALSO ARE COSTS US
IN SOCIAL SERVICES AND OTHER
TYPES OF THINGS THE LOST
PRODUCTIVITY IN OUR WORKPLACES --
WE TALK ABOUT MEDI CAL OF
ACTUALLY ASIDE FROM THE CHILDREN
WHICH ARE HALF OF ALL MEDICARE
OUR FATE.
THAT HALF OF ALL CHILDREN MEDI
CAL AND OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
DISABLED -- MOST OF THE PEOPLE
ARE MEDI CAL ACTUALLY WORK.
THEY WORK AND SO -- THEY'RE
PAYING TAXES YOU'RE CONTRIBUTING --
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THERE ACTUALLY
THEIR PRODUCTIVITY AND ABILITY
CAN BE HAMPERED BECAUSE OF
ILLNESS IN THE FAMILY
[inaudible]
SO.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE REASON TO
VOTE FOR THE BILL IS NOT FEWER
HUMANITARIAN REASONS.
WHICH I HAVE -- IF THAT'S NOT
COMPELLING ENOUGH IT IS ACTUALLY
IN OUR BEST INTEREST TO SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT WE SHOULD ACTUALLY
MAKE THE MOST EFFECTIVE USE OF
OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS WE SHOULD
ACTUALLY SEEK TO MAKE EVERY
PERSON IN CALIFORNIA AS
PRODUCTIVE AS POSSIBLE.
AND WE SHOULD ALSO TRY THE
LATEST SEEK TO LIGHTEN THE LOAD
ON OUR SOCIAL SERVICES THAT ARE
TAXPAYERS ALSO [inaudible]
HEY.
FOR AND SO WITH THAT I URGE IN
AYE VOTES ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL
BOTH BECAUSE IT IS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
BUT ALSO BECAUSE IT'S IN ALL OF
OUR SELF INTEREST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR GRANT SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU -- WELL FIRST OF ALL I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES FOR BRINGING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL FORWARD.
I WHAT I DON'T WANT TO DO IS
BELABOR THE POINT THAT ALL MY
COLLEAGUES HERE HAVE EXPRESSED
AS A PERTAINS TO THE BACK BASIC
RIGHT OF INDIVIDUALS TO BE
HEALTHY IN OUR STATE.
BUT I WILL SAY THIS.
WHEN IT COMES TO HEALTH CARE I
FIND IT OFFENSIVE THAT IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY? TO MISREPRESENT
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS.
AND AS YOU ALL KNOW I STAND
BEFORE YOU AS AN UNDOCUMENTED.
SUPPORT IT.
SENATOR IN THE SAME ROOM YOU'RE
ALL SET.
AND WHEN I HEAR WORDS LIKE
[inaudible]
INVASION.
IT REALLY IS OFFENSIVE.
AND I WANT MY COLLEAGUES TO LOOK
AT WHAT.
SOMEONE LOOKS LIKE WHEN GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY.
NOT ONLY FOR A GOOD EDUCATION.
GOOD HEALTH CARE.
AND SO I WILL SAY TO MY
COLLEAGUE TODAY THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT.
BUT I HOPE THAT WE STOP.
CONFUSING THE TWO HEALTH CARE IS
NOT PERMISSION. TO BASH OR
MISREPRESENT UNDOCUMENTED.
IMMIGRANT INDIVIDUALS I FIND IT
PERSONALLY OFFENSIVE AND I HOPE
THAT THAT.
STOPS THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
THAT I WILL BE VOTING YES.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES -- WELL I A WILL NOT
EVEN ATTEMPT TO BE AS ELOQUENT
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
LOS ANGELES.
IN RELATIONSHIP TO THE REACTION
FROM SOME OF THE FLOOR COMMENTS
THAT WE HEARD EARLIER.
I WANT TO ECHO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO.
AND WHILE I COMPLETELY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
PURELY AND SOLELY BECAUSE IT IS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
I THINK THOSE THAT MAY HAVE
EXPRESSED OR FEEL SOME OF THESE
NATIONALISTIC OR XENA PHOBIC
FEELINGS.
SHOULD THINK ABOUT THE IMPACT ON
THE REST OF THE POPULATION WHICH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO
REFERENCED.
NOT ADDRESS BENEFIT FROM PEOPLE
WITH COMMUNICABLE.
DISEASES OR TREATABLE INFECTIONS
HAVING THEM AND BEING AROUND OR
NEAR US.
THIS IS WHY WE HAVE TIGHTENED UP.
THE MEDICAL EXEMPTION AROUND
VACCINATIONS BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTOOD THAT.
WE NEEDED VACCINATIONS FOR OUR
GOOD PUBLIC HEALTH OF EVERYONE.
SO IF WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON
ABLE.
BECAUSE OF LACK OF THE OUR
COVERAGE OF HEALTHCARE. TO GET
TREATED FOR EXAMPLE OR EVEN GO
AND FIND OUT THAT THEY MIGHT
HAVE TUBERCULOSIS.
AND I SAY TUBERCULOSIS BECAUSE
IT IS A MUCH MORE COMMON.
DISEASE AMONG LOW INCOME PEOPLE.
AND OF COURSE MUCH OF THE
POPULATION THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT HERE THESE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND THAT WE
MIGHT CONSIDER FOR THIS WOULD BE
COVERED UNDER THIS BILL.
OUR LOW INCOME.
IN CALIFORNIA HAS HIGH RATES OF
TUBERCULOSIS.
IT IS A VERY CAN RECALL DISEASE.
SEVEN FACTIONS MERCER.
NONE OF US WANT.
ANYONE IN OUR COMMUNITIES OUR
SCHOOLS.
OUR WORK PLACES. TO GET ANY OF
THESE.
IN YET OUR REFUSAL TO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE.
COULD CAUSE THAT.
SO JUST FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
POINT OF VIEW THIS BILL MAKES
SENSE.
NOW LET ME ALSO TALK ABOUT THE
BUDGETARY.
IT IS FALSE FISCAL PRUDENCE TO
TALK ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE
COST ON THIS.
AND WHAT OTHER THINGS WE MAY BE
ARE SAYING NO.
TO JOHN HOPKINS UNIVERSITY ALONE
[inaudible]
ESTIMATES THAT.
THE EMERGENCY ROOM CHARGES.
THAT MAY RESULT FROM A PERSON'S
LACK OF HEALTH CARE.
SEE THE MEDICAL MEDI CAL COST
FOR APPROPRIATE TREATMENT BY
THIRTEEN TIMES.
SO EACH INDIVIDUAL THAT WE DO
NOT COVER THAT INSTEAD USES AN
EMERGENCY ROOM.
IT'S COSTING US THIRTEEN TIMES
WHAT IT WOULD COST THEM US.
AND ALL CALIFORNIANS FOR JUST
PROVIDING WHAT'S IN THIS BILL
[inaudible]
ADDITIONALLY.
THE MEDIAN COST OF THE ROOM
VISIT IN CALIFORNIA IS TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT'S THE
MEDIA [inaudible]
SO.
JUST FROM A FISCAL POINT OF VIEW
THIS BILL MAKES SENSE.
BUT FROM A MORAL POINT OF VIEW
IT IS ABSOLUTELY.
THE ONLY AND RIGHT THING TO DO
[inaudible]
CENTER MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
I AM A ONE OF THE FEW IMMIGRANTS
ON THE FLOOR.
I'LL LEAVE THAT SUBJECT ALONE
FOR NOW.
BUT I ALSO HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
SERVING ON THE CAL OPTIMA BOARD
FOR FOUR YEARS I COUNTY OPERATED
HEALTH SYSTEM AND IT TOOK QUITE
SOME TIME FOR THE STATE TO
FINALLY GET US THE NECESSARY AND
ADEQUATE FUNDING THAT WE NEEDED.
SO I'M CONCERNED MISTER
PRESIDENT FROM A COST STANDPOINT
AND I WILL.
ADDRESS IT.
OF FROM MY PERSPECTIVE -- WE'RE
LOOKING AT THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR.
THE GENERAL FUND AND WE'VE BEEN
HERE FOR A WEEK AND A HALF NOW
AND WE'VE APPROVED A LOT OF
BILLS WITH A LOT OF HIGH TICKET.
NUMBERS.
IF WE'RE GOING TO DO BOND
MEASURES -- WE HAVE TO FIND FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR AND
THAT'S A CONSTITUTIONAL
REQUIREMENT THAT THAT BE PAID.
SO THAT'S GOING TO SQUEEZE OUT A
LOT OF OTHER -- IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS AND I'M LOOKING AT THE
CURRENTLY THAT [inaudible]
ANNUAL.
FINANCIAL AUDITS FROM ALL OF OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN AND
COLLEAGUES THE NUMBERS ARE
REALLY SCARY -- THIS YEAR.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAD TO INCLUDE
IN THEIR LIABILITIES THEY'RE
UNFUNDED RETIREE MEDICAL -- LA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THERE
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT. FOR
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE MILLION.
BUT FOR THE NEW LAST REPORT THAT
JUST CAME OUT THERE
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORT.
IT'S IT'S ONE BILLION.
THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS IT IT IT'S
GONE UP FOUR HUNDRED AND NINETY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE OF
THE RETIREE MEDICAL WE'RE
LOOKING AT SOME SERIOUS.
COST COMING OUR WAY.
AS A BODY.
THAT HAS TO LOOK AT BUDGETS FOR
MANY YEARS. ONE THING ABOUT
BEING A LITTLE OLDER.
IS THAT YOU YOU KIND OF SEE HOW
PEOPLE LOOK AT YESTERDAY.
S. TODAY WILL BE TOMORROW.
AND IF WE HAD A GOOD BUDGET.
LAST YEAR AND WE HAVE TWENTY ONE
AND A HALF BILLION MISS YOUR
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE TWENTY ONE
AND A HALF BLLION NEXT YEAR.
AND AND COLLEAGUES I JUST WANNA
TELL YOU THAT THAT'S NOT THE
CASE RECESSIONS HAPPEN.
AND SO WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW
DO WE TAKE ON THESE COSTS.
AND HOW DO WE MAKE SURE WE KEEP
THEM IN THE BUDGET.
IN YEARS MOVING FORWARD SO I I
AM HERE TO CAUTION YOU.
FROM A BUDGET PERSPECTIVE.
THAT CUMULATIVELY THIS COULD BE
VERY DIFFICULT WHAT ABOUT OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS THEY'RE
RELIANT ON OUR GENERAL.
FIND WHAT WHAT GETS SQUEEZED
INTO RECESSION GOING FORWARD SO
WITH THAT.
MISTER PRESIDENT I AM VOTING NO
ON S. B..
TWENTY NINE THE QUEUE SENATOR
LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
YOU KNOW MEMBERS ONE OF THE
GREAT THINGS ABOUT THIS JOB IS
OUR LIFE EXPERIENCE THAT WE ALL
BRING HERE TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
AND FOR ME HEALTH CARE IS
PERSONAL IT'S SOMETHING THAT
I'VE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
FIGHTING -- FOR FOR TWENTY YEARS
BEFORE I CAME TO THE SENATE
FLOOR AS A LABOR LEADER.
I REPRESENT A GROCERY STORE
WORKERS AND I REMEMBER A LOT OF
TIMES PEOPLE USED TO SAY TO ME
COUNTY YOU REPRESENT WORKERS
THEY'RE NOT ALL HERE LEGALLY.
AND I SAID YOU KNOW WHAT THAT'S
NOT MY JOB TO FIGURE OUT WHO'S
HERE LEGALLY AND WHO ISN'T HERE
ILLEGALLY MY JOB IS TO REPRESENT
THOSE WORKERS THAT WORK AT THAT
WORK SITE.
IN 200-036-2000 GROCERY WORKERS
WENT ON STRIKE TO KEEP THEIR
FORCIBLE HEALTH CARE GUESS WHAT.
ALL OF THEM WERE HERE LEGALLY
BUT THEY WERE OUT THERE FIGHTING
FOR THEMSELVES.
AND FOR THE CO WORKERS.
WHEN THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WAS
PASSED IN WASHINGTON AND COVER
CALIFORNIA STARTED?
WE AT MY LOCAL UNION ALL BECAME
NAVIGATORS BECAUSE WE WANTED TO
HELP COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAVE
HEALTH CARE. FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE
CAME TO UFCW LOCAL FOURTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT AND WE SIGNED THEM
UP.
I DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF YOU HAVE
BEEN AROUND PEOPLE WHO HAVEN'T
HAD HEALTH CARE FOR TWENTY YEARS.
THEY DON'T LOOK LIKE YOU AND I
THEY DON'T LOOK VERY HEALTHY
THEY'RE NOT IN GOOD SHAPE.
OUR JOB AND OUR RESPONSIBILITY
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
WHETHER THEY'RE HERE LEGALLY OR
NOT HAS ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
BECAUSE I THINK OF US HERE ON
THE SENATE FLOOR THERE'S FORTY
OF US.
AND IF NOT US.
THEN WHO.
IF NOT NOW.
THEN WHEN.
WHEN WE DECIDE THAT ALL HUMAN
BEINGS MATTER THAT ALL HUMAN
BEINGS BRING SOMETHING AND
CONTRIBUTE SOMETHING TO OUR
SOCIETY?
I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING IT
FORWARD AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
IT TODAY.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
SHE IN ORDER BATES.
I THINK YOU MEANT ROSA MISTER
PRESIDENT SORRY ARE.
THE DEBATE ALWAYS SEEMS TO FOCUS
ON THE EMOTIONAL ISSUE OF
IMMIGRATION ANDI'D LIKE TO KIND
OF SET THAT ASIDE AND SHARE A
LIFE EXPERIENCE I BEGAN AS A
SOCIAL WORKER IN THE EARLY
SIXTIES AT THAT TIME.
I WAS THE SUPERVISING CASE
WORKER WHEN MEDI CAL WAS
INTRODUCED IT DID HAVE A ROOT
RESIDENCY REQUIREMENT OR TO HAVE
A CITIZENSHIP REQUIREMENT AT
THAT TIME.
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE NEEDED TO
BE PROVIDING ABOUT TIED TO THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE -- THE IT
HAS MORPHED OVER THE YEARS -- MY
PROBLEM WITH THAT IS VERY SIMPLY
THAT THERE'S AN ACCESS ISSUE IN
OUR AND COMPLETELY SUPPORT THOSE
WHOSE MESSAGE HAS BEEN ABOUT
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
OUR I HAVE A BROTHER WHO'S VERY
ILL WE'VE BEEN AN EMERGENCY ROOM
TWICE IN THE LAST MONTH.
I WILL SHARE WITH YOU THE
SERVICE IS POOR.
IT IS POOR BECAUSE THE
AVAILABILITY OF A SPECIALIST IN
THE EMERGENCY ROOM AND DOCTORS
IN PARTICULAR ARE NOT THERE
THEY'RE NOT THERE BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT REIMBURSING THEM
APPROPRIATELY.
SO I WILL CONTINUE -- TO
REGISTER AND NO VOTE ON ISSUES
LIKE THIS OF EXPANSION WE GIVE A
FALSE PROMISE TO THOSE WHO GET
MEDI CAL -- CERTIFICATES THEY
CAN'T FIND DOCTORS THEY GET TO
THE EMERGENCY ROOM IN A LESS HE
IS VERY CLOSE TO THE END OF HIS
LIFE.
THEY PUT HIM IN A NURSING HOME I
CAN'T EVEN GET OUT OF SOCIAL
WORKER TO RESPOND TO ME.
SO THERE ARE ISSUES WITH ACCESS
DEFINITELY BUT UNLESS WE ARE --
ADEQUATELY REIMBURSING THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE OUT THERE ON THE
FRONT LINES TO PROVIDE THAT
QUALITY HEALTHCARE THAT WE ALL
DESERVE DOCUMENTED UNDOCUMENTED
YOU NAME AT CITIZENS YOU NAME IT
BECAUSE WE'RE ALL HUMANS.
ARE WE'RE IN THE SAME --
SITUATION HUMANITY HOT SO I WILL
BE VOTING NO BUT I WANT VERY
CLEAR THAT HAS TO DO WITH THE
ACCESS ISSUE.
IN THIS LEGISLATURE IN THE
PEOPLE IN OUR GOVERNMENT HAVE
FIRST AND FOREMOST
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE PEOPLE ON THE FRONT LINES
IN THIS WAR FOR GOOD HEALTH CARE
ARE ADEQUATELY REIMBURSED THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SENATOR JACKSON'S VERY BRIEFLY I
WANT TO THANK MY GOOD COLLEAGUE
FROM LAGUNA FOR RECOGNIZING THAT
WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IS
HUMAN BEINGS AND I THINK THAT'S
BEEN PART OF WHAT MAKES THIS
SUCH A DIFFICULT AND FRUSTRATING
DISCUSSION.
BECAUSE I TOO HAVE BEEN RECENTLY
IN AN EMERGENCY ROOM.
THE END I HAVE BEEN SHOCKED.
AT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHETHER
TO DAY OR NIGHT PEOPLE LINED UP
FOR EMERGENCY ROOM CARE.
AND THE THE LACK OF PHYSICIANS
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS WHO ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT CARE AND
FOR THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
WHO ARE IN THOSE EMERGENCY ROOMS
IN TERRIBLE TERRIBLE SHAPE AND
AS WAS POINTED OUT BY THE COULD
CALLING FROM?
CHINO.
ARE FREQUENTLY THESE ARE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE NEVER WHO HAVEN'T HAD
HEALTH CARE.
THERE FIFTY YEARS OLD THEY LOOK
AT.
THEY ARE THEY ARE SUFFERING.
THE END THERE WERE AND THEY HAVE
TO WAIT HOURS BECAUSE OUR
EMERGENCY ROOMS ARE JUST TOO
FULL.
SO PART OF WHAT WE NEED TO DO
AND I THINK IT'S RCOGNIZE
PREVENTIVE CARE.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS SETTLED
EXPRESSION A STITCH IN TIME
SAVES NINE AN OUNCE OF
PREVENTION IS WORTH A POUND OF
CURE IF WE CAN PROVIDE THIS KIND
OF HEALTH CARE.
AND WITH THAT WE HEAR NUMBERS OF
HOW MANY MILLIONS AND MILLIONS
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SPEND BUT
HOW MANY BILLIONS AND BILLIONS
TO WIND UP SPENDING BY NOT
PUTTING THAT MONEY IN UP FRONT.
THESE ARE HUMAN BEINGS WHO NEED
CARE CORD TO WHO DESERVE THAT
CARE THERE ARE FAMILY I REMEMBER
WALKING INTO THE EMERGENCY ROOM
AND I LOOKED AT THESE PEOPLE
REYES THESE AREN'T IMMIGRANTS
THESE AREN'T FARMWORKERS THE
SWORD UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE.
THESE ARE HUMAN BEINGS.
AND WE NEED TO REMEMBER THAT AND
WE NEED TO REALIZE THAT WE DO
SAVE MONEY WE DO SAVE LIVES AND
WE ALSO SAVE THE HUMAN SPIRIT.
BY HELPING THOSE WHO ARE IN NEED
AND WITH THAT I WOULD ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM CENA
NAINA SENATOR ALSO TO LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I A I GREATLY APPRECIATE.
EVERYONE'S COMMENTS.
YOUR HEARTFELT COMMENTS
[inaudible]
OF SENATOR FROM -- LA COUNTY.
AND THE ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF
YOUR PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
AND EVERYONE ELSE ANA IT'S BEEN
TREMENDOUS TO SIT HERE I'M -- I
FEEL VERY HUMBLED.
BY.
ALL OF YOU JUMP IN AND TO GIVE
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON WHY.
COVERING.
ANOTHER. HUNDRED FORTY FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE IS SO IMPORTANT
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
OF AND I WELCOME THE DEBATE THAT
I'VE HAD WITH NUMBER OF PEOPLE
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS.
I THANK OUR PRO TEM FOR BRINGING
IN THE FACTS AND THE FIGURES AND
ALL THE INFORMATION THAT WE
COULD PROPERLY.
EVALUATE AND JUDGE THE TO BE
ABLE TO SAY WE ARE BOTH
RESPONSIBLE AND WE LOOK AT
OTHERS AS HUMAN BEINGS.
ALL OF THIS HAS BEEN A
TREMENDOUS EXPERIENCE FOR A
ROOKIE OF OF COMING INTO THIS A
GREAT SENATE CHAMBERS IT'S BEEN
EXTRAORDINARY SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL.
NOT ONLY FOR YOUR SUPPORT HERE
WITH THIS BILL BUT FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU DO YOU ARE
TREMENDOUS LEADERS FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA -- I'M BROKEN
HEARTED.
THAT THERE ARE STILL INDIVIDUALS.
WHO REFER?
TO HARD WORKING HUMAN BEINGS WHO
ARE JUST TRYING.
TO RAISE THEIR CHILDREN RAISE
OUR FAMILIES NOT LIVE IN
VIOLENCE.
NOT LIVE IN.
FEARING DEATH EVERY DAY IN ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER.
THEY'RE NOT HERE TO INVADE THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY'RE HERE TO HELP THIS
BY WORKING HARD.
AND NOTHING COULD BE SAID OF
THEM ANY DIFFERENT THAN THEY
COME HERE TO WORK HARD.
THEY ARE NOT OUR ENEMIES.
THEY ARE NOT LOOKING TO CAUSE
HARM TO ANYONE.
IN FACT MANY OF THE THINGS THAT
UNDOCUMENTED OR ELIGIBLE FOR THE
STAY AWAY FROM.
A WEEK WE HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT.
HOW MANY OF THEM ARE GOING TO
COME FORWARD TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
BECAUSE THEY STAY AWAY?
THEY ARE STRONG HARD WORKING
HUMAN BEINGS.
AND I URGE.
SOME OF YOU.
JUST A HANDFUL I HOPE.
OF WHO MADE SUCH OFFENSIVE
OFFENSIVE REMARKS ABOUT PEOPLE
LIKE THAT.
GO BACK TO DISTRICT.
AND REALLY PAY ATTENTION.
TO WHO'S WORKING IN THOSE
INDUSTRIES THAT YOU'RE DISTRICT
RELIES ON AND THINK ABOUT IT
TWICE AND I HOPE THAT IN YOUR
HEART.
YOU CHANGE YOUR MIND ABOUT.
THE KIND OF PEOPLE.
THAT WE ARE.
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NO BILL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS.
NO BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DODD.
THE RUSSELL HI BY [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
ROVE [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI HILL.
HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NO I'M BURKE [inaudible]
BY KATHY.
HI WIENER.
BY WILK [inaudible]
NO.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
NUMBER.
ICE TWENTY FOUR KNOWS ELEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP MEMBERS IS FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN BY SENATOR LABEL IT'S
CENTER LABOR YOU'RE PREPARED FOR
THIS I DON'T MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO TEN BY SENATOR
LEYVA AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICULAR AIR POLLUTION
[inaudible]
SENATOR LEYVA.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD.
MEMBERS I'VE SPENT MY ENTIRE
LIFE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE AND SO
IF YOU'VE HEARD ME TELL THIS
STORY -- WHEN I WAS A LITTLE
GIRL IN THE EARLY SEVENTIES WE
COULDN'T SEE THE MOUNTAINS THAT
WERE VERY CLOSE TO WHERE I LIVE?
IN CHINO AND GREW UP.
AND THEN AS THE YEARS WENT ON
THINGS GOT A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
BUT IN THE EARLY SEVENTIES THERE
WAS SO MUCH SMOG THAT WE
COULDN'T SEE THE MOUNTAINS WHEN
I WAS -- NEWMAN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL WE HAD SMOG DAYS OUR
LUNGS HURT WE WEREN'T ALLOWED TO
GO OUTSIDE.
AND THEN THINGS GOT A LITTLE BIT
BETTER AND WE CAN SEE THE
MOUNTAINS NOW WE DON'T HAVE AS
MANY SMOG DAYS BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
HAS HAPPENED THE PARTICULATES
GOTTEN SMALLER SO EVEN THOUGH WE
SEE THE MOUNTAINS AND APPEARS TO
BE A PRETTY DAY.
THERE'S STILL A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF SMOG NOT JUST IN MY
DISTRICT BUT UP AND DOWN THE
STATE.
SB TWO TEN ESTABLISHES A SMOG
CHECK REQUIREMENT FOR MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WILL APPLY SIMILAR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO TRUCK
OPERATORS TO MAINTAIN THEIR
MISSION CONTROLS AS WE ALREADY
REQUIRE THE CARS THAT WE ALL
DRIVE TO DEAL.
UNLIKE PERSONAL PASSENGER
VEHICLES CURRENT LAWS DO NOT
REQUIRE HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS TO
HAVE REGULAR SMALL CHECKS TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR MISSION
CONTROL SYSTEMS ARE WORKING
PROPERLY THROUGHOUT THEIR
LIFESPAN.
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS DRIVE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ROADS ANNUALLY AND
ARE MAJOR CONTRIBUTORS TO THE
STATE'S POOR AIR QUALITY.
STATEWIDE NEARLY TWELVE MILLION
RESIDENTS LIVING COMMUNITIES
THAT FAIL TO MEET FEDERAL CLEAN
AIR STANDARDS.
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS OPERATING
CALIFORNIA ACCOUNT FOR NEARLY
60% OF HARMFUL OXIDES OF
NITROGEN KNOCKS.
AND 82% OF DIESEL PARTICULATE
MATTER A POTENTIALLY CANCER
CAUSING AIR CONTAMINANT.
EXPOSURE TO THESE HARMFUL AIR
CONTAMINANTS IS DIRECTLY
ASSOCIATED WITH INCREASED
HOSPITALIZATIONS FOR CHRONIC
HEART AND LUNG DISEASE OR
DISEASES.
AND OTHER SERIOUS IMPACTS FOR
EARLY ADULT ELDERLY ADULTS AND
YOUNG CHILDREN.
MEMBERS DIRTY AIR COST
CALIFORNIA OVER TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN HOSPITALIZATIONS
VISITS TO EMERGENCY ROOMS AND
CHRONIC ILLNESSES.
THE CONSEQUENCES ARE MUCH WORSE
IN REGIONS ACROSS THE STREET A
STATE LIKE THE INLAND EMPIRE AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
BETTER AFFECTED GREATLY BY
WAREHOUSES IN CONGESTED FREEWAYS
DESPITE THE INVESTMENTS WE HAVE
MADE A TO SUPPORT A TRANSITION
TO ZERO AND NEAREST ZERO
EMISSION.
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES DIESEL
TRUCKS WILL CONTINUE TO OPERATE
ON OUR ROADS FOR DECADES TO COME.
WE HAVE TO TAKE A BOLD STEP TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY MAINTAIN
THEIR MISSION CONTROL THROUGHOUT
THEIR LIFESPAN.
THIS ACTION ALONE WILL PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY AND
PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS.
OVER THE NEXT TEST DECADE SB TWO
TEN WILL ASSIST IN THE REMOVAL
OF SIXTEEN HUNDRED TONS OF
HARMFUL PARTICULAR MATTER.
EQUIVALENT TO TAKING THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND TRUCKS OFF THE ROAD.
NOT ONLY WILL SB TWO TEN HELP
IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH AND AIR
QUALITY IT WILL ALSO IMPROVE THE
LIFE EXPECTANCY OF HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS AS BIG THEY BECOME MORE
FREQUENTLY MAINTAIN.
SB TWO TEN ALSO APPLIES TO OUT
OF STATE TRUCKS AND WILL HELP
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FOR ARE
LAW ABIDING CALIFORNIA TRUCK
OWNERS AND OPERATORS.
SIMPLY PUT SB TWO TEN WILL BE A
WIN WIN FOR CALIFORNIA
INDUSTRIES AND FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASOCIATION
THE CAT AND THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU.
HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY ENGAGED ON
THIS ISSUE EVERY SHARED
IMPORTANCE AS THEY TOO WANT THE
STATE TO FAIRLY ENFORCE VEHICLE
STANDARDS AND A MISSION LAWS FOR
IN COMPLIANCE MAINLY OUT OF
STATE TRACKS.
WELL SOME INDUSTRY CONCERNS
REMAIN WE ARE WORKING TOGETHER
ALONG WITH CLEAN AIR ADVOCATES
TO RESOLVE THEM.
I AM THROUGH THE AZTEC THAT
OPPOSITION BELIEVES THAT THE
APPROPRIATIONS AMENDMENTS
BELIEVE THAT THEY IT IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
RECENT AMENDMENTS INSURE THAT A.
R. B. WILL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
TO THE LEGISLATURE OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEES AND OPEN FOR PUBLIC
SCRUTINY FOR THE FEES AND
PROGRAM RULES THAT THEY PROPOSE.
ADDITIONALLY THE FEES CANNOT BE
USED FOR OTHER PROGRAMS ARE BE
ASSESSED ABOVE THE DETAILED AND
REVIEWED COST OF THE PROGRAM.
THE FEW WILL ALSO BE REQUIRED TO
BE ADJUSTED TO ACCOUNT FOR SMALL
AND LARGE TRUCK OPERATORS.
SB TWO TENNIS SUPPORTED BY
DOZENS OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ORGANIZATIONS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SHANE IN
HEARING ON SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
HI.
I'M SORRY I MISSED SENATOR
PORCHES HOUSES MIKE PLEASE.
WAS THERE OUGHT TO VOTE SENATOR
BORDERS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESERVATION OF
QUESTIONS THE AUTHOR.
SOONER LEGAL YOU TAKE QUESTION
HAPPY TO SERVE.
GREATER.
I WANT TO DO -- JUST ASK
QUESTION ON THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE MEDIUM AND LARGE TRUCKS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THEY GO
THROUGH IN ANNUAL -- OR EVERY
FEW YEAR -- PROCESS FOR
EMISSIONS COMPLIANCE.
IS THAT NOT SUFFICIENT.
IT IS NOT SUFFICIENT -- IT IS A
TEST THE IT IT'S A RANDOMLY
SELECTED TRUCKS -- GOING UP AND
DOWN THE ROADS AND THEY DO
SOMETHING CALLED AN OPACITY TEST
THAT JUST LOOKS AT THE SMOKE
THAT THEY ARE ADMITTING BUT
THERE'S ALSO THE NO MECHANISM IF
THE TRUCK IS POLLUTING THERE'S
NO MECHANISM. TO MAKE SURE THE
TRUCK NO LONGER -- IT POLLUTES
SO IT'S RANDOM SB TWO TEN WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT ALL TRUCKS COMPLY
WITH THE SAME -- PROCEDURES DO
YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON WHAT
THIS WOULD DO TO CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES -- TRUCKING CATTLE AG
SO AND SO FORTH.
IF -- TRUCKS ARE DEEMED TO BE IN
THE HIGHER POLLUTING CATEGORY.
BY IS THERE A REPLACEMENT
MECHANISM THAT -- WILL HAVE
WOULD.
OFFER SOME CONSIDERATIONS FOR
FOLKS IN THE INDUSTRY YOU MEAN
THE IF THEY'RE TRUCKERS
POLLUTING A LOT WITH BABY HAVE
ACCESS TO BY PURCHASING A
CLEANER VEHICLE.
EITHER THAT OR SMALLER ENTITIES
PURCHASING THOSE.
LARGER -- TRUCKS -- BECAUSE THEY
MIGHT BE HELD TO A DIFFERENT
STANDARD THIS BILL DOES NOT
ADDRESS THAT I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE PROGRAMS OUT THERE WHERE YOU
CAN -- YOU CAN APPLY FOR A GRANT
TO GET CLEANER ENERGY TRUCKS
THIS IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THE
TRUCKS THAT ARE ON THE ROAD
TODAY HOUSE A SMOG CHECK JUST
LIKE WE DO WITH ALL OF OUR
PERSONAL VEHICLES.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE NOT
IN MEETING MORE THAN THEY'RE
SUPPOSED.
TO OR IN JUST TO BE CLEAR I I
DON'T KNOW TOO MUCH ABOUT
EMISSIONS WHEN IT COMES TO
DIESEL AND AND REGULAR -- THESE
EMISSIONS ARE THESE ARE
TRANSPORTATION THESE HELD TO A
HIGHER STANDARD OF EMISSIONS AS
OPPOSED TO NON COMMERCIAL.
ANY OF THAT I'M AWARE OF IS IT
THE SAME.
NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF THAT I
DON'T THINK THEY'RE HELD TO ANY
DIFFERENT STANDARD OF THEY DO
POLLUTE MORE THAN YOUR REGULAR
AVERAGE VEHICLE DOES AS YOU
HEARD ME SAY IN MY MY STATEMENT.
SIXTEEN HUNDRED TONS OF CARBON
DIOXIDE COULD BE SAVED FROM THAT
AND THIS BILL WHILE HAVING THESE
TRUCKS -- GET A SMOG CHECK OVER
TEN YEARS WILL BE LIKE TAKING
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND TRUCKS OFF THE ROAD
WITHOUT ACTUALLY TAKE HIM OFF
THE ROAD THE OLDEST BE RUNNING
CLEANER.
SO IN TERMS OF MY BACKYARD --
REPRESENTING AN AREA IN THE
VALLEY WE'VE GOT.
THE WORST AIR.
HANDS DOWN SO THERE IS A BALANCE
AND I AM NOT CERTAIN EXACTLY
WHERE IT IS.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE MAJOR INDUSTRY --
IT NEEDS DO YOU HAVE ANY SENSE
ON I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S BEEN
ANY RESEARCH ON HOW THIS WILL
ACTUALLY IMPACT -- THE AG
INDUSTRY THE TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY -- CATTLE INDUSTRY SO
ON AND SO FORTH SO WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE CATTLEMEN WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE FARM
BUREAU AND I THINK THEY BROUGHT
ALL THEIR CONSIDER CONCERNS
FORWARD.
AND WE'VE BEEN WE'VE DONE A LOT
OF GREAT WORK WILL CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THEM.
THIS IS THE THIRD YEAR THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS --
AND THEY'VE BEEN TERRIFIC TO
WORK WITH AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
SO WE HAVE NOT CLEARED ALL OF
THEIR CONCERNS BUT WE'RE GETTING
THERE AND THEY'VE BEEN TERRIFIC
TO WORK WITH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SEE NINE IS AN EARLY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU NOW MR SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS AYE BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL [inaudible]
HI PORGES.
NO BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD [inaudible]
THEY'RE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
JACKSON.
I JONES NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
BY.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
I STONE.
NO.
NUMBER.
BY COUNTY.
BY WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
NO.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS COPY AT ALL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
BY -- TADO.
HI NUMBER.
HI [inaudible]
THE ARE YOU SIX TWENTY SEVEN
KNOWS TEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
WERE MOVING BACK IN FILE WE'RE
GOING TO RETURN TO FILE ITEM
ELEVEN SENATOR REVIEW ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THAT ITEM.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE.
READ SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVENTY
SEVEN BUT CENTERRUBIO AND
ACTUALLY ANY COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU.
MISTER PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
AM.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN TO INCREASE FULL TIME
FACULTY AT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND NINETEEN EIGHTY
COLLEGE THIS MISSION.
AND GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE AND
ALSO ESTABLISHED A GOAL THAT 75%
OF INSTRUCTION SHOULD BE TAUGHT
BY A FULL TIME FACULTY.
IT HAS BEEN MORE THAN THIRTY
YEARS AND THE 75% GOAL HAS YET
TO BE ACHIEVED.
MEMBERS AGAIN THIRTY YEARS AND
WE'RE STILL NOT THERE.
IN FACT DUE TO AN OVER RELIANCE
ON PART TIME FACULTY THE RATE OF
FULL TIME FACULTY HAS DROPPED TO
FIFTY SIX POINT 7%.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM ADOPTED
A VISION FOR SUCCESS.
THIS IS THE SYSTEM PLAN TO HELP
MORE STUDENTS RECEIVED DEGREES
TRANSFER TO FOUR YEAR COLLEGES
CLOSE EQUITY GAPS AMONG STUDENT
GROUPS AND CLOSE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AMONG THE REGION I BRING MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE TO YOU AND I
KNOW PERSONALLY AFTER BEING AN
EDUCATOR FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS
THAT OUR STUDENTS DO BETTER WITH
TEACHERS ARE VESTED.
AND THEY CAN BUILD A LONG
LASTING RELATIONSHIP.
I STILL MENTOR FOURTH GRADE
STUDENTS WHO ARE ADULTS AND NOT
BECAUSE I WAS GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ON CAMPUS SEE
THEM OFTEN.
AND BE PRESENT WHEN THEY NEEDED
MY HELP.
FULL TIME FACULTY ARE ABLE TO
STAY ON CAMPUS ALSO OFFICE HOURS
ARE MORE ACCESSIBLE TO STUDENTS
NEEDING HELP CONTRIBUTE MORE
HOURS TO THE PROGRAMS ON CAMPUS
WHICH IS.
REALLY IMPORTANT AND SPEND MORE
TIME AS COUNSELORS AND MENTORS
AMONG OTHER BENEFITS THIS BILL
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THE LARGEST STUDENT POPULATION
AT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
IS ALSO THE POPULATION THAT'S
MOST IN NEED.
BECAUSE THE ECONOMIC PROSPERITY
OF THE STATE'S RESTED LARGE PART
ON EDUCATIONAL SUCCESSES OF THE
GROWING NUMBER OF MINORITY
COMMUNITIES AND BECAUSE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE INTEGRAL
TO ALL THOSE MINORITY
COMMUNITIES IT IS IMPERATIVE WE
DO ALL WE COUNTY INCREASE
STUDENT ACADEMIC OUTCOMES I
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND INCREASING THE RATE OF
INSTRUCTION BY FULL TIME FACULTY
IS CRITICAL TO REACHING THIS
GOAL AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SEEN HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES.
NOBEL.
AYE PORGES.
BRADFORD.
I COVER YET ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I WHISTLE.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH HI RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO NUMBER.
IOWA KELSEY BY WINNER BY WILK.
NO.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR JESS.
NO [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
I TADO [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO.
VICE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES.
AND WE'RE RETURNING TO FILE ITEM
NINE SENATOR JACKSON ARE YOU
PREPARED.
MANA MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL FIVE FIFTY ONE
BY SENATOR JACKSON AN ACT
RELATING TO OIL AND GAS.
INTERJECTION THANK YOU MISS
PRESSING COLLEAGUES THIS IS A
MEASURE THAT SIMPLY DIRECTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF OIL GAS AND
GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES.
BELOVED LEE KNOWN AS DARKER. TO
DEVELOP AN ACCOUNTING MECHANISM.
FOR ASSESSING THE COST OF
DECOMMISSIONING AND REMEDIATING
WORRELL AND GAS INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE STATE.
THAT IS ALL THE BILL DOES.
THE COST OF INFRASTRUCTURE TO
THE STATE IS NOT HYPOTHETICAL.
FOR EXAMPLE IN MY DISTRICT TRUST
IN THE PAST COUPLE YEARS.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
SPENT OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF TAXPAYER
FUNDS FOR TRUST -- FACILITIES
THAT HAVE ARE BEING
DECOMMISSIONED.
AS WELL AS AN ADDITIONAL SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A SERIES OF
ABANDONED COSTA WELLS.
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE HAVE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF THESE WELLS
OFF.
AND ONSHORE WELLS FACILITY
STORAGE TANKS AND PRODUCTION
LINES.
WE HAVE MADE PROGRESS.
ON IDENTIFYING THESE WELLS IN
DOING THAT KIND OF ACCOUNTING
FOR A SMALL.
PERCENTAGE OF THESE WELLS.
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES HAS DONE LEGISLATION
DEALING WITH OFFSHORE WELLS IN
ORDER TO IDENTIFY THEM AND TO
TRY TO DETERMINE WHAT THE COSTS
WILL BE IF WE IF AND WHEN THEY
ARE DECOMMISSIONED.
AS WELL AS FORMER SENATOR LARA.
WE ARE WE ARE ABLE TO LOOK AT
IDLE DWELLS AND OFFSHORE WELLS.
BUT THERE ARE A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND OPERATING WELLS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MOST
OF WHICH ARE NOT COVERED
[inaudible]
THIS MECHANISM.
UNDER THIS BILL WILL DIRECT
DARKER TO DEVELOP A TRULY
COMPREHENSIVE TOOL. TO ASSESS
ALL INFRASTRUCTURE WE DO THIS
NOW FOR EXAMPLE FOR THE SURFACE
MINING INDUSTRY.
AND IT IS EMINENTLY SENSIBLE
THAT WE DO THE SAME WITH THE
SECTOR WITH A FOOTPRINT IN
LITERALLY EVERY CORNEROF THE
STATE.
RECENT AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
TAKEN IN APPROPRIATIONS FURTHER
CLARIFY DOGGER MAY DEVELOP A
STANDARD MODEL SO THAT IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO MAKE INDIVIDUAL.
INDIVIDUALIZED ASSESSMENTS FOR
EACH CATEGORY OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THE DOCTOR CAN MAKE ITS BEST
ESTIMATES AS TO THE LIFETIME OF
CURRENTLY PRODUCING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I WANT THIS MCHANISM TO BE BOTH
USEFUL FOR THE PUBLIC AND
WORKABLE FOR THE AGENCY WITH
THIS BILL.
THIS IS A BILL OF TRANSPARENCY
SO THAT WE CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE FULL SCOPE OF THIS PROBLEM
AND TO PLAN FOR LIABILITIES IN
AN UP FRONT.
AN ORDERLY WAY.
THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT
IS A REAL PROBLEM AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG ON
THIS ITEM [inaudible]
HOLD.
THANK YOU UP.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT YOU
KNOW.
A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF SPEAKER PEREZ.
OF THIS LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
SIGNED A LAW.
CALLED RIGS TO REEFS.
THE BASIC PREMISE BEHIND THE LAW.
WAS THAT WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
OFFSHORE WELLS.
AND THAT IF INSTEAD OF SOME OF
THOSE WELLS AS TALL AS A
THOUSAND FEET GOING DOWN TO THE
DEPTHS OF THE FLOOR OF THE OCEAN.
AND INSTEAD OF ARM HAVING THOSE
WELLS JUST BE REMOVED AS THE
REQUIRED UNDER THE FEDERAL LAW.
IF THERE'S A NET ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFIT.
THE NOTION WAS YOU CAN CHOP IT
OFF AT A HUNDRED FEATURES ALL
SHIPS CAN GO OVER IT.
IT WOULD BE A RE FENCE RIGS TO
REEFS.
AND IT WOULD HAVE TO HAVE AN
THAT ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS.
THERE WAS SOME CHALLENGES WITH
THAT AND FOR THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS ON THIS FLOOR I HAVE BEEN
ARGUING.
FOR THIS IDEA OF THE RIGS TO
REEFS BECAUSE THE NOTION WAS
THAT THE MONEY SAVED. 80% 85% OF
THE MONEY BEING SAVED WOULD GO
INTO AND IN DOWN ONE FOR THE
OCEAN.
IT WOULD MAKE WE ESTIMATE.
OF FIVE BILLION DOLLAR ENDOWMENT
PROTECT THE OCEAN.
THE SINGLE LARGEST ENDOWMENT ON
PLANET EARTH TO PROTECT THE
OCEAN.
IT IS DIFFICULT FOR US AS WE
FACE CHALLENGES IN THIS BODY TO
PAY.
FOR OTHER THINGS EDUCATION
HEALTHCARE AND OTHER CHALLENGES
TO ALSO PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT
IN THE OCEAN THE WAY THIS WOULD
DO SO. TO THE BILL THAT I HAD
HAD TO MAKE IT IN THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFIT IT HAS
BEEN QUITE CHALLENGING.
THE THING I LIKE ABOUT THIS BILL
IS THAT IT REQUIRES STARTED NOW
DO AN ASSESSMENT.
AS TO WHAT IT WOULD COST TO
REMOVE EACH OF THESE AS NOW IN
ADDITION TO DOES OTHER PIPELINES
AND OTHER THINGS BUT I'M
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED THE
OFFSHORE.
OIL WELLS SO NOW WE CAN ACTUALLY
LOOK AT A REAL ASSESSMENT AS TO
HOW MUCH MONEY COULD BE SAVED.
TO BE ABLE TO GO INTO THIS
IMPORTANT AND DOWN ONE FOR THE
OCEAN.
AGAINST THE ARM THE THE THE ANY
OTHERS ASSOCIATED COSTS AT INFO
OF FOR OF COURSE ONLY IF THERE'S
AN THAT ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFIT SO
FOR THAT REASON I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE TODAY.
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING WHAT THOSE NUMBERS ARE SO
WE CAN QUANTIFY THE SAVINGS IN
THE BENEFIT TO THE OCEAN.
OF CALIFORNIA AND BEYOND AS FOR
AND I THINK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OF IT ON THE SIDE OF
IN CHINO ANSWER JACKSON JAW TO
CLOSE THANK YOU WELL I ALWAYS
APPRECIATE THE WISDOM OF MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY WE DO HAPPEN TO DISAGREE
A LITTLE BIT.
ON THAT.
THE REACH TO REAP CONCEPT BUT
THE ISSUE IS THE SAME WE NEED TO
DO AN ASSESSMENT WENEED TO KNOW
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT THE COST IS GOING TO BE
WHEN AND IF WE START DE
COMMISSIONING THE VARIOUS
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT EXISTS THIS
IS TRUST THE BILL SO THAT WE
KNOW?
IT IS A TRANSPARENCY BILL.
THAT'S ALL IT DOES BECAUSE TODAY
IRONICALLY WE HAVE NO IDEA.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ON A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
NO BILL.
I PURCHASE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
COPY AT ALL [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD [inaudible]
THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
BY GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
NO GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI HILL.
BY WITH SO -- TITLE [inaudible]
NO JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO HAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER [inaudible]
IOWA CASKEY.
BY WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI. SIX THIRD PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS ARCHULETA [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
COPY AT ALL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
ROTH RUBIO
.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RIGHT FOR A BRADFORD I ICE
TWENTY TWO KNOWS THIRTEEN THE
MEASURE PASSES [inaudible]
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
YES.
MOVING NOW BACK TO FOLLOW ORDER
WERE ON ITEM FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN SENATOR SKINNER YOU
PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM.
SHE IS MOVING BACK TO HER DESK.
IN THE MEAN TIME INSTRUCTOR
PLEASE RATE SENATE BILL THREE
THIRTY BY SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING.
WINNERS CAM THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SO SB THREE
THIRTY IS A RARE BILL THAT HAS
BOTH THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION AND CAL CHAMBER IN
SUPPORT.
NOW WHAT IS SB THREE THIRTY DO.
I IT THIS BILL.
WAS PATTERNED AFTER.
THE ACTIONS THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE TAKEN WHEN THEY
EXPERIENCED A LARGE LOSS OF
HOUSING FOR EXAMPLE AFTER FIRE
OR ANOTHER DISASTER.
IN THEIR OBJECTIVE WAS TO GET
THAT HOUSING REPLACED AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE SO I SERVED ON THE
BERKELEY CITY COUNCIL DURING THE
OAKLAND.
BERKELEY TUNNEL FIRE IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE WHEN WE LOST OVER
THREE THOUSAND UNITS IN A TWELVE
HOUR PERIOD SO UP UNTIL THE
SANTA ROSA FIRE THAT WAS THE
WORST DISASTER IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY THE LARGEST LOSS OF
UNITS THE LARGEST LOSS OF LIFE.
OF COURSE IN ROSE'S SICK
EXCEEDED THAT -- BUT INDEPENDENT
OF THAT BOTH SANTAROSA AND
OAKLAND BERKELEY AFTER THAT LOSS
OF UNITS.
KNOWING THAT THEY WANTED TO GET
HOUSING FAST.
THE STREAMLINED THE PROCESS A
BIT THEY DID WHAT THEY WERE
ALREADY DOING BUT THEY DID IT
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY TO
HELP GET THAT HOUSING BACK
IMMEDIATELY.
SO THAT'S WHAT SB THREE THIRTY
IS PATTERNED AFTER AND IN FACT I
ASKED BEFORE A SUBMITTED THE
BILL THE CONCEPT ALLEGE COUNCIL
I ASKED THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA
FOR WHAT THEY DID WHAT THEY
ENACTED.
IN ORDER TO ASSIST IN THEIR
UNITS AND THIS BILL IS VERY MUCH
PATTERNED AFTER THAT.
SO IT RELIES ON OUR EXISTING
LOCAL ZONING AND IT TELLS OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DO WHAT YOU
ARE DOING.
BUT DO IT EFFECTIVELY DO IT
EFFICIENTLY AND DON'T CHANGE THE
RULES MIDSTREAM SO ONCE A
HOUSING APPLICANT HAS SUBMITTED
THEIR APPLICATION THAT FOLLOWS
THE ZONING RULES AND FOLLOWS THE
EXISTING DESIGN REVIEW STANDARDS.
AND ONCE THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SAYS YOUR APPLICATION IS
COMPLETE THEN THE BILL SAYS
PROCESS THE PERMIT ANY YEAR.
AND IT LIMITS THE NUMBER OF
PUBLIC HEARINGS BUT TO TO UP TO
SIX IT STILL ALLOWS FOR UP TO
SIX PUBLIC HEARINGS AND IT SAYS
GET THAT PERMIT OUT.
IN ONE YEAR AND THEN DURING THAT
YEAR DO NOT CHANGE THE RULES
DON'T CHANGE THE SIGN REVIEW
DON'T CHANGE OTHER RULES THAT
WAY THE APPLICANT KNOWS THERE'S
CONSISTENCY.
THIS HELPS REDUCE THE COST OF
HOUSING BECAUSE TIME IS MONEY.
SO WHAT SB THREE THIRTY DOES IT
TAKE KNOWLEDGE THAT UP AND DOWN
THE STATE WE ARE IN A HOUSING
CRISIS AND WE NEED UNITS FAST WE
NEED AFFORDABLE UNITS AND WE
NEED MARKET RE UNITS AND WE NEED
THEM FAST -- IT ALSO THE BILL IS
EFFECTIVE FOR FIVE YEARS SO IT
SUNSETS IN FIVE YEARS IT ALSO
SUSPENDS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ABILITY TO
DOWN ZONE OR PUT A CAP ON THE
NUMBER OF HOUSING UNITS JUST FOR
THE FIVE YEAR PERIOD.
AND FIVE THERE WAS ORIGINALLY IN
THE BILL A CAP ON FEES BUT THAT
IS BEEN LIFTED SO THAT IS NO
LONGER IN THE BILL.
AND IT'S EFFECTIVE FOR FIVE
YEARS AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OF THE
BAIT ON THIS ITEM.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
STANDING HEARING NONE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
NOBEL.
AYE PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
BY HILL.
AYE HUESO -- TITLE.
JACKSON.
HI JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN.
I BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I LIKE OWSKI.
I WINNER BY WILK.
HI.
MR MRS VICTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FOR JUST
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
GLAZER.
NO.
WAY SO.
I TITLE I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
STERN.
MARCH TWENTY EIGHTH KNOWS SEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN SENATOR MITCHELL.
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR SUPPLY LINE.
SIXTEEN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
THREE SENATE BILL ONE FORTY FOUR
BY SENATOR MITCHELL AN ACT
RELATING TO FEES [inaudible]
MR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT [inaudible]
I DON'T [inaudible]
I MEAN [inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M SORRY I GOT A LOT OF PAPER
HERE TO TRY TO MANAGE TAKES TIME.
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY FOUR
COLLEAGUES CURRENT LAW STATES.
THAT COUNTIES ALLOWS COUNTIES TO
CHARGE FEES FOR DOZENS OF
SERVICES PROVIDED BY THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND JUSTICE SYSTEM ALLOWS
THEM TO SET THE AMOUNT OF FEES.
THIS LAW HAS RESULTED IN A
PATCHWORK OF FEES CHARGED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WAS VERY ON
EVEN OUTCOMES IN EACH COUNTY.
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY FOUR SIX
TO REFORM THE WAY WE DO BUSINESS
THAT OUR PUBLIC SAFETY CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM BY ENDING THE
FAILED PUBLIC POLICY FOR A
BILLION PEOPLE.
ACCUSED AND CONVICTED OF CRIMES
FOR THE COST OF THESE SERVICES.
EVEN AFTER THEY HAVE SERVED
THEIR TIME AND EVEN THOUGH ALL
OF US ARE SUPPOSEDLY A BURKE
PURPORTEDLY BENEFICIARIES OF
THESE SYSTEMS.
I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR THIS
BILL DOES NOT ELIMINATE FINE
ONLY FEES.
HOWEVER LAWS ON THE BOOKS AND
STAKEHOLDERS OFTEN USE TO TAME
THE TERMS INTERCHANGEABLY.
MOST IMPORTANTLY THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE SANCTIONS ARE OFTEN
BLURRED FOR THOSE RECEIVING
BILLS AS THEY ARE CALCULATED
ARTICULATED AS ONE LARGE AMOUNT
OFTEN WITHOUT ANY DISTINCTION.
WHILE THE BILL WAS UP ON THE
SUSPENSE FILE WE SURVEY FAMILY
STATE WHY.
THE IDENTIFIED THE MOST
EGREGIOUS OF THE FEES ANY FEE
THAT DID NOT MAKE THIS WORST OF
THE WORST LIST WERE ADOPTED AS
OFFICE AMENDMENTS.
THE COMMITTEE STRUCK A HOST OF
ADDITIONAL FEES.
THE RESULT IS THE AMENDED BILL
BEFORE YOU THAT RETURN TO MORE
THAN SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEES TO THE COURTS AND COUNTIES.
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES POLL
STREAMING PROBLEMS FOR CITIES
COUNTIES IN RESIDENTS NUMBER ONE
THEY ARE CHARGED TO LOW INCOME
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY
THEM. TO THEY CREATE BARRIERS TO
RE ENTRY AND THREE THEY ARE SELF
DEFEATING ANEMIC SOURCE OF
REVENUE.
THE CRIMINAL ADMINISTRATIVE
SYSTEM AS CONDUCTED BY THE
COURTS IN COUNTIES WAS NOT
DESIGNED TO RELYING FEES HOWEVER
OVER THE COURSE OF SEVERAL
DECADES A SERIES OF EVENTS LED
TO A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
AUTHORIZED FEES.
AND THEN A SIGNIFICANT DECREASE
IN COLLECTIBLE FEES.
THE REGRESSIVE TOUGH ON CRIME
AIR OF THE NIGHT EIGHTIES AND
NINETIES LEANED HEAVILY ON FEES
IS PUNITIVE DESPITE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL CONFLICT AND TO A
LESSER EXTENT AS FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR THE SYSTEM.
WITH THE GREAT RECESSION CAME
SIGNIFICANT CUT STATE WHY CUTS
THAT WE AS A STATE ARE STILL
RECOVERING FROM THIS THIS
INCREASE THE RELIANCE FOR FEES
AS A REVENUE SOURCE.
WITH THE REALIGNMENT RECENT
COURT DECISIONS AND A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT THE ONCE
INTRACTABLE PROBLEM RECIDIVISM
THE SYSTEM NOW FINDS ITSELF WITH
A STEADILY DECLINING REVENUE
SOURCE.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS BODY
HURT SB ONE NINETY AND VOTED TO
ELIMINATE JUVENILE FEES.
IN THE LESS THAN TWO YEARS SINCE
IMPLEMENTATION THE COUNTIES ARE
AT 1100% COMPLIANCE WITH THAT
LAW.
IN FACT SOME COUNTIES WENT
BEYOND THE LAW AND THE FOR GIVEN
BACK -- TO FEES NOTABLY THE
LARGEST COUNTY IN THE STATE LOS
ANGELES.
IN A TWENTY EIGHTEEN STUDY ON
THE IMPACT THEIR PROBATION FEES
IN CALIFORNIA. FIFTY EIGHT
PUBLIC RECORDS REQUESTS WERE
SENT TO ALL COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS. 80% OF COUNTIES
RESPONDED REPRESENTING NEARLY
95% OF CALIFORNIA'S TOTAL
POPULATION.
RESPONSES SHOW THAT MOST
COUNTIES DO NOT TRACK COLLECTION
RATES SUGGESTING THAT THE FEES
ARE OF LITTLE CONSEQUENCE THE
COUNTY BUDGETS.
THOSE THAT DID TRACK COLLECTION
RATES REVEAL LOW COLLECTION
RATES AND THE HIGH COST OF
COLLECTION.
ALSO IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO BY
WAY OF THEIR FINANCIAL JUSTICE
PROJECT PUBLISHED.
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES HI PAIN FOR
PEOPLE LOW GAIN FOR GOVERNMENT A
CALL TO ACTION FOR CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES.
AS A RESULT OF THAT PUBLISHED
REPORT SAN FRANCISCO ABOLISHED
ALL LOCALLY IMPOSE FEES AND
FULLY DISCHARGED ALL LOCALLY
IMPOSE CRIMINAL ADMINISTRATIVE
DEBT.
IN FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR THE US
SUPREME COURT RULED UNANIMOUSLY
THAT THE PROHIBITION IN THE
EIGHTH AMENDMENT OF THE
CONSTITUTION RELATING TO
EXCESSIVE FINES DOES IN FACT
APPLY TO STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
THEREBY LIMITING THEIR ABILITIES
TO IMPOSE FINES AND SEIZE
PROPERTY.
PERMISSION TO READ MISTER
PRESIDENT.
WHAT I'LL DO CAPTION JUNCTION
THANK YOU IN THAT RULING JUSTICE
GINSBURG SAYS AND I QUOTE FOR
GOOD REASON THE PROTECTION
AGAINST EXCESSIVE FINES HAS BEEN
A CONSTANT SHIELD?
THROUGHOUT ANGLE AMERICAN
HISTORY EXORBITANT TOLLS
UNDERMINE OTHER CONSTITUTIONAL
LIBERTIES.
AND THAT THE PROTECTION AGAINST
EXCESSIVE PUNITIVE ECONOMIC
SANCTIONS SECURED BY THE CLAUSE
IS BOTH FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR
SCHEME OF ORDERED LIBERTY AND
DEEPLY ROOTED IN THIS NATION'S
HISTORY AND TRADITION.
IN QUOTE.
THIS FEBRUARY ALONG WITH A
SEVERAL OF YOU I ATTENDED THE
SMART JUSTICE CALIFORNIA RETREAT.
SOME OF YOU IN THIS ROOM WERE
THERE AS WELL THE BIGGEST TAKE
AWAY WAS THAT VICTIMS.
WHO WERE PRESENT?
TALKED ABOUT THEIR PREFERENCE
FOR JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT FOCUSES
MORE ON REHABILITATION THAN
PUNISHMENT.
EDUCATION THAN INCARCERATION AND
JOB CREATION AND TREATMENT.
THEY TALKED ABOUT COMING TO THAT
CONCLUSION BASED ON THEIR
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT WHAT REALLY
HELPS RECIDIVISM RATES.
LAST MONTH THE LA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AGREED TO EXAMINE
THE APPLICATION OF FINES FEES
AND PENALTIES AND DETERMINE THE
FEASIBILITY OF ELIMINATING SOME
OR ALL OF THEM.
I WALK THROUGH THIS RATHER
LENGTHY SUMMARY BECAUSE I REALLY
HOPE TO MAKE CLEAR TO YOU THAT
SB ONE FORTY FOUR IS PROMOTING
THE NEW VISION FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND WE'RE NOT AHEAD OF THE CURVE
COMMUNITIES COURTS COUNTY IS AN
EVIDENCE BASED STUDIES MAKE IT
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR.
THAT THE FEES ARE AGAIN HIGH
PAYING LOW GAME THEY PERPETUATE
RECIDIVISM ARE A CONSTITUTIONAL
CHALLENGE.
MANY OF YOU I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH WHO EXPRESSED SOME CONCERN
YOU'VE HEARD FROM YOUR COUNTIES
WHO WILL GIVE YOU A DOLLAR
AMOUNT THAT THEY SAY THIS BILL
WILL BLOW A HOLE IN THEIR BUDGET --
I'VE.
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO
GO BACK TO TALK YOUR COUNTIES TO
ACTUALLY ASKED THE QUESTION
ABOUT COLLECTION RATE.
AND WHAT FEE THEY ARE PAID OR
WHAT ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH ACTUALLY TRYING
TO COLLECT THESE FEES.
WE'VE HAD ONGOING CONVERSATIONS --
ABOUT SOME OF THE PARTICULARS IN
THE BILL SPECIFICALLY WITH
REGARD TO IGNITION INTERLOCK
DEVICES IN OTHERS.
AND MY POINT TO YOU IS REALLY TO
ALLOW US TO CONTINUE THIS
PROCESS WITH THE BILL.
THE PRIMARY LETTER OF OFFER
OPPOSITION STATE.
FROM THE COUNTIES AND AND THOSE
IN OPPOSITION THAT THEY DON'T
CHALLENGED THE POLICY THAT WE'RE
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS WITH THE
BILL.
THE QUESTION IS LOS REVENUE.
THE QUESTION I POSED TO THE
OPPOSITION THAT I HOPE THAT YOU
ALL WILL DO AS WELL IS LET'S GET
A REAL CLEAR PICTURE OF THE TRUE
DOLLARS IN SINCE.
BEING DEBATED [inaudible]
WHAT?
KIND OF ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ARE
THEY IN CURRY IN THEIR EFFORT TO
COLLECT THE FEES.
AND WHAT ARE THEY ACTUALLY
COLLECTING NOT WHAT'S OLD TO
THEM ON THE BOOKS BUT WHAT ARE
THEY ACTUALLY COLLECTING.
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO COLLECT THAT
DATA ACROSS THE BOARD AND UNTIL
WE DO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE
CONTINUE TO PUSH FORWARD AND
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO CONTINUE TO
CHARGE PEOPLE.
BOB SOME OF WHOM HAVE BEEN
VICTIMS OF THE SYSTEM SOME OF
WHOM AVE BEEN -- HAVE ALREADY
PAID THEIR IF YOU WILL FOR THE
LACK OF A BETTER TERM DEBT TO
SOCIETY.
AND IF IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO ON THE BACKS OF
PEOPLE IMPACTED BY THESE SYSTEMS.
CHARGE THEM FOR WHAT ARE IN
EFFECT GOVERNMENT SERVICES.
FOLKS OF ASK ME THE QUESTION
ABOUT WHAT ABOUT NOT YOU KNOW.
CHARGING KNOWS BASED ON THEIR
INABILITY TO PAY.
WELL THAT'S ALREADY IN THE LAW
AND APPARENTLY DOESN'T GET
IMPLEMENTED. FOR MORE COALITION
THERE BEEN A NUMBER OF MEETINGS
AND CONVERSATIONS THAT A TASK
FORCE MEETING. ONE TOWNS
COALITION MEMBER ASK A PROBATION
CHIEF IF THEY ALREADY DID THAT.
AND THE PROBATION CHIEF ADMITTED
THAT THEY REALLY DON'T DO THE
ABILITY TO PAY DETERMINATION IN
THEIR COUNTY.
THEY JUST CHARGE EVERYONE AND
ATTEMPT TO LET THEIR COLLECTION
AGENCY DEAL WITH COLLECTIONS.
BECAUSE THE COLLECTION RATE IS
SO LOW THE AMOUNT THE COUNTY
SPENDS AND COLLECTING THESE FEES
IS THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT PART.
OF WHAT'S COLLECTED TRULY
IMPLEMENTING ABILITY TO PAY
WOULD JUST INCREASE THE ADMIN
COSTS AND SINCE WE KNOW MOST
PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY WOULD
BE SPENDING MORE PUBLIC DOLLARS --
TO ATTEMPT TO FIND A NEEDLE IN
THE HAYSTACK A RARE DEFENDED WHO
HAS A RESOURCES SO IT SIMPLY IS
NOT COST EFFECTIVE WE BELIEVE
FOR MOST COUNTY DEPARTMENTS AND
GOVERNMENTS.
OUT WITH THAT MISTER PRESIDENT
I'D ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SB.
ONE FORTY FOUR THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MUCH IS THE PRESIDENT
SO.
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE.
AND I START WITH THE BASIS OF
WHO WE ARE AS A PEOPLE.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT WE HAVE
LOST OUR WAY.
WHEN YOU STUDY THE REASONS FOR
PUNISHMENT WHEN PEOPLE VIOLATE
THE LAW?
WHETHER IT IS TAKING AWAY THEIR
LIBERTY OR IMPOSING A FINE.
THE PURPOSE OF THE FINE.
IS TO PUNISH FOR DEFENSE.
THAT'S ITS PURPOSE.
THAT'S WHAT KIND OF SOCIETY WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT.
BUT WE HAVE LOST OUR WAY.
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
IT COSTS THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS
UNDER OUR CODE IF YOU BOUGHT A
STOP SIGN.
THAT'S WHAT IT COSTS THAT'S THE
SIZE OF THE FINE THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS.
BUT WHAT'S HAPPENED IS WE HAVE
USED THESE PROCESSES TO
BASICALLY SUPPLEMENT AND FUND
ALL SORTS OF GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS
THERE'S A PENALTY ASSESSMENT ON
TOP OF THAT THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS.
FOR FORTY DOLLARS THERE'S A
COUNTY ASSESSMENT OF TWENTY
EIGHT DOLLARS A PROP SIXTY NINE
DNA ASSESSMENT I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU GET A STOP SIGN WHAT THAT
MEANS FOR DNA FOR TWENTY DOLLARS.
THERE'S AN EMT CHARGE FOR FOUR
DOLLARS ANOTHER SURPLUS ANOTHER
OF V. FOR FOR OTHER THINGS IT'S
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT
DOLLARS. TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT DOLLARS.
THE TEST IS NOT WHETHER OR NOT
WE'RE PUNISHING PEOPLE BUT TO BE
LAZY AND TO USE THESE SYSTEMS TO
COLLECT FEES FOR ALL SORTS OF
OTHER THINGS LEADERS TO FEW OF
THE DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
EXAMPLES.
IT'S ABOUT PUNISHMENT.
WHAT IS THE PRICE OF JUSTICE?
WE HEARD FROM THE OF THE AUTHOR
ON THIS THAT THE EVEN THOUGH
YOU'RE YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE
IMPOSING ALL THESE BILLS NOT
COLLECTING AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S TO THE STORY.
THE REPORT A 200-013-1411
BILLION DOLLARS OF UNPAID.
FINES.
SO LET'S SEE YOUR IMPOSING THESE
FINES YOU'RE NOT COLLECTING
ANYTHING AND YOU'RE RUINING
PEOPLE'S LIVES THAT WE HEARD
ABOUT.
THE SYSTEM DOESN'T MAKE ANY
SENSE IT'S GONE AMOK WE HAVE
LOST OUR WAY.
THE DOING USE CASE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I'M GONNA QUOTE
THAT.
THE DECISION OF THE COURT WHERE
THEY SAID.
IMPOSING UNPAYABLE FINES AND
FEES ON INJURED INDIGENT.
DEFENDANTS IS NOT ONLY UNFAIR IT
SERVES NO RATIONAL PURPOSE.
FAILS TO FURTHER THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT AND MAY BE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE AND I WOULD
SUGGEST IT IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT GOVERNMENT
NEEDS MONEY FOR OTHER THINGS BUT
YOU DON'T TAKE IT OFF THE BACKS
OF PEOPLE WE HEARD OTHER DEBATES
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS ON THE
FLOOR OF THIS HOUSE.
OF THE ISSUES THAT IMPACTS WHEN
OUR ON FOLKS LIVES WE KNOW THAT
MOST FOLKS CAN'T EVEN COME UP
BEFORE DOLLARS THAT HAVING TO
BORROW FROM A FRIEND OR SELL
SOMETHING WE'VE HEARD THAT OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
THE WHAT I LIKE ABOUT THIS BILL
SO MUCH AND WHAT'S SO IMPORTANT
IS IT REFOCUSES ON US AND BE
ABLE TO ASK THE APPROPRIATE
QUESTIONS BUT NOT TO PUT THE
BURDEN ON THE BACKS.
OF EVERYBODY UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU -- PRESIDENT --
CENTERS -- ACTUALLY AT I ADMIT
I'M STRUGGLING A BIT WITH THIS
BILL BECAUSE ACTUALLY I AGREE
WITH THE POLICY AND I AM I THINK --
MY GOOD FRIEND FROM AUSTIN JUST
RING THIS BILL FORD ACTUALLY
BOTH GOOD FRIENDS OF LOS ANGELES.
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
THINK IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE WHY I'M STRUGGLING WITH IS
IS THAT IN MY OWN COUNTY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
I KNOW THAT -- THESE FUNDS ARE
BEING USED TO ACTUALLY CARRY OUT
A PROGRAM THROUGH A PROBATION
DEPARTMENT TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM.
SAID OF HIS OWN TO ACTUALLY HELP.
PEOPLE COLOR WHO -- WHO WERE
INVOLVED IN FROM THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM GET BACK ON THEIR FEET
THEY DON'T RETURN TO CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM -- CERTAINLY A
GOAL THAT I THINK WE ALL SHARE --
I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE IDEA
THAT PERHAPS WE OUGHT TO TRY TO
FIND OTHER WAYS FOR THE FUNDS
FUND IT BUT I'VE ALSO FACED WITH --
THE PEOPLE WITING THE PROGRAM
TURNING TO ME AND SAYING WELL.
YOU KNOW WITH THE OF WE DON'T
HAVE THAT THAT IF WE LOSE THIS
MONEY -- WE MAY HAVE TO YOU SEE
SIGNIFICANT BACK OR EVEN CLOSE
THE PROGRAM BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
ASSURED THAT.
NO IT WOULD NOT CONFIDENT THAT
FUNDS WILL COME FROM OTHER
PLACES -- SO I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT.
YOU'RE RIGHT YOU KNOW WE I THINK
TECHNO COUNTY THEY HAVE IN FOR
ME -- IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN DAY THEY SAYS FOURTEEN
MILLION IN ADMINISTRATIVE FEES
DALY COLLECTED FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION.
THEY DID REPORT.
THEN THAT THEY SPENT FOUR TO
TWENTY THOUSAND COLLECTIONS SO
THEY DO COLLECT MORE THAN THEY
THAN THEY CLAIM THEY SPENT ON
COLLECTIONS I DIDN'T GO AND DO
AN ACTION YOU KNOW DO AND A
AUDIT OR SOMETHING TO FIND OUT
HOW ACCURATE THAT IS.
BUT I GUESS A QUESTION TO THE
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR -- IF
SHE'S WILLING TO TAKE IT SENATOR
MITCHELL YOU TO QUESTION OF
COURSE.
I GUESS -- DO YOU HELP ME WITH
ONE AND SAYS TO TELL MY WHO'S
PROGRAM I WANT TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WELL I THINK YOU
SHOULD TELL YOUR PROBATION CHIEF
THAT THAT'S THE KIND OF PROGRAM
THAT A PROBATION DEPARTMENT AS
OPPOSED WAS DESIGNED. TO IN
CREATED TO PROVIDE QUITE FRANKLY
THAT THAT'S THE NATURE OF THEIR
WORK.
I WOULD SAY THAT SECONDLY --
DOCTOR ACIDITY PAN EASY YOUR
COUNTY MAY BE YOU KNOW ONE OF
FIFTY EIGHT ON THAT COULD
ACTUALLY IDENTIFY THAT DATA
BECAUSE A PART OF US RUNNING
THIS BILL IN A PART OF MY DESIRE.
TO HAVE THE BILL PASSED OUT OF
THE FLOOR TODAY AND MOVE OVER TO
THE OTHER HOUSE IS TO ALLOW WAS
QUITE FRIENDLY TO CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE IN QUITE FRANKLY PUT
PRESSURE.
ON COUNTIES AND PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS TO COME FORWARD TO
BE FORTHCOMING WITH THEIR RATE
OF COLLECTION -- THEIR THEIR
ADMIN FEE THAT THEY CHARGE TO
COLLECT THOSE DOLLARS A MINUTE
YOU ARE HEARING -- DOLLAR AMOUNT
THAT THEY SAY THAT THEY'VE
ASSESS LIKE YOU SAID FOURTEEN
MILLION THE QUESTION IS WHAT DO
THEY COLLECT.
AND WHAT DOES IT COST THEM TO
COLLECT THAT -- AGAIN I THINK MY
MY CO AUTHOR -- ARTICULATED
QUITE FAIRLY.
IS THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE USE OF
FEES.
WE'RE CLEAR THAT FEES -- QUITE
FRANKLY CAME INTO BEING A DURING%
THE TIME WHEN PUBLIC FUNDING FOR
THESE CRITICAL PUBLIC SERVICES
WERE CUT AND WERE REDUCED.
AND SO AS MANY IN THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUP WHO ARE
WORKING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT TIME SPENT.
IS IT APPROPRIATE THAT THE SAME
POPULATION GETS CHARGED. FOR THE
WITHTHE ANTI RECIDIVISM
SERVICES THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO
BENEFIT THE I THINK THAT'S A
TOUGH PUBLIC POLICY ISSUE THAT
WE ALL HAVE TO CONFRONT.
AGAIN ACROSS THE BOARD STATE
WIDE WE DO NOT KNOW HOW MUCH OF
THOSE COLLECTED FEES ACTUALLY GO
TO THE PROGRAMS THAT THE COURT
CITIES AND COUNTIES VALUE AND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS FOR
YOUR SUPPORT IT PRIORITIZE AND
FUNDING.
I WOULD ARGUE WE HAVE SEEN -- IN
SOME COUNTIES WHERE THE IT
SHOULD BE PERSONNEL COSTS NOT
JUST PERSONNEL COSTS FOR THOSE
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS THE
PERSONNEL CAUGHT COSTS.
ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND AGAIN WE'RE CONTINUING TO
ASK THE QUESTION.
IF THE FEES ARE COLLECTED ARE
THEY TRULY BEING USED THE WAY IN
WHICH THAT WOULD BENEFIT THOSE
WHO HAVE.
EXPERIENCE TIME SPENT -- AND
THOSE OF THE COUNTIES ARE
WILLING TO ADMIT.
TO CENTER PIN ON YOUR TURN YEAH
YES ON AND ON MY END -- I WITH
ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
ANSWER -- I THINK AT THIS POINT --
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY I WANT TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION CONTINUE --
SO I WILL SUPPORT THE BILL. FOR
TODAY -- BUT I WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR HELP THAN OTHERS AND TRYING
TO HELP ME -- AND THINK OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE SAME SITUATION TO
TRY TO SOLVE THIS.
PROBLEM THAT.
YOU'RE RIGHT I THINK THE FEES
RIGHT NOT THE MOST APPROPRIATE
WAY TO FIND THE SUCH PROGRAMS
THAT -- AND RECOGNIZING
CERTAINLY THE COUNTY STILL LOCAL
CONTROL HAVE TO DATE CERTAIN
PRIORITIES AS WELL BUT CERTAINLY
HOPING WE CAN FIND WAYS. TO TRY
TO FIND -- YOU KNOW VERY
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS THAT REALLY
DO HELP OUR KEYS OF COLOR -- BE
ABLE -- TO WHO WHO ARE BASICALLY
SUFFERING FROM THE VERY JUSTICE
INTEGRAL JUSTICE SYSTEM I KNOW
YOU'RE TRYING TO DRESS AS WELL
WITH THIS BILL IN OTHER BILLS
THANK YOU.
I I AGREE I THINK THE LAST POINT
I WOULD MAKE IN IN ANSWERING
YOUR QUESTION IS ALSO
RECOGNIZING THE WORK ON THAT'S
BEEN DONE UNDER THE LEADERSHIP
OF OUR SUB FIVE CHAIR.
PARTICULARLY IF YOU TALK ABOUT
RECIDIVISM AND REENTRY PROGRAMS
AND DOLLARS -- WE'VE DONE -- A
YEOMAN'S JOB OF THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS OF INVESTING IN THE AISLES
LOCAL PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED
THROUGH BOTH THE COUNTY CAN
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS WHO SOME
WOULD ARGUE PROBABLY.
BETTER EQUIPPED TO ENGAGE IN
RECIDIVISM ACTIONS AND SO -- I
THINK IT'S NOT A ZERO SUM GAME
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN PUBLIC
DOLLARS ALLOCATED FOR THOSE KIND
OF PROGRAMMING ACTIVITIES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A MAN PRO TEM.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES I AM
GLAD -- THE ORDER HAPPENED AS IT
DID BECAUSE I REALLY JUST WANT --
TO SPEAK TO A CALL I GOT FROM A
CONSTITUENT.
AND IT'S CLEAR THAT OUR SYSTEM
NEEDS REHABILITATION. FIVE FOUR
YEARS OF ASSESSING FEES EXCEPT
FOR THAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE GONE.
THROUGH IN A WAY TO COVER OUR
COST IF WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT
REHABILITATION AND A COMMITMENT
TO TAKING A DIFFERENT APPROACH
TO THIS.
THEN WE HAVE SYSTEMATIC CHANGES
WE HAVE TO MAKE.
I WAS THRILLED TO HEAR THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES WAS
DOING THIS BILL BECAUSE AFTER
THE BILL DEADLINE I GET A CALL
FROM A CONSTITUENT.
YOUNG MEN OF COLOR.
WHO HAD SERVED HIS TIME IN
PRISON -- FOR A VERY LOW LEVEL
OFFENSE BUT HE WAS IN PRISON.
AND SINCE.
HE DIDN'T HAVE A VERY GOOD
BEGINNING IN LIFE WHICH HE
DIDN'T EXACTLY WANT TO HAVE TO
SHARE WITH THE WORLD.
BUT HE HAD GOTTEN OUT OF PRISON.
HE HAD HAS A FULL TIME JOB.
BUT HE NEEDS HIS GED SO WE HAD
SENT HIM OFF TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM IN THE TRADES.
WHO WAS HOLDING A SLOT FOR HIM?
IN ORDER FOR HIM AS HE GOT HIS
G. D. HE WOULD BE ABLE TO GET
INTO THIS APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM.
AND HIS HIS SALARY WOULD TRIPLE.
YOUNG MAN WITH A FIANCE WHOSE
FAMILY HAD EMBRACED HIM SO WE
HAD A NEW BEGINNING A NEW
SUPPORT STRUCTURE A BEAUTIFUL
BABY GIRL -- WHO HAS A SISTER AW
FIANCE HERE'S A YOUNG MAN WHO
WAS EXCITED ABOUT LIFE?
AND THEN THE BILL CAME.
FROM -- CORRECTIONS AND FROM THE
FERRET FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND
HIS WAGES WERE GARNISHED.
HE COULD NO LONGER GO TO THE G.
D. PROGRAM AT NIGHT AT ECC.
BECAUSE HE HAD TO WORK DOUBLE.
BECAUSE HE WAS GOING TO HAVE HIS
WAGES GARNISHED AND HE COULDN'T
TAKE CARE OF HIS NEW FAMILY.
AND HE WAS A SHAME BECAUSE NOW
HE HAD TO ADMIT. TO HIS NEW
FAMILY THAT HE HAD SERVED TIME
FOR A LOW LEVEL CRIME.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE IT.
AND THEN OF COURSE WE CHECKED
INTO THE SYSTEM TO SEE COULD WE
WORK TO ASSIST HIM IN OUR
CONSTITUENTS SERVICES CAPACITY.
THAT THE FEES WOULD BE STRETCHED
OUT AND HE COULD PAY LESS OVER A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME.
TURNS OUT THEY OWED HIM MONEY.
LOWER.
BECAUSE IT HAD BEEN ASSESSED
WRONG BUT IT TOOK US INTERVENING
IN ORDER TO MAKE THEM REVIEW THE
SITUATION.
AND COME FORWARD WITH A SOLUTION
AND I WANT TO THANK MY STAFF FOR
UNDERSTANDING HOW IMPORTANT
CONSTITUENT SERVICES.
IS FOR ALL OF US AND THIS YOUNG
MAN.
IS RELEASED BUT WHEN HE LEARNED
THAT HE WAS GOING TO GET A
REFUND FOR STUFF HE IT OR IT
MONEY HE'D ALREADY PAID.
HE WAS AFRAID TO SPEND.
BECAUSE HE WAS AFRAID.
THAT HE THEY WOULD FIND OUT AND
CORRECT THE SYSTEM.
AND HE LIVES PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK HE AND HIS FAMILY
[inaudible]
SO.
I BELIEVE IN THIS BILL BECAUSE I
THINK IT FORCES US TO REALLY
FACE SOME FACTS AND CORRECT SOME
SITUATIONS THAT WE WERE IN
BECAUSE OF BUDGETARY PROBLEMS I
GET IT.
BUT NOW IT'S UP TO US TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE NEED TO PAY FOR IN
ORDER.
THAT OUR SYSTEM FULLY WORKS AND
FOR THOSE WHO REALLY DO WANT A
SECOND CHANCE AND ARE PREPARED
TO TAKE IT THAT THEY HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY.
AND THAT HE CAN GET HIS GED AND
HE CAN GO INTO THAT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM AND HE
CAN PROVIDE FOR HIS FAMILY WITH
DIGNITY BECAUSE HE HAS REALLY --
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES AND SO I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL I KNOW THERE
IS MORE TO BE DONE IT IS OUR JOB
TO DO THAT WORK.
LET'S KEEP THIS MOVE IN
REQUESTED I'VE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS SENATE
ROTH.
THANK THEIR PRESENT COLLEAGUES --
FORTUNATELY OR UNFORTUNATELY --
WE USE FEES IN THE STATE TO FUND
SOME VERY VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS.
THAT ARE CONDUCTED CERTAINLY AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL IN OUR COUNTIES
AND IN OUR COURTS -- AND WE NEED
TO HELP THE COUNTIES AND THE
COURTS TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE
THESE PROGRAMS.
IF WE ELIMINATE THE FEES THAT
CURRENTLY FUND THEM.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT'S THE
BUDGET BACK FILL HOW MUCH.
WHAT DO THEY COLLECT HOW DO THEY
USE THE MONEY?
AND WHERE DOES IT GO.
IT'S OUR JOB TO CONTINUE THESE
PRGRAMS BUT TO DO SO WE NEED
THE INFORMATION IN ORDER TO
DETERMINE WHAT THE BUDGET
AUGMENTATION NEEDS TO BE.
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE THEM.
HELLO MY PHONE IS LIGHTING UP
FROM THE COUNTY THAT I'M
PRIVILEGED TO REPRESENT SO IT'S
CLEAR TO ME THAT AT THIS POINT
TIME SOMEBODY'S FINALLY RUNNING
THE CALCULATOR. TO DETERMINE HOW
MUCH MONEY THEY COLLECT.
OKAY WHAT THE COLLECTION RATE IS
AND WHAT IT'S USED FOR AND WHAT
THEY WOULD NEED FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE THE PROGRAM.
THIS IS IF WE ELIMINATE FEES.
PROBLEM IS THE JOBS NOT DONE NOT
ALL THE COUNTIES OF REPORTED AND
WE REALLY DON'T KNOW SO WHAT WE
REALLY NEED THIS IS NOT THE
FIRST TIME.
THIS IS COME UP THOSE OF YOU WHO
WERE INVOLVED IN BUDGET
CONVERSATIONS OF A FEW YEARS AGO
MAY RECALL IN THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION -- THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION WANTED TO
ELIMINATE SOME COURT RESERVE
FUNDS.
AND WE HAS JUDICIAL COUNCIL WHAT
HOW MUCH MONEY. TO THE COURT
SYSTEMS HAVE IN RESERVE ACCOUNTS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE COURT
SYSTEM COULDN'T TELL US. FOR
THIS SITUATION IS REALLY NO
DIFFERENT WHAT WE NEED TO DO
FRANKLY IS WE NEED TO FORCE ALL
OF THE COUNTY IS NOT JUST A FEW.
AND OUR COURT SYSTEM.
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
PROVIDE ACCURATE FIGURES. TO US
SO WE CAN DETERMINE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF FEEL IN THE
NATION AND THE AMOUNT OF THE
BUDGET BACK FILL THAT WE NEED.
TO TO MOVE FORWARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE COUNTIES IN THE COURTS
AND THE REST ARE MADE WHOLE AND
THAT THESE VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
PROGRAMS CONTINUE.
IF IN FACT WE FIND WHEN WE TAKE
A LOOK AT THIS THAT THERE ARE
DEFICIENCIES THAT SIMPLY CANNOT
BE MADE UP.
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET FOR ONE
REASON OR ANOTHER.
DESPITE THESE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY
ARGUMENTS THAT OF FOLKS HAVE
BEEN -- PUSHING MOVING FORWARD
HERE ON THE FLOOR.
THEN IT WILL NEED TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
THE PROGRAMS NEED TO CONTINUE
AND IF THE STATE BUDGET CAN'T
SUPPORT THEM.
THEN WE MAY NEED TO DECIDE THAT
THERE'S CERTAIN FEES AND NEED TO
REMAIN IN PLACE IN ORDER TO FUND
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE VALUE HERE.
SO I'M GOING TO VOTE TODAY. TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND TO MOVE IT
TO THE ASSEMBLY.
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
VERY VERY TALENTED AUTHOR THE
SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK THIS ISSUE.
WELL HOPEFULLY GATHER THE
INFORMATION THAT SHE NEEDS FROM
THE COUNTIES IN THE COURTS TO
DETERMINE WHICH FEES WE CAN
ELIMINATE AND WHICH HOW MUCH
MONEY WE CAN DO RE DIRECT OUT OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET BACK DOWN
TO THE LOCAL SO THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO OPERATE THESE
PROGRAMS.
AND IF THE MONEY WE FIND IN THE
BUDGET IS INSUFFICIENT WILL HAVE
TO MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS IN THIS
BILL.
IN TERMS OF WHICH FEES ARE
ELIMINATED.
AND WHICH CONTINUE TO REMAIN SO.
I'M GOING TO DO JUST THAT A
RESERVE -- THE RIGHT TO
RECONSIDER MY POSITION ON THE
TRIP BACK TO THIS FLOOR.
AND I THINK THE CENTER FOR LOS
ANGELES FOR FINALLY ATTEMPTING
TO WRAP HER ARMS AROUND IS
EXTRAORDINARILY HUGE ISSUE. TO
TRY TO RESOLVE THE THE THE FEE
ISSUE IN THE STATE FINALLY THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
ROBB SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI.
YOU AND PRESIDENT OF THE AUTHOR
DISASTROUS IS IT APPROPRIATE.
FOR A STATE CONTINUE THE FINE
PEOPLE TO HAVE THEM PAY
ADDITIONAL FEES EN EN I RECALL
EARLY ON WHEN I WAS PRACTICING
WHY DID SOME CRIMINAL DEFENSE.
AND I TOOK A CLIENT DOWN -- TO
THE WINDOW TO PAY THEIR FINAL
WE'RE WAS A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS THEY WERE TOLD BY
THE CLERK WE DON'T DO THAT
ANYMORE HERE WE'RE GOING TO
REFER YOU OVER TO CENTRAL
COLLECTION YOU'RE GONNA PAY THEM
THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS.
AND IF YOU'RE LATE YOU COULD PAY
THEM INTEREST AND IT BECAME THIS
WHOLE INDUSTRY THAT WE'VE SET UP
SO THAT FOLKS CAN MAKE FOLKS CAN
MAKE MONEY SO THE ANSWER IN THE
LEASE IN.
THIS ONE SANDERS MINE IS IS.
NO IT'S NO LONGER APPROPRIATE
FOR US TO DO THIS YOU KNOW YEARS
AGO WE TALK ABOUT THE FOUNDING
FATHERS HERE AND I HAVE A
SPECIAL -- FOR AFFINITY TOWARDS
BANKRUPTCY AND WE ELIMINATED
DEBTORS PRISONS WHEN WE SET UP
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WE
DID A LOT OF OTHER THINGS ONE OF
THE THINGS IS THAT INDENTURED
SERVITUDE WAS NO LONGER --
VALUED IN IT WAS TO STAY IN THE
POND AND WE SAID NOT NOT IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WHEN
THE CORD SITS AND TELLS YOU OKAY
YOU GOT YOUR DO YOU WHY.
YOU GOTTA DO FIFTY TWO WEEKS OF
ALCOHOL SCHOOL IN AND COMPLETE
THIS AND DO THIS AND THEN YOU
PAY A FINE IN THE FEE.
THAT'S THE CONDITION OF YOUR
PROBATION IF YOU DON'T PAY THAT
FINE IN THE FEE AND ALL THE
PENALTIES AND ALL THE INTERESTS
THAT ACCUMULATE.
EVEN THOUGH YOU'VE DONE ALL THE
THINGS THAT THE COURT HAS
ORDERED YOU HAVEN'T COMPLETED
THE CONDITIONS OF YOUR PROBATION
SO YOU'RE STILL IN THE FALL WHEN
YOU GET TO THE END OF THE CALL.
THE TERM OF YOUR PROBATION THE
MONEY.
IT'S THE MONEY THAT PROHIBITS
YOU FROM FROM PAYING WORST.
COMPLETING YOUR SERVICE AND
THERE ARE SIMPLY HUNDREDS.
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THE FALL
INTO THIS CATEGORY BUT FOR THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT THEY HAVE
TO PAY SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
BRING THIS FORWARD IT'S LONG
OVERDUE WE SHOULD NO LONGER BE
TREATING PEOPLE CRIMINALIZING
THEIR INABILITY TO PAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR WHITE HOUSE HE
CENTER PORCHES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- I
WANT TO COMMEND THE THE SENATOR
FROM LOS ANGELES I THINK.
ARE WE FINALLY BROUGHT TO THE
SURFACE IN ISSUE THAT THING'S
BEEN SIMMERING FOR SOME TIME.
ON WHETHER OR NOT -- FEES AND
FINES AND SO FORTH SHOULD BE
ASSESSED WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
MY COLLEAGUES -- IN THIS BODY
ARE THAT THEY'RE NOT HAPPY --
ABOUT HOW FEES AND FINES HAVE
BEEN ASSESSED.
WHAT I'M CURIOUS ABOUT THOUGH IS
THAT?
WOULD IT NOT BE MORE HELPFUL.
IF THE QUESTION THAT IS POSED.
WITH THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE
POSED BY.
ODD THIS LEGISLATION BE ANSWERED
FIRST.
AND WE'RE GONNA HEARD FROM THE
CENTER FROM RIVERSIDE -- THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE.
HAVE WE ABUSE HAVE A HAS OUR
SYSTEM ABUSED THE FINES AND FEES
STRUCTURE AS A MEANS OF
SUPPLANTING LOST REVENUE -- FROM
THE STATE IN ELSEWHERE.
ON THE FLIP SIDE -- I'M
CONCERNED THAT CERTAIN COUNTIES
MIGHT BE -- HARMED IN THE
PROCESS IN TERMS OF PROVIDING --
FUNCTIONS AND SERVICES THAT WE
HEARD FROM THE CENTER FROM
SACRAMENTO.
SO BUT I I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH
THE PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
PRESENTS A QUESTION.
BUT DOESN'T ANSWER IT.
EVEN THOUGH I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF MERIT.
IN WHAT IS BEING PROPOSED.
ULTIMATELY IF IT IS COST
INEFFECTIVE.
BASED ON THE ASSESSMENT VERSES
THE RATE OF COLLECTION.
WOULD IT NOT BE HELPFUL FOR ALL
OF US TO HAVE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES.
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION BEFORE
WE MOVE FORWARD.
AND ULTIMATELY ALSO LEAVE IT UP
TO THE DISCRETION OF THE
COUNTIES.
BECAUSE THERE'S A MERITORIOUS
PROGRAMS IN THERE THERE'S
THERE'S A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OF
FEES THAT ARE ASSESSED AT
CERTAIN CERTAIN COUNTIES PUBLIC
DEFENDER FEES THAT ARE ASSESSED.
SO I THINK YOU'RE ON THE RIGHT
TRACK I WAS WONDERING -- IF THIS
MIGHT BE BE MORE HELPFUL TO WIN
THROUGH A JOINT AUDIT.
OF ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AND
THEN CAME BACK WITH A COMPLETE
ASSESSMENT -- BUT WITH THAT I
THINK -- I'LL PROBABLY ESTáN
LAY OFF ON THIS BUT THAT'S WHERE
I THINK HE WOULD BE MOST HELPFUL
FOR THIS TO GO.
THANK YOU SENATOR BOARD JUST
CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SAT.
I WANT A LIFE THANK THE AUTHORS
FOR THEIR INSIGHT AND WISDOM.
IN BRINGING THIS ISSUE -- TO US --
TODAY -- I THINK THAT MANY OF
THE THE ISSUES THAT THIS BILL
PROPOSES -- TO I DEAL WITH ARE
THE CORRECT ONES -- AND I AM I
AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY.
I WOULD ASK THAT -- THE AUTHORS
TO DO WHAT THEY HAVE BEEN DOING
WHICH IS THAT THIS IS A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE LIST OF FEES.
THEY ALL HAVE THEIR INTRICACIES --
AND PURPOSES -- AND THAT THERE
ARE SOME THAT MAY MERIT A RE
EXAMINATION WE PASSED A A FEW
DAYS AGO.
LEGISLATION BY THE SENATOR FROM
THE PENINSULA ABOUT IGNITION
INTERLOCK DEVICES -- AND THAT IS
A FEE BUT IT TO SUBSIDIZE FEE
ALL THESE ARE UNIQUE IN THERE'S
CIRCUMSTANCE.
AND I WOULD JUST ASK THAT THAT
CONTINUED EXAMINATION HAPPEN AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD TODAY.
YEAH MY COMMITMENT THANK YOU
CENTER GLAZER SENATOR HILL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES -- IN AYE AYE TO
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR AUTHORS FOR
THE THE GREAT EFFORT THAT
THEY'VE PUT FORTH IN THIS TO
REDUCE FEES AND AND AND CREATE A
MORE FAIR SYSTEM AND THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SET THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY WHEN HE TALKED
ABOUT RUNNING A STOP SIGN AND
IT'S THIRTY FIVE DOLLAR.
BASED FEET IT'S TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE BUT IF YOU MAKE THAT
ROLLING RIGHT TURN ON RED THAT
HUNDRED DOLLAR BASED FEED GOES
TO FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS FOR ONE VIOLATION.
AND IT IT LOOKING AT THE
LEGISLATURE WE KNOW WE HAVE
ADDED TO THOSE FEES ALONG THE
WAY I KNOW IN MY TEN YEARS IN
THE LEGISLATURE I'VE.
VOTED TO SUPPORT ADDITIONAL FEES
AND SO WE HAVE A I THINK THE
OBLIGATION NOW TO LOOK AT THOSE
FEES CRITICALLY. TO SEE IF
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
MAKE THIS SYSTEM EVEN MORE FAIR.
AND EQUITABLE SO THAT THOSE WHO
LEAST CAN AFFORD IT DON'T SUFFER
MORE BECAUSE OF IT -- AND I DO
APPRECIATE BY GOOD FRIEND FROM A
RENDA. FOR HIS COMMENT RELATED
TO IGNITION INTERLOCK DEVICES AS
THE AUTHOR KNOWS THAT.
OF REDUCING DRUNK DRIVING HAS
BEEN AN IMPORTANT PART OF OF MY
LEGISLATIVE A TENURE.
AND THE CURRENT STATUTE IN PLACE
HAS SOME CHALLENGES.
WITH THE AND THE THE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE PART OF THAT IS
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS SO I
APPRECIATE THE THE WILLINGNESS
TO CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION SO
THANK OF CERTAINLY BE SUPPORTING
THIS AND APPRECIATE RIVAL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR HILL
MEMBERS ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE.
SENATOR MITCHELL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I WOULD AND THANK YOU
FOR ALL MY COLLEAGUES WERE VERY
RICH DISCUSSION I WOULD JUST SAY
BRIEFLY IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW.
IS THIS BILL NOW THE APPROPRIATE
ACTION AS OPPOSED -- TO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR OR ASKING THE
COUNTY SAYS AS HAS BEEN DONE --
IN ANY NUMBER OF VENUES OVER THE
YEARS TO COME FORWARD WITH THEIR
TRUE NUMBERS I WOULD JUST DIRECT
MY COLLEAGUES ATTENTION TO AT
LEAST JUST THREE REPORTS THAT I
HAPPEN TO HAVE YOUR IN MY BINDER.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE ADMINISTRATIVE
FEES HIGH PAIN FOR PEOPLE LOW
GAME FOR GOVERNMENT A CALL TO
ACTION FOR CALIFORNIA COUNTIES.
PRODUCED BY THE FINANCIAL
JUSTICE PROJECT OUT OF SAN
FRANCISCO THE PROBLEM WITH
PROBATION THE STUDY THE ECONOMIC
AND RACIAL IMPACT OF PROBATION
FEES OF CUT IN CALIFORNIA --
PUBLISHED BY A AT THE HARVARD
KENNEDY SCHOOL AND IMPROVING
CALIFORNIA'S CRIMINAL FINE IN
FEES SYSTEM THE REPORT BY THE
LEAD GENTLEST AND SO I THINK
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT A GREAT DEAL
OF THOUGHT LEADERS HAVE A PUT
THEIR MIND TO REALLY TRY.
TO ON WIND -- A PROCESS THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THAT WE HELP
FACILITATE.
BECAUSE OF A STRUGGLING ECONOMY
BECAUSE OF A STRUGGLING GENERAL
FUND -- THIS WAS THE WAY TO
CONTINUE TO FIND GOOD WORK.
AND THE QUESTION IS IS IT
FUNDING GOOD WORK THE QUESTION
IS WHAT IS IT FUNDING.
AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT WE DON'T
KNOW.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE COUNTIES
IN THE PROBATION DEPARTMENT
SERVE HAD AMPLE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME FORWARD TO PROVIDE CLARITY
AND THEY HAVE NOT.
AND SO PERHAPS THE SUIT COULD BE
PERCEIVED AS THE STICK APPROACH
AND PERHAPS THAT'S WHAT'S
NECESSARY FOR US TO REALLY GET
DOWN TO THE NITTY GRITTY IF YOU
WILL.
IN DETERMINING HOW COUNTIES ARE
USING THESE DOLLARS PAID ON THE
BACKS OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE -- BEEN
SUBJUGATED TO OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AS I'VE SAID BEFORE I THE THE
POINT OF THE BILL IN THE POINT
OF ME ASKING YOU TO CONTINUE IT
THE MOVE TO THE PROCESS I AM
SURE IT WILL BE AMENDED IN THE
ASSEMBLY WHICH WILL GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BACK.
AND WE CAN HAVE A FULL
DISCUSSION IF IT IS SUCCESSFUL
IN THE COMEBACKS COMES BACK
PARKING CURRENTS I'D MAKE
COMMITMENTS TO MANY OF YOU TO
KEEP YOU UPDATED AS WE GO ALONG
THE PROCESS.
I'M CLEAR ABOUT THE QUESTION
AROUND THE INTERLOCK AT THE
MISSION IN IRAQ DEVICES AGAIN
THE MEMBERS WE TOOK AN
APPROPRIATIONS.
A REINSTATED THE FEE TO COVER
THE COSTS FOR THE PROGRAM IT'S
IN THE VICES AND THEMSELVES THAT
WE STILL HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK OUT WANT LANGUAGE -- THAT
WILL BE HELPFUL AND USEFUL TO
ALL.
AGAIN WE TOOK AMENDMENTS THAT
APPROPRIATIONS BASED ON THE
STATE WIDE SURVEY OF THOSE
IMPACTED BY THE FEES TO REALLY
SEE IF WE COULD FIND THE SWEET
SPOT.
IN TERMS OF THE GREEN THE THE
FEES ARE THE LISA GREGIS -- AND
FOR PEOPLE IMPACTED BY THE FEES
THEY WERE WILLING TO STEP UP AND
SAY WE APPRECIATE THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL WE UNDERSTAND THE
FISCAL IMPACT.
AND SO WE'RE GOING TO WEIGH IN
IN TERMS OF WHAT THESE WE THINK
IT WOULD BE BEST TO REMAIN IN.
AND SIXTY MILLION.
IS WHAT'S BEEN PUT BACK INTO THE
CAR FOR IF YOU WILL AS A RESULT
OF US A MILLION THE BILL TO
REINSTATE SOME FEES.
SO I THINK THAT WE THE
STAKEHOLDERS THE THOSE WHO ARE
PAYING THE FEES HAVE STEPPED UP
TO THE PLATE.
THE HAVE A MEANINGFUL --
STRATEGIC APPROPRIATE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE PUBLIC
POLICY CULTURE SHIFT THAT WE
BELIEVE IS APPROPRIATE TO TAKE
PLACE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
AND WITH THAT I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL ALLOW.
MY COOPER NINE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
PUBLIC POLICY ISSUE BY ALLOWING
THE BILL TO GO FORWARD BY
CASTING AN AYE VOTE TODAY FOR SB.
ONE FOUR FOUR THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BY ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
COVER YET ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD.
BY THE RISE OF I GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER.
BY GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO BY OUR CONDO
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES.
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LUCK NO MORALE.
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NOPE NUMBER.
HI LE CASKEY.
I WINNER.
BY WILK.
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD -- TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
SKINNER.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL.
SENATOR MAJORITY LEADER FOR WHAT
PURPOSE THE RISE.
ON TO CALL A DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
IN THE MADDIE LOUNGE IMMEDIATELY.
AND ALSO TO INDICATE THAT WE
WILL BE BACK HERE AT TOO SHARP
SHARP SHARP WERE POUNDING THE
GAVEL ROLAND IF YOU'RE NOT HERE.
YOU KNOW MISSING VOTES LET'S GO.
OKAY WE A LOT TO DO THIS
AFTERNOON IS A LOT OF TOUGH
BILLS ARE TAKING UP A LOT OF
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG SENATOR
GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM MADAM SPEAKER --
WE HAVE A REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN
THE **** CLUBHOUSE JUST OFF THE
FLOOR AFTER YOU GET YOUR FOOD
PROVIDED BY THE SENATE PRO TEM.
PLEASE TELL HER THANK YOU FOR A
WONDERFUL LUNCH.
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE MEMBERS
WILL BE BACK ON THE FLOOR AT TWO
O'CLOCK
IN A THIRD READING.
NEXT ITEM UP IS ITEMS SEVENTEEN
BY PROTO MACHEN'S.
MATT APPROACH HIM ARE YOU READY.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE RATE
SENATE BILL ONE BY SENATOR
ATKINS AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
WELFARE.
APPROACH HIM FOR YOURS.
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH I RISE TO PRESENT SB ONE
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WORKERS
DEFENSE ACTIVE.
TWENTY NINETEEN SB ONE IS
SENSIBLE AND NECESSARY
LEGISLATION IT MAKES FEDERAL
BASELINE STANDARDS. FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND WORKER
PROTECTION ENFORCEABLE UNDER
STATE LAW FOR THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION.
IN WASHINGTON ROLES THEM BACK.
SINCE THIS ADMINISTRATION TOOK
OFFICE IT IS SYSTEMATICALLY
UNDERMINED DECADES OF REGULATORY
PROGRESS.
DOZENS OF VITAL CLEAN AIR CLEAN
WATER AND ENDANGERED SPECIES
STANDARDS HAVE BEEN WEAKENED OR
ELIMINATED.
THE AGENCIES CHARGED WITH
SAFEGUARDING OUR HEALTH AND OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES HAVE BEEN
CAPTURED BY THE INDUSTRY'S
THEY'RE MEANT TO REGULATE.
A COLD LOBBYIST NOW RUNS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
AND OIL LOBBYIST IS IN CHARGE OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR.
AND THEIR SYSTEMATICALLY UNDER
ENFORCING THE LAWS THAT ARE
STILL ON THE BOOKS.
IN ADDITION THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS PROPOSED A BUDGET BLUEPRINT
THAT WOULD REDUCE THE FUNDING OF
THE U. S. EPA TO A POINT.
WHERE THE AGENCY WOULD NO LONGER
BE ABLE TO MEANINGFULLY ENFORCE
CLEAN AIR -- AND WATER LAWS.
COLLEAGUES THE LIST GOES ON AND
ON AND IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS PUTTING
WORKERS AT RISK OSHA ENFORCEMENT
IS DOWN SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN
WHILE WORKPLACE INCIDENTS AND
FATALITIES HAVE INCREASED.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS SLASH THE
NUMBER OF INSPECTORS AND REDUCED
OVERSIGHT OF WORKPLACE HAZARDS.
INSPECTIONS ON WORKPLACE HE
CONDITIONS HAS FALLEN 50% IN TWO
YEARS.
AN INSPECTION OF DANGEROUS
CHEMICALS AND PESTICIDES HAVE
FALLEN BY TWO THIRDS.
SB ONE WOULD INSULATE CALIFORNIA
FROM THE RECKLESS APPROACH TO
OUR HEALTH AND OUR SAFETY.
IT SIMPLY PROVIDES THAT WHATEVER
ACTIONS THE NEW FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION MAY TAKE
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO
ENFORCE THE SAME ENVIRONMENTAL
AND PUBLIC HEALTH PROTECTIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN IN EFFECT FOR
YEARS DECADES EVEN.
IN SOME CASES AS A MATTER OF
STATE LAW.
THE FEDERAL CLEAN AIR CLEAN
WATER SAFE DRINKING WATER
ENDANGERED SPECIES.
AND WORKER PROTECTIONS WERE ALL
ADOPTED ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES OVER
FORTY YEARS AGO.
THIS BILL INSURERS WE KEEP THOSE
COMMONSENSE PROTECTION.
I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION FROM THE BEGINNING TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSED.
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE PROCESS.
RECENT AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ADDRESS THE FOLLOWING ISSUES.
APPLICATION OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT.
IT ENSURES A MORE OBJECTIVE
HEALTH AND SCIENCE BASED
STANDARD.
SPECIFICALLY STATES THE BILL
DOES NOT AFFECT VOLUNTARY WATER
AGREEMENTS NEGOTIATED BY THE
STATE WATER BOARD.
ADDRESSES TROPHY HUNTING
CONCERNS AND NARROWS WORKER AND
SAFETY PROVISIONS.
THE WALL I KNOW THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS DO NOT REMOVE
OPPOSITION THEY ARE A
SIGNIFICANT STEP AT ADDRESSING.
ARE REALISTIC CONCERNS SO I'M
GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
THE PARTIES TO MOVE HI.
THIS AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD
SHOULD YOU VOTE IN SUPPORT TODAY
I WILL COMMEND COMMIT TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH PARTY'S.
SB ONE IS SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKER SAFETY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS.
I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU I RISE.
IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE ALSO WAS --
JOIN AUTHOR OF SB ONE WANT TO
COMPLEMENT OUR PRO TEM -- FOR
MOVING THIS VERY STRONG MEASURE
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP AND ALSO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S LEGACY OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION THIS IS
A PRUDENT MEASURE THERE SHOULD
BE MINIMUM STANDARDS AND THE
STATE SHOULD BE ABLE TO SET
THOSE STANDARDS AND WE SHOULD
NOT ALLOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO INFRINGE ON THEM.
AND AGAIN RESPECTFULLY ASK --
THAT WE ALL SUPPORT BY HOPEFULLY
BIPARTISAN EFFORT TO SAY THAT --
OUR WATERS OUR AIR AND OUR
LEGACY OF ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP MATTERS IN CALIFORNIA
SHOULD SET A MINIMUM STANDARD IN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD
STAY OUT OF OUR BUSINESS.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE SIDE ON HEARING
SEEN ON MANTA PROTEIN WHICH
ELECT CLOSE.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
I AM A HOPEFULLY PEOPLE HAVE HAD
A CHANCE TO LOOK AT THE ANALYSIS
AND THEY KNOW THAT WE ARE
SERIOUSLY TRYING TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS SO THAT WE KEEP --
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE THAT MERE
OUR VALUES AND OUR WORK HERE IN
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE THOSE.
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL [inaudible]
I PORGES.
BRADFORD.
I HAVE A YELLOW [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE ROUTE SO.
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER BY GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
I HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
BY JACKSON.
I JONES.
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
HI.
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
I WALK OUT SEE.
I WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK.
THE PROTO MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW OUR
PRESIDING OFFICER TO PRESENT HIS
TWO BILLS WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH.
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY SEVEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY FOUR BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AND ACKERLEY
NEW INSURANCE CENTER BRADFORD
[inaudible] ONE MINUTE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB FIVE
THREE FOUR WHICH HAS THREE PARTS
FIRST REESTABLISHES INSURANCE
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY SURVEY WHICH
SUNSET ON JANUARY OF THIS YEAR
SECOND CODIFIES THE GOVERNING.
GOVERNING BOARD OF DIVERSITY
SURVEY DESIGNED TO IMPROVE
DIVERSITY AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS
THE GOVERNANCE IN INSURANCE
INDUSTRY.
AND LASTLY -- SB FIVE THREE FOUR
CODIFIES INSURANCE DIVERSITY
TASKFORCE THIS FOLLOWS THE LINES
OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING FOR THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS AND ARE IN --
UTILITY INDUSTRY MAKING SURE
THAT WOMEN AND MINORITY
CONTRACTORS IN OUR VETERANS HAVE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO BUSINESS.
WITH THESE BUSINESSES THAT DO
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IF NOT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL I CHIANG
[inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RUSSELL.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE GROW
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HI HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
HI LEYVA.
I'M ACQUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY.
I'M MORE LUCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN.
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
[inaudible]
NUMBER.
BY WORK OWSKI.
I WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK.
HI.
CENTER BRADFORD MOVES A CALL
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 772% -- BRADFORD AN
ACT RELATING TO ENERGY.
SENATOR BRADFORD THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SB SEVEN SEVEN TWO
HELPS FILL A BIG GAP IN A ROW.
TO OUR ENERGY GOALS AND DOES SO
IN THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY
POSSIBLE THIS BILL ENABLES US TO
START PROCURING BALK ENERGY
STORAGE.
WHICH ARE BOB GRADE WILL
ABSOLUTELY NEED.
WE MADE THIS DECISION LAST YEAR
WITH US IF YOU ARE.
ONE HUNDRED WHEN WE DECIDED TO
PHASE OUT.
FALSE OF FUEL POWER PLANTS RIGHT
NOW NATURAL GAS GENERATION
SERVES AS BOTH.
BASS AMP PEAK LOAD WHEN REAP
NOBLE ENERGIES CANNOT DO THE JOB
FOLKS STORAGE WILL BACK UP WIND
AND SOLAR.
JUST LIKE GAS PLANTS DO NOW
NEITHER TECHNOLOGY WORKS WITHOUT
THE OTHER.
WE NEED TO FOLLOW THROUGH ON OUR
GOALS AND START FILLING IN THE
RESOURCE GAP.
IF WE WAIT THE PROBLEM DOES NOT
GO AWAY IT ONLY.
BECOMES MORE EXPENSIVE.
I HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A ADVOCATE
FOR REPAIR PROTECTION AND AND
NOTHING HAS CHANGED HERE WITH
THIS MEASURE THIS BILL IS ABOUT
ENSURE THAT OUR LOFTY GOALS
TRANSLATE INTO AGREED THAT IS
STILL RELIABLE AND AFFORDABLE.
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTY AND
BEYOND.
THE ONE THING THAT WE GET OUT
THROUGHOUT THE K. FORD'S RADICAL
CHANGE THE NOW THE THING TO MAKE
SURE IT WORKS THIS WORKS THIS
TECHNOLOGY WORKS WE'VE SEEN IT
WORK.
THERE IS NO SILVER BULLET
ELECTRICITY ASKED TO COME FROM
DIVERSE IMBALANCE RESOURCES THIS
HELP US ACHIEVE THAT GOAL
BOOKSTORES IS ONE OF THE PIECES
FOR FUTURE GRIT.
BOOKSTORE TO WON'T BE THERE WHEN
WE NEEDED UNLESS WE START NOW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SEVEN TWO
IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'SLONG TERM
ENERGY GOALS.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE ADOPTION
OF PUMP STORAGE TECHNOLOGY AS A
WAY TO MEET OUR 1100% RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO AS PASS UNDER SB.
ONE HUNDRED THIS BILL IS
CERTAINLY NOT PERFECT BUT I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
AMENDMENTS TO LIMIT THE TOLD
NUMBER OF MEGAWATTS THAT WOULD
BE AUTHORIZES A WAY TO MAKE SURE.
ONLY THOSE PROJECTS WITH
WIDESPREAD COMMUNITY SUPPORT
MOVE FORWARD.
I ALSO WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS WILLINGNESS TO
KEEP WORKING ON THE AMENDMENTS
IN THE ASSEMBLY TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THIS BILL PROTECTS A SACRED
SITES EXIST ON NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBAL LANDS.
PUMP STORAGE IS A PROVEN
TECHNOLOGY AND WE NEED TO ADDED
TO THE MIX OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
OPTIONS TO MEET OUR GOALS FOR
THESE REASONS I REQUEST A AYE
VOTE IN SB.
SEVEN SEVEN TWO AND PAUL THE
AUTHOR FOR BEING A FORWARD THANK
YOU SENATOR STONE.
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CENTER CABALLERO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL.
SEVEN SEVEN TWO LET ME BE BLUNT.
ALLAYED DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND
POWER EXPECTS TO HAVE BROWN OUTS
THIS SUMMER BECAUSE IT LACKS
SUFFICIENT ENERGY WHEN THE SUN
GOES DOWN.
IT'S POSSIBLE THATSOMEONE
SOMEONE WILL DIE IN A SCORCHING
HOUSE BECAUSE THERE ARE
CONDITIONER ISN'T RUNNING OR
KIDNEY DISEASE PATIENT SUFFERS
BECAUSE THEY'RE DIALYSIS MACHINE
DIALYSIS MACHINE CANNOT RUN.
THESE BEST POTENTIAL HUMAN
TRAGEDIES UNFORTUNATELY SHINE
THE LIGHT ON THE LACK OF ENERGY
GRADE MANAGEMENT AND FOR
FINANCIAL FLEXIBILITY NEEDED IN
OUR ENERGY SECTOR.
SB SEVEN SEVEN TWO COULD BE PART
OF A GOOD GOVERNANCE DISCUSSION
THAT WE HAVE NOT HAD ON OUR OUR
PS SYSTEM THAT WE COULD BRING
EQUITY TO HELP OUR PS COSTS
IMPACT DIFFERENT CALIFORNIA
REPAIRS.
REGIONALLY AND SOCIAL SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE SENATOR FROM GUARDINO TO
PROVIDE. TO PROVIDE RELIEF FOR
THE PO USE AGRICULTURE BUSINESS
CONCERNS AND OTHERS THAT WILL
PURCHASE THESE STORED RENEWABLE
RESOURCES AND COUNT THIS ENERGY
PRODUCTION TOWARD THE OUR PS
GOALS OF THE DAY.
I SINCERELY ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THE USER CABALLERO ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT JUST A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR.
THE RED FOR WOULD TAKE A
QUESTION YES PLEASE PROCEED.
WILL THIS BE PAID FOR THROUGH
THE RATES OF ALL RATEPAYERS IN
CALIFORNIA YES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER MARK THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING MANSON ABROAD FOR YOU MY
CLOTHES YES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS WHO HAVE SPOKEN OUT ON
THIS ISSUE IN A TO ISSUE THAT.
I I BELIEVES TIMES COM ALL WE'VE
ALWAYS TALKED ABOUT HAVING A
BALANCED PORTFOLIO OF DIVERSE
RESOURCES BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
OUR OUR PS.
OPERA FOLIO THAT'S NOT THE CASE --
WE'VE EXCLUDED A LOT OF
TECHNOLOGIES THAT CLEARLY WORK A
LOT OF TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE
CLEAR CLEAN AND RELIABLE THAT
ARE BASED LOW THAT OUR DISPATCH
BULL.
AND BULK STORAGE IS ONE OF THOSE
TECHNOLOGIES WHOSE TIME HAS COME.
WE'VE HEARD THE CRITICS OF
SAYING IT'S GONNA COST MORE BUT
WE'VE PROMOTED A OUR PS PROGRAM
FOR THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS AS
COST EVERY RAPIER WE CONTINUE TO
SUBSIDIZE WIND AND SOLAR
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE THERE'S NO SUCH CONCERN
OR CRY ABOUT REPAIRS PAN IT NON
SOLAR CUSTOMERS CONTINUE THIS
SUBSIDIZES.
THIS IS A APPROACH THAT WILL
HELP US PROVIDE A RELIABLE
SOURCE WE'VE ALSO TALKED ABOUT
THE DUNKERQUE AND THE FACT THAT
WE PRODUCE MORE ENERGY TO SOLAR
DURING THE DAY.
WHAT WE SELL THE BULK OF IT TO
NEVADA BECAUSE WE CAN'T USE IT?
THIS WILL HELP UTILIZED THAT
POWER THAT'S PRODUCED IN THE
DAYTIME SO AT NIGHT WHEN THE
WINDS WINDS NOT BORN IN THE
SUN'S NOT SHINE WE CAN HAVE
RELIABLE -- DISPATCH WILL ENERGY
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
HI KELLY ERA [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
HUESO.
HI BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LUCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NUMBER.
BYE BYE COUNTY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WIENER NO [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
CENTER MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
NINETEEN SENATOR ALLEN.
NOT AT HIS DESK [inaudible]
RUN FAST.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR ALAN AND ECHOING THE
SOLID WASTE.
WHEN YOU'RE READY SENATOR ALAN?
THINK ABOUT A PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
MEMBERS ARE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
RECYCLERS HAVE A CRISIS ON THEIR
HANDS.
FOLKS MAY KNOW THAT CHINA HAS
JUST IMPLEMENTED.
THE NATIONAL SORT POLICY.
WHICH I A DECISION IT'S NOW
BEEN FOLLOWED BY OTHER ASIAN
NATIONS. TO NO LONGER ACCEPT OUR
RECYCLING.
WHEN THAT HAS SINGLE HANDEDLY
BECAUSE THE BOTTOM TO FALL OUT
ON A RECYCLING MARKETS?
IT'S COSTING CITIES AND COUNTIES
RIGHT HERE IN CITY CALIFORNIA.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY SINGLE
YEAR.
SO IT TURNED OUT THAT IN THE
PAST.
CHINA HAD BEEN ACCEPTING.
40% RECYCLABLE MATERIAL FROM THE
U. S..
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE CALIFORNIA THAT RATE WAS AT
56%.
SO HAD MORE OVER HALF MAJORITY
ARE CYCLE MATERIALS GOING.
OFF THE CHINA.
AND OF COURSE-- AT THE TIME
ACCORDING TO OUR YCLES DATA
NUMBERS THREE THROUGH SEVEN OF
OF RECYCLED.
PLASTICS WERE FETCHING ABOUT
TWENTY DOLLARS PER TON IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN NOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE PAYING ROUGHLY
TEN DOLLARS A TON TO DISPOSE OF
IT.
SO WE'RE ACTUALLY HAVING TO PAY
PEOPLE IT USED TO BE A REVENUE
GENERATOR OUR CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND HAVING TO PAY
PEOPLE. TO TAKE CAN RECYCLE OUR
MATERIAL.
SO AS A RESULT MORE MORE OFTEN
THAT MEANS THE MATERIAL IS BEING
LANDFILLS.
AND EVEN WHEN WE DILIGENTLY SORT
OUR RECYCLABLES INTO OUR BLUE
BINS.
THE MATERIAL IS LESS LIKELY TO
BE PROCESSED RECYCLED NOW.
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM IS
UNSUSTAINABLE AND I I JUST ASK
YOU TO TALK TO YOUR CITIES.
AND YOUR WAIST -- FOLKS TO ABOUT
THE CURRENT STATE OF AFFAIRS
I'LL GIVE YOU SOME EXAMPLES IN
FULL SOME USED TO MAKE NEARLY
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
FROM RESEARCH RESIDENTIAL
RECYCLING NOW THE CITY'S
PROJECTED TO PAY.
NEARLY THE SAME AMOUNT TO
DISPOSE OF THE WASTE CULVER CITY.
IN OUR BUDGET CHERRIES DISTRICT
ONCE MINUTE HALF MILLION IN
REVENUE NOW THEY PAY ABOUT A
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR.
CITY OF LA THE NET REVENUES WERE
WERE FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION FOR
RECYCLING NOW THEY'RE LOSING
MONEY.
IN ADDITION OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE USING MONEY IN
TERMS OF A LITTER CLEANUP --
EVERY SINGLE YEAR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE SPENDING A
NEARLY HALF A BILLION DOLLARS.
IN ONGOING EFFORTS TO CLEAN UP
AND PREVENT LITTER IN THE
STREETS STORM DRAINS.
PARKS AND WATERWAYS.
AND BEACH CLEANUP SIMPLY CAN'T
KEEP PACE FOR THE PRODUCTION OF
SINGLE USE DISPOSABLE ITEMS
WHICH CONTINUE. TO GROW
EXPONENTIALLY.
SO WE NEED TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
WE HAVE -- INFRASTRUCTURAL
CRISIS ON OUR HANDS THERE'S A
FINANCIAL CRISIS ON OUR HANDS.
THIS BILL REQUIRES CAL RECYCLE
TO CONDUCT A ROBUST STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS THAT TRULY ENGAGES
INDUSTRY.
AND ALL THE KEY STAKEHOLDERS TO
BRING TOGETHER MANUFACTURERS
RETAILERS CITIES COUNTIES
HOLLERS RECYCLERS TOGETHER TO
DEVELOP THE BEST SOLUTIONS TO
TACKLE THIS PROBLEM.
IT WILL TAKE A SUITE OF TOOLS
SUCH AS MINIMUM RECYCLED CONTENT
STANDARDS EXTENDED PRODUCERS
ONCE ABILITY -- TO BOLSTER THEIR
CYCLING MARKETS TO MAKE
COLLECTION RECYCLING PROFITABLE
AGAIN WHILE ENSURING THE
MANUFACTURES HAVE A STEADYING
CLEAN SUPPLY OF MATERIAL. TO
MAKE IT PROFITABLE.
THE BILL PROVIDES FOR A LONG
HONORING UNTIL TWENTY THIRTY
BEFORE IT'S FULLY IMPLEMENTED --
THIS VERY LONG LEAD TIME WILL
ALLOW MANUFACTURERS TO EITHER
SWITCH TO MORE SUSTAINABLE
MATERIALS WERE BY USING RECYCLED
CONTENT THEIR PACKAGING ENSURE
THE MATERIAL.
THAT THEY WANT TO USE MEETS THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL.
I KNOW THAT EVEN ALWAYS
SIGNIFICANTLY NARROWED THE SCOPE
OF THE BILL TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION WE
STILL SOME WORK TO DO I'VE HEARD
FROM SOME OF YOU -- ABOUT -- THE
ISSUE OF OF OF GIVING POWER
CYCLE ALL OF THIS DISCRETION.
HI.
I MEAN ULTIMATELY THIS REALLY IS
GOING TO BE THE PROCESS OF OF
THE THE THE CAN RESULT OF A VERY
ROBUST STAKEHOLDER PROCESS.
I'M CERTAINLY COMMITTED TO
REFINE THE LANGUAGE TO GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT MORE GUIDANCE I'M
ALSO OPEN TO INCLUDING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN.
TRACK THE STAKEHOLDER IN
REGULATORY PROCESS IS A PLAY.
NOW WE ALSO WILL KEEP THEM
ACCOUNTABLE THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS THREE Q. OVERSIGHT SACHA.
WE HAD A SERIES VERY PRODUCTIVE
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS IN A
FURNACE THE SUPPORT THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES SEE SACRIFICE THE RC
MANY THE STATE'S.
HOLLERS RECYCLERS OF WHAT THE
FOLKS ON THE BUSINESS SIDE IN
THE WASTE MANAGEMENT WORLD.
I'M VERY COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
MANUFACTURERS AND RETAILERS TO
GET THIS BILL RIGHT NOW ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE TODAY -- AS WE
CONTINUE THIS VITALLY IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION -- THAT IS SO
DRAMATICALLY IMPACTING OUR
CITIES AND COUNTIES.
THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
CHIANG THANK YOU SO MUCH MA'AM
PRESIDENT.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
THE GOALS OUTLINED IN THE BILL.
ARE COMMENDABLE AND WE HAVE A
POLLUTION PROBLEM THAT IMPACTS
OUR FOOD SUPPLY AN OCEAN
ECOSYSTEMS AND AND I'M JUST
GONNA SAY IT'S ABSOLUTELY
LUDICROUS.
THAT WE CAN FIND PLASTIC
PRODUCTS AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
MARIANA TRENCH -- I DO BELIEVE
HOWEVER THE BILL PUTS TOO MUCH
FAITH IN STATE DEPARTMENTS IS
NINE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROGRAM.
IT DOESN'T REALLY DOESN'T GIVE
ENOUGH TIME -- TO PUT THAT PLAN
IN PLACE BECAUSE REGULATIONS AND
PLANS AT THIS SIZE AND SCOPE
TAKE TIME. FOR THAT REASON WAS
THE OFF THE BILL TODAY HOWEVER I
WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH.
THE AUTHOR AND STAKEHOLDERS AND
I HAVE TO SAY.
THE AUTHOR HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
FABULOUS AND WONDERFUL BECAUSE
WE WERE JUST RIGHT BACK THERE IN
THE CHAMBER TRYING TO TO WORK IT
ALL OUT AND I KNOW.
THAT.
HE'S GOING TO PUT IN THE THE THE
WORK IN THE TIME TO TO MEET WITH
ALL OF US IN TO SEE IF WE CAN
FIND SOME.
IT TO SEE IF WE CAN GET THERE
AND I REALLY DO WANT TO GET
THERE I BELIEVE IT THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT COULD.
BE BROUGHT SUPPORT SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH. FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
OUR ENVIRONMENT AND FOR BRINGING
THIS CONVERSATION BEFORE US.
THANK YOU CENTER CHANCELLOR
GLAZER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS WE OFFERING -- DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES TO OUR LIFE HERE ON
THE SENATE FLOOR.
THOSE WHO -- WE'RE NOT AWARE FOR
FOUR YEARS I SERVED ON MY SOLID
WASTE -- A REGIONAL BOARD -- IN
MY NECK OF THE WOODS I AND MANY
OF YOU RECALL THAT LAST YEAR I
KERRY LEGISLATION TO TRY TO
PATCHWORK OUR SYSTEM OF SOLID
WASTE AND RECYCLING THAT IS
DETERIORATING.
I AS THE AUTHOR THIS BILL IS SO
CORRECTLY DESCRIBED.
OF AND I THINK THAT THERE ARE
SOME ISSUES WITH THE LEGISLATION
THAT'S BEFORE US.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT THE AUTHOR'S
INTENTIONS ARE GOOD ONES AND I
THINK HIS BILL IS HEADING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND SO I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY.
BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S THE THING WE
HAVE TO DO -- THIS IS A SERIOUS
PROBLEM -- WE HAVE TO GET IN
FRONT OF IT WE CAN'T IGNORE IT.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE INTENTION
OF THIS THE AUTHOR FROM SANTA
MONICA.
AND IT'S WHY I WANTED TO ADVANCE
IT IN CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS BUT THERE ARE TWO
ISSUES THAT I THINK DESERVE
ATTENTION AS THAT WORK AT AND
THAT -- THAT -- COMMUNICATION --
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
CONTINUES.
THE FIRST IS THAT WE HAVE NOT
BUILT THE INFRASTRUCTURE. TO
RECYCLE -- LIKE THIS BILL WOULD
POTENTIALLY REQUIRE AND THAT'S A
VERY EXPENSIVE PROPOSITION --
BUT THERE'S A REASON THAT WE
CAN'T RECYCLE LOT OF PLASTICS
HERE I IN OUR NECK OF THE WOODS --
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY AND THEN THE
MACHINERY AND AND ALL THE
ELEMENTS THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR
THAT SO.
AS WE LOOK TO THESE -- HIGH
POLLUTING PLASTICS SINGLE USE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE OUT THERE WE
HAVE TO FIND A WAY IF WE'RE
GONNA SAY.
YOU GOT TO RECYCLE IT THERE HAS
TO BE ABLE AWAY -- PURSES TO
SHIPPING IT AND A CONTAINER TO
ANOTHER COUNTRY -- AND SECONDLY.
I AM SKEPTICAL ABOUT SENDING ALL
THIS DECISION MAKING TO A STATE
AGENCY TO A STATE BUREAUCRACY
YES WE HAVE POLITICS ON THI
FLOOR IT DOES AFFECT THE CHOICES
THAT WE MAKE -- BUT THEY'RE ALSO
POLITICS IN THE ADMINISTRATION.
AND THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE ANY
WAY TO PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE CHOICES
THAT THEY THEY NEED TO MAKE
GOING FORWARD IN TERMS OF THE
SINGLE USE RECYCLED PRODUCTS SO
I THINK THAT THE AUTHOR IS NEAR
THE BILL IN THE RIGHT WAY. TO
FOCUS ON THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS.
BUT I THINK THERE HAS TO BE SOME
AND BOUNCE THAT WE CAN EXERCISE
AS MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURESO
I ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR IN HIS
GOOD WORK. TO LOOK FOR WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN -- ADVANCE THE
IMPORTANT GOALS BUT STILL
PROVIDE A LEGISLATIVE ROLE
THAT'S IMPORTANT I IN THIS IN
THIS AREA SO WITH THAT I WOULD
URGE EIGHT AND I'VE.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER CENTER
SKINNER.
THANK YOU AYE MADAM PRESIDENT
AND A MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
AND WHILE THE BILL IS TITLED IN --
PLASTICS AND CIRCULAR ECONOMY.
THE ERRANT BY OBVIOUSLY M.
SOMEONE WHO IS FEELS VERY
STRONGLY ABOUT PROTECTING OUR
MARINE ENVIRONMENTS.
AND SUCH FROM THIS TYPE OF
POLLUTION THE REASON THAT I'M
REALLY STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IS BECAUSE WE ARE IN A
I'LL CALL IT A A GARBAGE CRISIS
RIGHT NOW AND I SEE GARBAGE
CRISIS.
OTHER PEOPLE MIGHT CALL IT A
RECYCLING CRISIS BUT WE SO MUCH
OF OUR INTO HIGHER WASTE.
INDUSTRY AND INFRASTRUCTURE IS
DESIGNED [inaudible]
TO IN FACT.
IDENTIFY A LARGE STORE A LARGE
PORTION OF WHAT WE OTHERWISE
MIGHT CONSIDER THE WASTE STREAM
TO BE RECYCLABLE MATERIALS
MATERIALS THAT WOULD.
BE COLLECTED SEPARATELY AND THEN
REMADE INTO A SECONDARY PRODUCT.
NOW IN THE US UP UNTIL LIKE MUCH
OF OUR MANUFACTURING YOU KNOW WE
WE USED TO HAVE A RELATIVELY
ROBUST -- SYSTEM OF
MANUFACTURERS WHO WOULD TAKE
THESE SECONDARY MATERIALS AND
MAKE A NEW PRODUCT WE DON'T ANY
LONGER THERE ARE VERY VERY FEW
ANYWHERE IN THE US.
THAT TAKE A MATERIAL AND
REMANUFACTURING SO THAT MEANT
THAT EVERYTHING THAT WE
COLLECTED THAT WE DIDN'T PUT IN
A LANDFILL OR DIDN'T COMPOST.
HAD TO BE SENT SOMEWHERE ELSE
PRIMARILY TO ASIA CHINA.
AND SOMEWHAT INDIA AND THEY
WOULD THEN TAKE THAT STUFF.
AND TURN IT INTO ANOTHER PRODUCT.
WELL WHAT HAPPENS WHEN OTHER
COUNTRIES DEVELOP A MIDDLE CLASS
AS THIS HAPPENED IN CHINA AND
ELSEWHERE IN ASIA.
THEY START PRODUCING AS MUCH OF
THESE BY PRODUCTS AS WE DO.
SO THEY NO LONGER NEED TO
PURCHASE OUR MATERIAL.
THEY HAVE ENOUGH FOR THEIR OWN.
SO THEY BASICALLY YOU KNOW
WHETHER WE CALL IT CHINA SOARED
WHETHER WE COULD SAY IT'S A
REACTION TO TERRACE OR WHATEVER
WHAT IT BASICALLY IS.
IS THAT ALL OF THE SECONDARY
MATERIALS MANUFACTURERS IN THOSE
COUNTRIES HAVE ENOUGH FOR THEIR
OWN STUFF THEY DON'T NEED TO BUY
IT FROM US.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE IS SERIOUSLY
HAVE BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN EVEN GREATER SO WE THINK
IT'S BAD RIGHT NOW.
WITHIN A CERTAIN CITY YEARS AS
OTHER ECONOMIES DEVELOP MORE AND
MORE MIDDLE CLASS.
AND THEY KNOW.
PRODUCE MORE IT'S A LUXURY TO
PRODUCE WASTE PRODUCE MORE WASTE
OR QUOTE UNQUOTE RECYCLABLES
THEY WILL HAVE NO INTEREST IN
PURCHASING HOURS.
AND WHAT WERE ALREADY SEEN WITH
THIS COLLAPSE OF MARKETS IS THAT
WHETHER IT'S OUR HAULER WASTE
MANAGEMENT OR REPUBLIC SERVICES
OR RECOLOGY OR WHETHER WE HAVE
SOME OF THE COMMUNITY BASED
HOLLERS WHICH EXIST IN LOTS OF
COMMUNITIES WHETHER SAN DIEGO.
OR ALAMEDA COUNTY CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY.
THEY ARE TAKING THEIR MATERIALS
TO THE PROCESSOR WHO BAILS AND
SUCH AND THEN IT SITS.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE A MARKET
THEY CAN'T SELL.
SO WE NEED TO GO BACK
[inaudible]
TO PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY.
GET BACK HOW TO DEAL WITH THESE
MATERIALS THAT WE ARE NOT GOING
TO BE ABLE TO RECYCLE BECAUSE
WHAT WE RELIED ON IS MARKETS
DON'T EXIST ANYMORE.
SO FROM A FROM A BUSINESS POINT
OF VIEW AND FROM A GARBAGE
REPAIR POINT OF VIEW AND WE TALK
A LOT ABOUT TRYING TO PROTECT
RATE PAYERS.
WELL WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO PROTECT.
OUR REGULAR RATE PAYERS WHO PAID
THEIR MONTHLY FEES FOR GARBAGE
AND RECYCLING FROM HUGE
INCREASES IN FEES UNLESS WE
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF MATERIALS.
THAT WE ARE EITHER PACKAGING TO
SELLABLE CELL SOMEWHERE ELSE OR
QUOTE UNQUOTE WASTING AND WITH
THAT I ENCOURAGE AND ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER SENATOR
WIENER.
VERY MUCH BETTER PRESIDENT I
RISE -- AS A JOINT AUTHOR OF AS
TWO FIFTY FOUR I WANT TO THANK
THE CENTER OF UP IN SANTA MONICA
FOR HIS.
WORK ON THIS BILL AS PART OF HIS
BROADER WORK -- TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH OF OUR OCEANS AND OUR
WATER WAYS A SINGLE USE PLASTICS
ON ARE A SIGNIFICANT FACTOR --
IN THE UNDERMINING OF THE HEALTH
OF OUR OCEANS OF OUR OCEAN
ECOSYSTEMS -- OF OTHER WATER
WAYS -- PLASTICS ARE FRANKLY
STRANGLING -- ARE THE HEALTH OF
OUR OCEANS STRANGLING ARE --
WITHIN OCEANS KILLING --
WILDLIFE -- JUST CAUSING MASSIVE
CONTAMINATION -- THIS IS A HUGE
PROBLEM -- AND IT'S TIME TO MOVE
PAST BABY STEPS. TO ADDRESS IT
WE NEED A BOLD ACTION IN THIS
BILL WILL PUT US IN A DIRECTION
TO T. BOLD ACTION IN REDUCING
SINGLE USE CLASSICS -- AND AND
HAVING HEALTHIER OCEANS AND
RIVERS ETCETERA AS A RESULT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER SIR
MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THE
AUTHOR A STATED THAT -- ONE OF
THE REASONS THE OPPONENTS HER
POSES AT TO IT SEATS MORE THIRTY
TWO CALORIE CYCLE.
AND I'M JUST WONDERING WHY THIS
HASN'T BEEN RESOLVED BEFORE THE
BILL CAME TO THE FLOOR TODAY.
YOU LOOK AT THE BILL AND YOU SAY
TWENTY FOUR NEW POSITIONS AT
THREE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
HERE'S ANOTHER BUDGET BUSTER.
400-260-01000 A YEAR IN ANNUAL
COSTS.
AND WERE IMPOSING ON THE PRIVATE
SECTOR A DIFFICULT MANDATE.
WHEN WE SHOULD BE LOOKING?
AT THE FREE MARKET FOR SOLUTIONS
WITH.
UPCOMING TECHNOLOGICAL
INNOVATIONS TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE WITH IT SHOULD BE A ONE
TWO AS OPOSED TO I HAVE TO I
THINK WE CAN WORK WITH INDUSTRY
BECAUSE WE ALL SHARE.
HOPEFULLY THE SAME CONCERNS
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING -- IN OUR
LANDFILLS AND IN OUR OCEANS SO
I'M I'M CONCERNED THAT.
THIS HASN'T BEEN RESOLVED TODAY
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CLOSING REMARKS FROM THE AUTHOR
FROM SANTA MONICA.
YOU CENTER MORE LOG MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATE ROTH.
THING THAT ARE PRESENT
COLLEAGUES I'M -- GENERALLY NOT
A FAN OF IMPOSING.
MANDATES ON BUSINESS BUT IN
LISTENING TO NPR THE OTHER
MORNING IN THE AND THE FACT THAT --
COUNTRIES THAT WE HAVE SHIPPED
THIS STUFF TOO APPARENTLY OF
DECIDED THAT THEY DON'T WANT
ANYMORE AND THEY'RE GOING TO
SHIP IT BACK TO US.
A REALLY ILLUSTRATES THE FACT
THAT WE DO HAVE A CRISIS -- I'M
NOT THE I'M NOT SURE ABOUT THE
TWENTY THIRTY TARGET TO OUR
ABILITY. TO TO MEET THE THE
THRESHOLD THAT THE BILL SETS OUT.
TO I THINK WE MAY HAVE -- TO
CERTAINLY TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD IF IT
MOVES FORWARD OUT OF THIS HOUSE
AND ALSO PERHAPS.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE AGENCY THAT
WE'VE ENTRUSTED THIS
RESPONSIBILITY TO TO MAKE SURE
THAT IN FACT.
CAL RECYCLE IS THE APPROPRIATE
CHOICE BUT BE THAT AS IT MAY WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING AND WE NEED
TO DO SOMETHING FAST AND WE NEED
TO COUPLE THIS BILL.
WITH A A RATHER SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN RECYCLE --
FACILITIES TO TAKE CARE OF THIS --
THIS PLASTIC MATERIAL AND DEAL
WITH IT IN THE APPROPRIATE WAY
AND OF COURSE THAT'S A BUDGET
ISSUE AND WILL HAVE TO BE
DEALING WITH THAT -- IN THE
BUDGET AS WE HAVE MONEY TO DO SO
BUT SORT OF AN UNUSUAL POSITION
FOR ME BUT I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY.
AND I'M I'M CONFIDENT THAT THE
AUTHOR TO THE EXTENT THAT IT HAS
ANY.
DEFECTS DEFICIENCIES ARE
IMPERFECTIONS THAT TO HE WILL
WORK VERY VERY HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE ARE TAKEN CARE OF
THANK YOU CENTER ROTH.
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
ALLEN YOU MAY CLOSE.
MEMBERS I I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
DISCUSSION I I WILL SAY -- PART
OF THE REASON WHY YOUR CITIES
AND COUNTIES ARE CALLING ON US
TO TAKE ACTION IN THIS AREA IS
BECAUSE THEY'VE GOT A BUDGET
BUSTER ON THEIR HANDS.
I THEIR ABILITY -- TO TO TO
THRIVE AND AND HANDLE THE WASTE
MANAGEMENT CHALLENGES THAT THEY
HAVE -- IS BEING VERY SERIOUSLY
CALLED INTO QUESTION REVENUE
THAT THEY WERE ABLE TO COUNT ON
JUST TWO YEARS AGO -- IS NOW
SUDDENLY GONE AND SO THAT'S ONE
REASON WHY WE'RE HEARING AN
OUTPOURING OF OF CONCERN AND
OVER THE SITUATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
FROM OUR FRIENDS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT -- BECAUSE OF THE
BUDGET IMPLICATIONS THAT ARE
IMPACTING THEM -- WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY -- AND TALKING
TO FOLKS THE MINISTRATION I
THINK THAT.
AYE AYES IS MOVES FORWARD -- THE
THE FOLKS THE MINISTRATION IF
THIS IS IF THIS IS SIGNED INTO
LAW IT WILL BE BECAUSE THE FOLKS
THE MINISTRATION WILL HAVE
REALLY TAKEN OWNERSHIP.
OVER THIS CHALLENGE AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT THEY'VE BEEN
HANDED IN CONJUNCTION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE LEGISLATURE
TO REALLY ACT ON THIS ON THIS
ENORMOUS INFRASTRUCTURAL CRISIS
THAT WE HAVE.
WITH REGARDS TO WASTE MANAGEMENT
SO -- I CERTAINLY STAND OPEN TO
WORKING WITH EVERY MEMBER OF
THIS OF THIS SENATE BODY TO
CONTINUE TO HOLD THE BILL AND
WORKED THROUGH THE THE DETAILS --
IT IT IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT'S TRYING TO ADDRESS A BROAD
PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE -- BUT I
THINK THAT THE THE SCOPE OF THE
PROBLEM REALLY DOES MERIT --
BOLD ACTION -- BUT SENSIBLE
CAREFUL ACTION AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ALL ABOUT NIGHT I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE.
AND STAND -- LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE MEMBERS
OF THIS BODY -- TO TO CONTINUE
TO IMPROVE THIS BILL IS A MUST
FOR IT IF IT GETS OUT OF THE
HOUSE TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
BY ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BELL. FIVE FOR JUST [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD.
I COUNTY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT.
BY THE RISE OF I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
HI [inaudible]
JACKSON.
I JONES.
NO.
LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY.
I'M MORE LUCK.
NO MORALE.
NO.
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible] FIVE ROTH
[inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
NO -- BURKE.
IA CATHY.
I WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI.
THIS CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARTS THAT A HI [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
RUBIO.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM.
TWENTY TWO SENATOR JACKSON
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY TWO BY
SENATOR JACKSON AND ACT REALLY
INTO LOCAL GOVERNMENT CENTER
JACKSON THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES -- THIS IS
AN ITEM SB ONE EIGHTY TWO WHICH
REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT STEP
FORWARD IN THE COMPLEX AND
CRUCIAL AREA OF LAND USE.
AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE PLANNING.
IN AREAS OF THE STATE.
AT RISK OF MAJOR.
WILDFIRE.
COLLEAGUES WE KNOW THAT THE
IMPACTS FROM CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES ARE MANY.
AND WE KNOW THE TASK OF
PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS FROM
FUTURE IMPACTS IS SERIOUS.
AND MUST BE COMPREHENSIVE.
SO OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS WE
HAVE STRENGTHENED OUR ALERTING
CAPABILITY WE HAVE AUTHORIZED
NEW PROGRAMS FOR VEGETATIVE FUEL
TREATMENT.
AND WE HAVE WORKED ON HOME
HARDENING AND RETROFITS.
WHAT A CRITICAL GAP REMAINS TO
PROVIDING CALIFORNIANS THE LEVEL
OF SAFETY?
NECESSARY TO PROTECT AGAINST
FUTURE FIRE RISK.
DURING THE PAST TWO YEARS WE'VE
LOST OVER A HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS.
TO THESE WILDFIRES AND IN MY
DISTRICT THE SUBSEQUENT DEBRIS
FLOW KILLED ANOTHER TWENTY THREE
PEOPLE AND THIS PAST YEAR WE HAD
THE CAMPFIRE WERE EIGHTY EIGHT
PEOPLE LOST THEIR LIVES AND
PRIOR TO THAT.
WE HAD THE FIRES UP IN SANTA
ROSA AND IN THE NORTH COAST WE
LIVE IN A VERY PERILOUS TIME.
DUE TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE BEEN BUILDING
IN AREAS OF HIGH FILE YOUR RISK.
SO WE MUST DO WHAT WE CAN TO TRY
TO WOULD DRESS AGAINST FUTURE
FIRE RISK.
AND THE GAP.
THAT WAS.
CLEAR AND IS CLEAR IN THE AREA
OF LAND USE AND COMMUNITY
PLANNING IS WHAT THIS BILL.
SEEKS TO ADDRESS IN THE GAP IT'S
SEEKS TO CLOSE TODAY
[inaudible]
PUT SIMPLY.
THIS BILL DIRECTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. TO FULLY UPDATE IN
COORDINATOR LOCAL PLANS FOR FIRE
PREPARATION IN RESPONSE PLANNING.
AND IT SETS FORTH OUR BEST
STANDARDS FOR COMMUNITY DESIGN.
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL STAFFING
SUFFICIENT INGRESS AND EGRESS.
ROUTES OF EVACUATION WHICH WE
KNOW IN THE INSTANCE OF THE
CAMPFIRE WERE WHOLLY INADEQUATE.
WE NEED TO DO THAT WE NEED TO DO
UP PAY ATTENTION TO FIRE FLOW
HOME DEFENSIBLE SPACE COMMUNITY
FIRE BREAKS.
AND HOME HARDENING FOR ALL NEW
DEVELOPMENT APPROVALS IN
DESIGNATED VERY HIGH FIRE.
SEVERITY JONES.
THIS BILL IDENTIFIES STANDARDS.
BY WHICH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NEED
TO IDENTIFY TO START ACHIEVING
THOSE RESULTS TODAY.
AND IT AUTHORIZES THE OFFICE OF
STATEFIRE MARSHAL TO DEVELOP.
BASED UPON BEST SCIENCE.
STATE WIDE STANDARD SPECIFIC FOR
CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUE FIRE ECOLOGY
AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE NEEDS.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS A UNIQUE
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIP
AMONG LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RURAL
AND URBAN ALIKE.
ARE PLANNING COMMUNITY OUR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE COMMUNITY AND
EVEN CONSULTATION WITH OUR HOME
BUILDERS.
ALL OF THESE PARTIES MENTIONED
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO THE BILL WE
HAVE BEFORE US TODAY.
AND I MIGHT MENTION.
IF YOU DON'T THINK THAT'S
COMPLEX ENOUGH BRINGING THESE
PEOPLE TO THE TABLE PEOPLE WHO
DON'T NECESSARILY ALWAYS WANT TO
TALK TO EACH OTHER.
AS A RESULT OF WORKING HARD
TOGETHER.
LAST FRIDAY I INTRODUCED SIXTY
TWO AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL THAT
WERE AGREED UPON BY THESE
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS IN ORDER TO
KEEP THIS DISCUSSION GOING.
AND EVEN OUR HOME BUILDERS WHO
HAD OBJECTED INITIALLY TO SOME
OF THE STANDARD TO REQUIREMENTS
HAVE NOW CALLED FOR US TO
CONTINUE MOVING THIS BILL
FORWARD.
AND I SHOULD NOTE THERE REMAINS
A CONCERN ABOUT PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL THAT ADDRESSED THE
EXCEPTIONAL CIRCUMSTANCES WERE A
COMMUNITY IS CONSIDERING
DEVELOPING.
IN A VERY HIGH FIRE RISK AREA IN
ORDER TO MEET ITS LOCAL PLANNING
GOALS AND STATE HOUSING TARGETS.
BUT FINDS BUILDING IN THAT AREA
MAY NOT BE POSSIBLE TO THE
STANDARDS WE WOULD REQUIRE UNDER
THIS BILL IN ORDER TO ASSURE AS
MUCH AS OSSIBLE THE SAFETY IN
THE SECURITY OF THOSE PEOPLE.
SO IN ORDER TO ENSURE THOSE
PROVISIONS STONE OBVIATES
IMPORTANT STATE GOALS FOR
HOUSING I HAVE TAKEN AMENDMENTS
IN POLICY COMMITTEE.
THAT ARE SURE THERE WILL BE NO
NET LOSS ALL OF HOUSING FOR ANY
REGION.
INCORPORATING BY REFERENCE AN
IMPORTANT STANDARDS SET FORTH IN
LEGISLATION BY THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM BERKELEY.
I'VE WORKED WITH OUR HOUSING
COMMITTEE TO INSTITUTE A MULTI
STEP PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT ANY
ADJUSTMENTS IN HOUSING ALLOCATE
ALLOCATIONS ARE DONE WITH
SAFEGUARDS IN SAFETY IN PLACE.
I HAVE TAKEN AND I APPRECIATE AS
I MENTIONED MANY OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE REQUIRED BY
THE HOUSING COMMITTEE.
REQUIRED BY THE LOCAL PLANNING
PEOPLE REQUIRED BY THE RURAL
AREAS REQUIRED BY THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHO WERE AT THE
TABLE HERE.
IT IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IT IS A
FUNDAMENTAL WEAKNESS IN
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITIES FROM
THE SCOURGES OF WILDFIRES THAT
ARE.
PERMEATING OUR STATE AT THIS
POINT IN TIME.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
ISSUES THAT I WILL CONTINUE
ADDRESSING GOING FORWARD TO AND
I PLEDGE TO DO THAT.
BUT HAVING CHAIRED THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT FOUR FOUR OF THE LAST
SIX YEARS.
AND IS SERVING AS VICE CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE I AM ACUTELY AWARE.
OF THE DANGERS ASSOCIATED WITH
LIVING IN WILDFIRES OWNS AND AS
SOMEONE WHO'S COMMUNITY SUFFERED
FOR FORTY DAYS AND TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND ACRES OF THE
THOMAS FIRE.
A YEAR AGO IN DECEMBER.
I KNOW FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WHAT THOSE DANGERS CAN MEAN AND
ITS IMPACT ON THE PSYCHE OF A
COMMUNITY AND SO I WOULD ASK
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
AS WE BRING TOGETHER THIS GROUP
OF STAKEHOLDERS TO TRY TO DO
WHAT WE CAN TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM WILDFIRES GOING
FORWARD WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIFLE.
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING.
THIRD A WINNER I AM QUITE SORRY
PLEASE PROCEED. FIVE I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT.
I COLLEAGUES I MUST RESPECTFULLY
RISE -- IN OPPOSITION -- TO THIS
BILL -- TODAY -- THIS BILL DID --
THERE A LOT OF IMPORTANT ASPECTS
OF THIS BILL -- AND BUT I'M
FOCUSED ON WINE WHICH IS WHAT WE
FOCUSED ON THE HOUSING COMMITTEE.
OF WHICH WAS THE ASPECT OF THE
BILL THAT POTENTIALLY ALLOWS
CITIES TO REDUCE THEIR RINA --
OBLIGATION OTHER HOUSING
OBLIGATION -- BASED ON HAVING
SOME WILD FIRE RISK IN THE CITY.
HI THE AUTHOR AND I WE WORKED --
BEFORE THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
HEARING TO TRY TO RESOLVE THIS
ISSUE BECAUSE WHILE WE WANT TO
REDUCE DEVELOPMENT PRESSURE IN
AREAS AT HIGH RISK OF WILDFIRE --
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT -- THAT
CITIES NOT PUSH THEIR HOUSING
OBLIGATIONS INTO OTHER CITIES --
AND THAT IS A REAL ISSUE THAT WE
SEE TODAY AND WE DON'T WANT TO
EXACERBATE DOT.
WE WERE UNABLE TO REACH
AGREEMENT BY THE TIME OF THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE SO THE AUTHOR
AND I IN HOUSING COMMITTEE PUT
INTENT PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE AND
AND AGREED TO KEEP WORKING ON
THE ISSUE.
WE DID THAT IN EARNEST AND THE
AUTHOR AND I HAD MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS THAT OUR STAFF
WORK TOGETHER -- AND WE CAME TO
AN AGREEMENT.
I AMENDMENTS -- THE AUTHOR
CROSSED AMENDMENTS LAST FRIDAY
WE DID NOT SEE THOSE AMENDMENTS
UNTIL AFTER THEY WERE CROSSED --
DIED DO NOT FULLY REFLECT THE
AGREEMENT -- WITH THE COMMITTEE --
IN ADDITION THE AMENDMENTS ARE
INTERNALLY -- CONTRADICTORY AND
MY CONCERN WITH THE BILL AS IT
STANDS NOW.
IS IT PROVIDES THAT IF IF THE IF
THE CITY HAS HI WILD FIRE RISK
AREAS IN THAT CITY.
AND IF THE PERCENTAGE OF LAND IN
THE HIGH RISK ZONE IS ABOVE THE
AVERAGE FOR THE ENTIRE REGION OR
THE COG -- THE NIGHT CITY IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A REDUCTION IN ITS
RINA AND THAT RENO WILL THEN GET
SHIFTED TO OTHER CITIES WITHIN
THE COG.
WELL IF YOU ARE A CITY LET'S SAY
THE AVERAGE IN THE COG IS 10% IN
A HIGH WILD VIRUS OWNS A NOT
PARTICULARLY HIGH.
AND YOU'RE A CITY THAT HAS 12%.
YOUR THAN ELIGIBLE FOR REDUCTION
EVEN THOUGH 88% OF YOUR LANDS.
IS NOT AT HI WILD FIRE RISK.
AND NOW WILL THEN GET
DISTRIBUTED TO OTHER CITIES A
RAISES SIGNIFICANT EQUITY ISSUES --
AND I JUST WANT TO POINT THAT
OUT BECAUSE THAT'S BEEN THE PATH
OF THIS BILL I HAD HOPED TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY --
BUT I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
BILL REFLECTS OUR WHAT WE AGREED --
TO AND IF THIS BILL MAKES IT
OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY AND IF IT
COMES BACK -- IF THESE ISSUES
ARE RESOLVED -- I WILL OF COURSE
RESERVE MY RIGHT -- TO PULL THE
BILL BACK INTO THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE BUT I WILL BE VOTING
NO TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER SENATOR
DODD.
THE PRESIDENT MEMBERS -- WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT -- TO MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO I
UNDERSTAND.
THAT SO IMPORTANT ISSUE HOUSING
IS A BIG ISSUE HERE BUT LAND USE
PLANNING.
IN OUR WHILE FIRE AREAS -- I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYTHING
MORE IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
TODAY WHEN YOU STOP AND THINK.
HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS -- YOU
OFFER PEOPLE -- THE THE OTHER
WE'VE WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
DIFFERENT ISSUES ABOUT PEOPLE
LOSING THEIR INSURANCE WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT RATES OF UTILITIES
GOING UP.
AND I REALLY BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS GOOD -- A GOOD BILL THAT SETS.
FOR US IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO LOOK AT LAND
USE PLANNING PARTICULARLY IN THE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE.
AREAS THAT ARE SO IMPORTANT --
FOR PREVENTING THESE WERE --
WILDFIRES IT'S SO -- WELL -- WE
CONTINUE. TO WORK ON THESE TYPE
ISSUES I THINK IT BE
IRRESPONSIBLE NOT TO MOVE THIS
THING ALONG TODAY THIS BILL
ALONG.
TODAY AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR SB.
ONE EIGHT TWO THANK YOU SENATOR
DODD SENATOR GALGIANI.
I WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING ON A VERY DIFFICULT ISSUE
AND WHILE I DON'T HAVE WILD FIRE
RISK AREAS IN MY DISTRICT I DO
HAVE -- AREAS THAT ARE FLOOD
PRONE AND HISTORICALLY WE HAVE
HAD FLOODS AND WE HAVE HAD
PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOST THEIR HOMES
IN WHO'VE LOST EVERYTHING THAT
THEY OWN -- IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN EIGHT WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY WE DOUBT WITHOUT WITH
LEGISLATION WITH SB FIVE BY
SENATOR MACHADO.
AND IT WAS A VERY VERY DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION TO HAVE TO TELL
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT THEY ARE
THAT THEY HAVE TO HAVE.
SOME BOUNDARY SAID AROUND WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO ALLOW FOR NEW
DEVELOPMENT AND IT WAS ALSO VERY
DIFFICULT TO NEGOTIATE WITH
SEVEN THAT LANDOWNERS WHO.
HAD GONE THROUGH PURCHASING
PROPERTY GOING THROUGH.
A PRMITTING PROCESSES AND SO
FORTH BUT THERE HAVE TO BE
BOUNDARIES I WILL TELL YOU THAT
IN TWO THOUSAND IN NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN WHEN I WERE FOR
SENATOR PAT JOHNSTON WE HAD THE
FLOODING WHERE PEOPLE DID LOSE
EVERYTHING.
WITHIN A YEAR THAT WHOLE AREA WE
SAW HOW HOUSES AND APARTMENT
BUILDINGS GOING UP BECAUSE THERE
WERE NO BOUNDARIES IN PLACE.
FAST FORWARD TO TWO YEARS AGO
WHEN WE HAD THE THE SAFETY VALVE
IT THE OROVILLE DAM THAT HAD
ISSUES AND WE HAD SOME FLOODING.
WE HAD FLOODING IN MY DISTRICT
ANOTHER LEVEE BREAK AND ONCE
AGAIN THE PROPERTY THAT WAS
INITIALLY UNDER WATER WAS UNDER
WATER AGAIN AND PEOPLE WERE
BEING EVACUATED AND IT AT RISK
OF LOSING THEIR HOMES.
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T KNOW THAT
THEY HAD BOUGHT A HOME AND A
FLOOD PRONE AREA.
CELL AYE I RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
MAY BE SOME ISSUES THAT STILL
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED BUT I THINK
THAT THE AUTHORS TAKEN ON A VERY
COMPLICATED ISSUE AND I THANK
HER FOR FOR TAKING IT ON AND
BEING WILLING TO WORK ON IT.
THE CENTER GALGIANI MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
THEIR CHECKS WHICH LED TO CLOSE
IT'S THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM PRESIDENT THIS IS A VERY
VERY.
IMPORTANT ISSUE YOU KNOW THE
NUMBER ONE RESPONSIBILITY OF
GOVERNMENT IS THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF ITS PEOPLE.
AND IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN WE DO BUILD
WE BUILD IN WAY IN IN MANNERS
AND WHICH WE ARE.
KNOWING WHAT WE KNOW.
ABLE TO PROTECT OUR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THAT IS WHAT
THIS BILL IS ALL ABOUT.
IT IS AS I MENTIONED IN
IMPORTANT COLLABORATION AMONG
PARTIES THE DON'T ALWAYS GET
ALONG.
BUT FOR THE BENEFIT OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR SAFETY.
WE HAVE SAT DOWN AND WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING HARD TO TRY TO COME
TO CONSENSUS.
ISN'T PERFECT WILL IT BE PERFECT.
PROBABLY NOT BUT IT IS NECESSARY
THAT WE TAKE THE STEPS AND
ALTHOUGH I RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
WITH THE CATEGORIZATIONS BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE WE MUST WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN AS WAS POINTED
OUT BY AN NPR STORY THIS MORNING.
THERE ARE SOME PLACES FRANKLY
SIMPLY WHERE WE CHOSE SHOULD NOT
BE BUILDING.
AND WE SHOULD NOT BE REBUILDING.
AND I KNOW THE TENDENCY IN THE
YOU'RE JUST FOR PEOPLE TO GET
BACK ON THEIR FEET AND REBUILD
IN THE SAME LOCATION AND IN THE
SAME WAY.
BUT THEN WE SUFFER THE POTENTIAL
RISKS OF ADDITIONAL FIRES AND
FLOODS IN THE KINDS OF NATURAL
DISASTERS THE TAKE THE LIVES OF
THE GOOD PEOPLE OF THIS STATE WE
CANNOT.
ACCEPT THAT WE CANNOT STAND BY
AS THAT HAPPENS AND SO -- I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT I AM ABLE TO
CONTINUE.
WORKING WITH THE DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS -- IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE TO THAT WE FIND
THAT SWEET SPOT IF YOU WILL
WHERE EVERYONE CAN COME TOGETHER --
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
PLANNERS OR EMERGENCY RESPONDERS
THE BILL'S SUPPORTERS THE RC RC
WHICH IS THE SPONSOR THIS BILL
WE'VE GOT TO KEEP EVERYBODY AT
THE TABLE AND IN AGREEMENT.
IT'S A VERY CHALLENGING --
BALANCE.
AND I AM COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
WITH THAT AND WOULD ASK YOUR
SUPPORT IN ORDER FOR THAT TO BE
POSSIBLE WITHOUT I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BY BATES.
NOBEL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
NO BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WITH SO -- TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON BY JONES [inaudible]
NO.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LARK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
HI STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NO AMBERG [inaudible]
IOWA CASKEY [inaudible]
I WINNER [inaudible]
NO WILK [inaudible]
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN [inaudible]
BRADFORD[inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL SO [inaudible]
MORE LUCK [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
ROTH.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY EIGHT SENATOR
MITCHELL MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY BY
SENATOR MITCHELL AN ACT RELATING
TO INSURANCE.
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
ARE RISE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
SEVEN FORTY THE UNCLAIMED LIFE
INSURANCE.
AND ANNUITIES ACT A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BETWEEN THE
CALIFORNIA INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER.
A GUY THAT IS FAMILIAR TO ALL OF
US AM LIFE INSURANCE PROVIDERS
THE BILL REQUIRES INSURERS TO DO
THREE THINGS NUMBER.
ONE IDENTIFIED THE CEASE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN THE
FISHERIES IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
TERMS OF LIFE INSURANCE POLICIES
OR ANNUITY CONTRACTS ARE
RETAINED ASSETS ACCOUNT. TO
LOCATE THOSE BENEFICIARIES OF
THE DECEASED INDIVIDUALS AND
THREE PROVIDE APPROPRIATE
INSTRUCTIONS FOR THEM TO MAKE A
CLAIM.
THIS BILL AS A RESULT OF WORKING
ON THE ISSUE OF UNPAID LIFE
INSURANCE POLICIES OVER SEVERAL
YEARS BY THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONERS AND THE NATIONAL
CONFERENCE OF INSURANCE
LEGISLATORS.
SEVERAL STATE CONTROLLER'S
OFFICES AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE RECENT
AMENDMENTS REFLECT SUCCESSFUL
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE LIFE
INSURERS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
HI BILL I PORGES.
BY BRADFORD.
I CAMBIADO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
I DOT I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I WAS SO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
BY PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER BY STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
BY AMBERG.
I WOULD COUNTY.
I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS COVER YET ALL.
HI [inaudible]
GROWTH HI [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY. FIVE THIRTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY SENATOR DORADO.
PASS ON FILE VERY GOOD WE ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE
SENATOR PELL MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE BY SENATOR BILL
AN ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FINANCE SENATOR BELL.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF OUR
HOUSING CRISIS AFFECTS EVERY
CITY IN CALIFORNIA.
NOW THIS WAS NOT CREATED
OVERNIGHT AND IT WON'T BE SOLVED
OVERNIGHT.
BUT WE CANNOT WAIT WE HAVE TO
START CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING NOW.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
CALIFORNIA HAS FAILED TO PRODUCE
THE HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
NECESSARY NEW HOUSING UNITS PER
YEAR.
AS A RESULT.
NEARLY A HUNDRED THIRTY MEN
WOMEN AND CHILDREN LIVED ON OUR
STREETS LAST YEAR AND ANOTHER
TWO POINT TWO MILLION EXTREMELY
LOW INCOME AND VERY LOW INCOME
RENTER HOUSEHOLDS.
ARE NOW CMPETING FOR ONLY SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOMES.
THIS LEAVES MORE THAN ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION OF CALIFORNIA'S LOS
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT ACCESS
TO HOUSING.
AND OUT AT RISK OF BECOMING
HOMELESS.
SO SB FIVE CREATES A LOCAL AND
STATE MARTIN PARTNERSHIP. TO
TACKLE THE CRISIS PROVIDES
IMMEDIATE ONGOING SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING FOR CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE BILL CREATES UP TO A HUNDRED
A A A THE BILL CREATES UP.
TO EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND NEW AND
REHABILITATED HOUSING UNITS.
HELPFUL ILLEGALLY POVERTY CREATE
JOBS.
AND MEETS OUR STATE MARRED
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS WITHOUT
AFFECTING SCHOOL FUNDING. ONE
TIME INVESTMENTS TO BUILD
SHELTERS.
AND SHORT TERM HOUSING IS A
TEMPORARY SOLUTION BUT IT'S AN
EFFICIENT WITHOUT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF PERMANENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS.
SB FIVE ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO COLLABORATE ON A STATE
APPROVED COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
PLANS WHICH WILL BE FUNDED BY
REDUCING THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE LOCAL EDUCATION REVENUE
AUGMENTATION FUN.
THE EMPHASIS WILL BE PLACED ON
DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING FOR VERY
LOW LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES AS WELL AS TRANSIT NOR
IT PRIORITY PROJECTS.
ADDITIONALLY INFILL DEVELOPMENT
AND REVITALIZATION OF
NEIGHBORHOOD PROJECTS OR
PRIVATIZE.
STATE GENERAL FUNDS WILL BE USED
TO BACK FILL SCHOOLS.
THE LEGISLATURE CAN SUSPEND NEW
PLANS DURING THE FISCAL DOWN
TURN.
AND THE BILL ALIGNS WITH OTHER
STATE AND FEDERAL PROGRAMS IT
REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PROVIDE LOCAL CONTRIBUTION.
AND A LEVERAGE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES.
THE LEGISLATION.
CONTAINS STRONG ACCOUNTABILITY
PROVISIONS TO ENSURE FUNDS ARE
ONLY SPENT ON DESIGNATED
PROJECTS.
AND TO PROTECT SCHOOL FUNDING.
THE BILL CREATES A STATE
COMMITTEE.
HOUSED UNDER EACH C. D.. TO
REVIEW AND APPROVE PROPOSED
PLANS PROVIDING STRONG STATE
OVERSIGHT.
THE COMMITTEE IS ALSO ONE POWER
TO TAKE CORRECTION ACTION AND
LOCALS DO NOT MEET THEIR PLANNED
OBJECTIVES.
SB FIVE TO SUPPORT BY A BROAD
COALITION OF BUSINESS.
LABOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT HOUSING
ADVOCATES AND COMMUNITY LEADERS.
WE URGE AN AYE VOTE ON SB.
FIVE THANK YOU CENTER BELL
CENTRE RAW.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES IS MADE BY MAYBE
SETTING A RECORD TODAY IN TERMS
OF STANDING UP BUT I WANT TO
STAND UP TO INDICATE THAT I AM --
CLEARLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILLS.
MY SENATOR GOOD SENATOR.
FROM SAN JOSE HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY -- IS A MAJOR
PROBLEM IN THE STATE I DON'T
HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT.
AND IN INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHERE I'M FROM.
THE AREA MADE ITS MARK IN THE
STATE AS A CENTER FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
NOT SO MUCH ANYMORE WHERE THE
AVERAGE PRICE OF A HOUSE.
IS WELL OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS HARDLY.
AFFORDABLE.
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR
ON GOING AND SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
DEDICATED TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND THAT'S JUST WHAT THIS BILL
DOES FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
REMEMBER THE ABUSES OF SOME
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES.
AND WE HAD A FEW IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY IN THE DAY.
THIS BILL SENATE BILL FIVE
CONTAINS STRONG.
ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS TO
ENSURE THE FUNDS ARE ONLY SPENT.
ON APPROVED IN DESIGNATED
PROJECTS SO I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I AM SO PLEASED TO STAND
TO SUPPORT SB FIVE I WANT TO
COMMEND.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA MY OTHER COLLEAGUES
FROM WAY NORTHERN CALIFORNIA --
ON THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE -- AS SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW
BACK IN -- TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS I MADE WHEN
I OPPOSE THE DISSOLUTION OF
REDEVELOPMENT.
WAS.
HOW DO YOU TAKE AWAY THE STATE
DEDICATED FUNDING SOURCE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITHOUT
HAVING A REPLACEMENT -- YOU KNOW
AND HERE WE ARE IN -- TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN MOVING FORWARD
A VERY VERY POSITIVE I OFFERED
TO CREATE THAT DEDICATED REP.
REVENUE SOURCE THIS -- IF SP
FIVE PASSES -- IT WON'T BE
PERSPECTIVE IN ITS
IMPLEMENTATION.
COMMUNITIES WILL BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THAT MONEY -- MUCH SOONER
THAN THEY WOULD UNDER OTHER --
PROPOSALS THIS WILL GO A LONG
WAY TO HELP CREATE A FUNDING
SOURCE TO BUILD THOSE
DESPERATELY NEEDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS.
THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS -- YOU
KNOW I'M JUST PLEASED TO BE A
JOINT AUTHOR AND A VERY EXCITED
THAT THIS IS MOVING FORWARD --
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN PURSES
THE ACTION WE TOOK IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN I THINK
CALIFORNIA WOULD HAVE BEEN
BETTER OFF HAD WE KEPT THAT THE
FUNDING SOURCE IN PLACE.
I AM PLEASED TO SEE THIS MOVING
FORWARD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON SB [inaudible]
FIVE THANK YOU.
SENATOR FOR IT.
NELSON ARE YOU SPEAKING ON THIS
THAT SENTINELS.
PRESENT LATE IN JAIL THE SENATE
I ALSO ORIGIN I VOTE I'VE HAD
GOOD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR OF THIS LEGISLATION.
HE'S BEEN A CHAMPION FOR THIS
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA.
SOME OF THESE HOUSING BILLS I
HAD NOT SUPPORTED BUT THIS ONE I
CERTAINLY WILL.
AND I DO APPRECIATE THERE'S A
SET ASIDE FOR THE RURAL AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S IN SACRAMENTO SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY'S OUT IN THE
DESERT.
THAT ARE REALLY SUFFERING
THEMSELVES.
THERE'S SOMETIMES JUST THOUGHT
THAT THE HOUSING CRISIS IS ALL
BIGGER BUT IT IS NOT.
AND THIS WILL BE HELPFUL TO ALL.
I THEREFORE URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BORDERS THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT -- I'D LIKE
TO COMMEND -- THE THE AUTHOR OF
THIS LEGISLATION.
I HAD -- THE SOMETIMES
UNFORTUNATE.
OBLIGATION OF SERVING -- ON THE
ALREADY A AND THE SUCCESSOR RDA --
IN THE VALLEY.
AND I KNOW THAT THE RDA HAD THE
SOME CHALLENGES AND I THINK --
NOT EVERYTHING WAS DONE -- TO
THE BEST OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS USE.
BUT I THINK THAT -- IT SERVES A
VERY IMPORTANT PURPOSE
ESPECIALLY IN THE VALLEY WHERE
WE DON'T HAVE FORTUNE FIVE
HUNDRED COMPANIES AND WE'RE
ALWAYS STRUGGLING TO ATTRACT AND
RETAIN -- TALENT AND ENCOURAGE
DEVELOPMENT THIS IS A VERY
HELPFUL TOOL. FOR LOCAL ENTITIES
TO BE ABLE TO STIMULATE
OPPORTUNITY.
AND I THINK THAT -- THIS AND
OTHERS -- OTHER COMPONENTS OF A
PROJECT LIKE THIS -- OR
MERITORIOUS AS LONG AS OUR
FISCALLY PRUDENT AND INVESTED --
WITH -- WITH WISDOM SO -- I'D BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT -- TO SB FIVE
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER STERN.
THE FAMOUS PRESIDENT ARIZA PROUD
JOINT AUTHORED IN STRONG SUPPORT
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT ONE OTHER
KEY ELEMENT OF THIS BILL FOR
ANYONE WHO MAY BE STILL
CONSIDERING THEIR VOTE -- THIS
NOT ONLY ADDRESSES THE HOUSING
CRISIS.
BUT ALSO THE CLIMATE CRISIS
THAT'S THREATENING THE
RESILIENCY OF OUR COMMUNITIES AN
IMPORTANT AMENDMENT WAS MADE --
TO THIS FRAMEWORK THAT ALLOWS
INVESTMENTS -- IMPORTANT
PROJECTS DEALING WITH SEA LEVEL
RISE WITH WILD FIRE RISK -- WE
NEED FINANCING TOOLS TO DEAL
WITH HARDENING OUR HOMES AND OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE I THINK SB FIVE
IT'S GONNA BE A CRITICAL PIECE
IN THAT FRAMEWORK THAT IS STILL
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE.
BUT PUTS US FOR NOT JUST ON THE
HOUSING CRISIS BUT ON THE
CLIMATE CRISIS AS WELL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I'VE
[inaudible]
CINNABAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PRESIDENT FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK
TODAY.
WHEN I TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU? TO THE SENATOR FROM
SAN JOSE -- FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
AND COLLABORATION ON SENATE BILL.
FIVE I HAVE HAD THE PLEASURE TO
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE IN THE
SENATOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO ONE
HEARINGS WE'VE HAD OVER THE PAST
MANY MONTHS AND WE ARE TIME AND
TIME AGAIN.
THAT THIS STATE NEEDS TO PARTNER
I NEED TO PARTNER WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DEVELOP A
PERMANENT REVENUE SOURCE TO HELP
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE TALK
ABOUT DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
THE CRISIS IMPACTS THE WORKING
POOR.
AND THE LOWER MIDDLE CLASS THE
MOST.
WE HAVE A DESPERATE NEED FOR ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION AFFORDABLE
UNITS BETWEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND IN FACT WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
SURPLUS OF THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND MARKET RATE RENTALS IN
THAT SAME TIME PERIOD.
THIS BILL RECOGNIZES THAT ALL
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
FROM LOS ANGELES TO LAKE COUNTY
NEED TO BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
SB FIVE ALSO FOCUSES ON RURAL
COMMUNITIES AND SETS ASIDE A
PORTION. TO ENSURE RURAL
COMMUNITIES CAN ADDRESS THE
CRISIS.
IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING NEEDS.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO CONSULT WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
TO ENSURE THAT THEIR PROVISIONS
IN THIS BILL TO KEEP PUBLIC
SCHOOL FUNDING HOLE.
THIS BILL IS NOW SUBJECT TO
LEGISLATIVE APPROPRIATION ALLOWS
THE LEGISLATURE TO HIT THE PAUSE
BUTTON.
WHEN OF FINDING CRISIS LIKE THE
RECESSION HIT?
AARON WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM SAN JOSE
FOCUSING ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ESTABLISHING AN OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE. TO BE ABLE TO PROVE
THE PROJECTS.
HAVE THE MUSTARD TO BE ABLE TO
HOUSE WORKING FAMILIES AND
SENIORS THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
SB FIVE PROVIDES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WITH THE ONGOING
REVENUE SOURCE THE BILL THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE NEED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
BUT IT DOES SO IN THE MOST
RESPONSIBLE MANNER AND AGAIN I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU. FOR THE GOOD CENTER
FROM SAN JOSE FOR ALL HIS WORK.
RESPECTFULLY ASK [inaudible]
FOR NINE THANK YOU [inaudible]
CENTERS THERE'RE.
A MORALE.
YES QUESTION THE AUTHOR PLEASE.
QUESTION OF THE HONOR ROLL YOU
TO QUESTION.
YES SIR.
YEAH I JUST I READ IN THE BILL --
REAL QUICK LIKE HOW ON HOW MUCH
MONEY IS GOING TO BE ALLOCATED
TOWARDS HOMES HOW MANY HOMES ARE
WE REALLY GOING TO GET OUT OF
THIS NUMBER.
ONE ALSO IN TRANSIT -- WHAT --
WHAT -- WHAT ARE WE GONNA
PRODUCE HOW MANY RAIL LINES?
HOW MANY PEOPLE OR IS IT GONNA
MOVE PER YEAR PER MONTH?
ON THE HAVE ANY -- EMPIRICAL
DATA ON THAT AS WELL AS THE LAST
THING -- TO I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW IT'S GOING TO HELP
CLIMATE CHANGE IF YOU COULD WALK
ME THROUGH THE OUT HOW MUCH SO
ANOTHER WORDS HOW MUCH IS GOING
TO BE A LOT OF FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE.
HOW MUCH IS GOING TO BE ALLOTTED
FOR TRANSIT IN AND HOW MANY
HOMES -- WHAT'S GONNA BE A LOT
OF FOUR AND IF YOU GIVE ME
NUMBER ON HOW MANY HOMES HOW
MANY WERE ALL CARS HOW MANY
BUSES.
AND THE SPECIFICS ON CLIMATE
CHANGE I WOULD BE.
GREAT FOR AN APPRECIATIVE.
OF THAT.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE SEVENTEEN OF
THE BILL.
WANT TO GETDOWN TO IT -- PAY --
SEVENTEEN SECTION BE NUMBER TWO
AND THREE IT SAYS -- FOR TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE TO TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY SIX THE
COMMITTEE MAY APPROVE.
NO MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING EACH YEAR.
FOR A PARTICULAR PROJECTS IN A
THE NEXT -- FIVE YEARS TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR [inaudible]
SO.
IT'S A KIM OF ADDITION.
SO EVERY YEAR THERE'D BE AN
ALLOCATION PROCESS THERE BE
PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE SUBMITTED
TO THIS COMMITTEE BY.
CITY GOVERNMENTS YEAH AND THEY
WOULD -- THEY WOULD -- SUBMIT
THOSE PROJECTS HALF THE MONEY
WOULD HAVE TO BE SPENT ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS A
REQUIREMENT.
BUT WE BELIEVE IN IN TERMS OF
THE ACTUAL.
OUTPUT OF THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IT WILL BE -- AS MUCH AS 6570%
OF THE FUNDS WILL BE USED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HELLO MY I
CAN I THINK SO SIR IF THAT SOUL --
WE BELIEVE THAT EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS COULD BE
CREATED BY THIS BILL.
OKAY BUT OKAY THAT THAT'S SORT
OF THE NUMBERS I'M LOOKING FOR
BUT YOU DON'T ANSWER YOU HAVE N.
WALK THROUGH LIKE.
PER YEAR BECAUSE THIS IS A LOT
OF MONEY THE TAXPAYERS ARE PANTS
SO I I GUESS HE YOU KNOW IF I
WAS AN INVESTOR IN THIS WHICH I
GUESS YOU COULD SAY.
THE TAXPAYERS ARE -- IT BE NICE
KNOW HOW MANY HOMES AT LEAST
ANOTHER WORDS HIS SOMEONE
ACTUALLY FIGURED OUT HOW MUCH
THIS IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
PRODUCE PER YEAR I KNOW YOU'VE
GOT SO MUCH FUNDS LLOCATED BUT
ARE THERE ANY.
YOU KNOW AGAIN EMPIRICAL DATA
THAT SOMEONE SAT DOWN AND SAID
WE THINK WE CAN GET YOU KNOW
THIRTY TWO HOMES A YEAR TRANSIT.
AND AND THAT SORT OF THING
BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE NUMBERS
THAT I HAVE WE HAVE YES SIR WE
HAVE A WE HAVE A AND ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS ON THE BILL.
AND THAT ECONOMIC ANALYSIS WAS
DONE.
IT SHOWED THAT THE BILL WILL
PROVIDE EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND
HOUSING UNITS.
AND TWO AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS IN LOCAL AND STATE --
TAXES AS A RESULT OF THE
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY DUE TO THIS
BILL.
HOW CAN IN THE LAST QUESTION ON
THE CLIMATE CHANGE?
COULD YOU HELP ME WALK THROUGH --
THE SPECIFICS ON HOW IT'S GONNA --
I GET HOW MUCH MONEY'S GOING TO
GO TOWARDS CLIMATE CHANGE BUT
THE SPECIFICS WHAT'S ACTUALLY
WORSE THAT MONEY GOING TO GO AND
HOW'S IT GOING TO HELP CLIMATE
CHANGE [inaudible]
WELL.
SENATOR WHAT HAPPENS WITH THIS
BILL IS IT REQUIRES.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TO SUBMIT A
PLAN TO THIS COMMITTEE.
THAT'S APPOINTED BY US THE
SENATE THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
GOVERNOR WE HAVE SEATS THAT WE
APPOINT. TO A COMMITTEE.
THE COMMITTEE WILL REVIEW THE
PLANS THE THE BILL SPECIFIES
THAT -- 50% OF THE USE OF THE
FUNDS HAS TO BE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
ALTHOUGH WE THINK THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE 70%.
SOMEWHERE AROUND THERE THEY CAN
ALSO SPEND IT ON CLIMATE CHANGE
ACTIVITIES WHICH INCLUDES.
NEARLY DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS TO
PROTECT -- FROM FLOODING AND
THOSE KINDS OF ACTIVITIES DUE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE SO IT BE OF
FURTHER AREAS ALONG THE COAST.
THE BAYS -- THOSE KINDS OF AREAS
THAT HAVE OF POTENTIAL -- SEA
LEVEL RISE IN CAUSING THEM WITH --
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS THOSE
AREAS COULD HELP -- THIS BILL
WILL HELP THOSE AREAS FINANCE.
IT I DON'T BELIEVE PERSONALLY
THAT -- THE BILL WILL PROVIDE
THEM WITH ALL THE MONEY THEY
NEED IT WILL PROVIDE THEM WITH
SOME MONEY.
AND IT WILL PROVIDE THEM ABILITY
TO DO THE PLANNING AND START OF
CONSTRUCTION FOR THOSE TYPE OF
PROJECTS.
THANKS FOR YOUR ANSWER.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SADDAM.
I ENJOYED THE HEARINGS WITH THE
SENATORS FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AND SONOMA COUNTY.
I JUST WE'RE NOW LOOKING AT
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES TAKE. TWO
AND WE'RE GONNA BE USING
INCREMENTAL TAX REVENUES.
WE'RE GONNA GO FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SCHOOL FUNDING IS
PROTECTED.
NO IMMINENT DOMAIN OPPORTUNITIES
THERE'S MORE OVERSIGHT WITH
WHICH IS THE IT ESTABLISHES A
COMMITTEE.
YOU CAN.
BORROW AGAINST THE REVENUE
STREAM.
BUT I I I'M TRYING.
TO TRY TO CLEAN OUT OF ALL THIS.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS DIFFERENT IF
YOU SET THIS UP AS OPPOSED TO
NOT SETTING IT UP BECAUSE THEN
YOU WOULD ELIMINATE A LOT OF
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
THEN YOU'D STILL GET TAX IN
CRIMINAL REVENUES IN YOU CAN
STILL BORROW AGAINST IT AS A
CITY COUNCIL.
SO I'M KIND OF TRYING.
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS THE NEED
FOR THIS BILL WHAT IS THE
DISTINCTION THAT.
WHAT WHAT'S THE SECRET SAUCE
WITH HIM BECAUSE OF CITY CAN DO?
THIS ALL WITHOUT HAVING TO GO
THROUGH A A FORMAL.
PROCESS AS RECOMMENDED BY SB
FIVE SO I'M I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT IF IT WALKS LIKE A DUCK IN
IT.
SOUNDS LIKE A DUCK YOUR RECOVERY
BACK TO R. D. A.'S OR ARE WE
REALLY GETTING [inaudible]
SOMETHING THAT'S NO DIFFERENT
THAN IF YOU DID NOTHING AT ALL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM CENA.
SANTA NINE CENTER BILL WHICH
OUGHT TO CLOSE.
I KNOW WHAT REDEVELOPMENT IS.
AND THIS AND REDEVELOPMENT.
THIS IS COMMUNITY REINVESTMENT.
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO PRODUCE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INSTEAD OF
HAVING AS REDEVELOPMENT DID.
JUST A 20% SET ASIDE THIS
REQUIRES 50% MINIMUM OF THE
FUNDS TO BE SPENT.
NOT SET ASIDE BUT SPENT AND HAVE
A COMMITTEE OVERSIGHT TO MAKE
SURE THEY'RE SPENDING THE MONEY
IMMEDIATELY ON BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SO THIS THIS PARTICULAR.
BILL.
IS TAKING OUT OF THE HEARINGS
AND CLEANING OUT THE HEARINGS
THAT WE HAD.
ALL THE POSITIVE AND NEGATIVE
[inaudible]
ASPECTS OF COMMUNITY
REDEVELOPMENT PROJECTS OF THE
PASS IN TRYING TO CONSTRUCT.
FROM THE MISTAKES MADE IN THE
PAST.
AND THE NEED THAT WE HAVE IN THE
FUTURE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
A PROPER LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL.
TO ACTUALLY SOLVE A PROBLEM OF
NOT HAVING ENOUGH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL ACCOMPLISH THIS THAT
ARE CHEN AYE VOTE ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES.
BELL HI HI. FOR JUST.
BY BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO HI -- TADO
[inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NO AMBERG IOWA CASKEY I WINNER
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
HI.
SIR RICHARD PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERSHIP [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FORMER
TIMES SECTOR [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
OF ICE THIRTY ONE KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE CENTER [inaudible]
CURRENT.
WERE LIFTING THE CALL ON FI FILE
ITEM.
TWENTY TWO SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI I BRADFORD [inaudible]
CAFIERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
ROTH BY [inaudible]
GLAZER.
CALL CALL THE RUMOR JOHN.
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
BY HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL.
I WITH SO BRADFORD ARE I HUESO
AYE BRADFORD AYE.
ICE TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS NINE THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE SENATOR
ALLEN ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE
THAT MEASURE UP.
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR ALAN AND ACTUALLY ENDED
TENDENCY.
SENATOR ALLEN MISTER PRESIDENT
SB SIX THIRTY EIGHT HELPS
RENTERS ACCESS ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING STATIONS BY REFORMING
INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS TIED TO
THEIR INSTALLATION.
NOW WE HAD SOME REASON FOR
MEMBERS THAT WERE CLARIFYING IN
THE BILL'S RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT SO FAR AS NO OPPOSITION.
RESPECT FRESNO VOCAL.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SCENE.
NINE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN HI HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
BELL.
HI PORGES.
BRADFORD.
I COMING AT ALL.
I CHIANG I DODD.
AYE DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
HI AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
I TITLE HI [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
HI JONES [inaudible]
THE LEVER.
BY MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY THE TO BUY MORE LOCK.
MORRELL I WENT BY [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
BY AMBERG.
VIA CASKEY.
BY WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
HI. THIRTY THREE ONE MOMENT ONE
MOMENT.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME SECRETARY BATES
[inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
ICE THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW WE'RE MOVING
BACK TO FILE FILE ITEM TN BY
SENATOR DORADO ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR THAT.
ITEM THANK YOU.
THE SECTOR PLEASE READ SAID
ABOUT FIVE TWENTY NINE BY
SENATOR ALSO AN ACT RELATING TO
TENDENCY SENATOR FLOORS YOURS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
[inaudible]
THE BACK AGAIN -- THANK YOU ALL
FOR THE RECONSIDERATION.
SB FIVE TWO NINE WOULD REQUIRE A
LANDLORD.
EVICTING THE TENANT. TO HAVE AND
STATE THEIR REASON FOR THE
EVICTION [inaudible]
ONLY IF.
THE TENANT IS IN THE TENANT
ASSOCIATION.
CONSISTING OF THREE OR MORE
UNITS. THREE OR MORE UNITS OWNED
BY THAT LANDLORD.
AND THE ASSOCIATION HAS ADOPTED
BY LAWS OR AN OPERATING
AGREEMENT [inaudible]
BECAUSE NOT JUST BECAUSE BECAUSE
MUST BE STATED IN WRITING.
AND BE THE DOMINANT MOTIVE FOR
THE TERMINATION ARE YOU FICTION.
THIS BILL HAS BEEN NARROWED
[inaudible]
TREMENDOUSLY BY NO LONGER
INCLUDING THE RENT WITH HOLDING
THE RENT STRIKE [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
WE ALL KNOW RENTERS WE TELL
STORIES ALL THE TIME ABOUT
RENTER'S FACING AN X.. THREE
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT REALITY
IN CALIFORNIA.
WHERE NEARLY HALF OF
CALIFORNIANS [inaudible]
OR RENTER'S.
HALF OF CALIFORNIANS ARE RENTERS
ACROSS THE BOARD. 44% ARE TRYING
TO RAISE THEIR FAMILIES.
SB FIVE TWO NINE SIX TO EQUALIZE
THOSE TEN INVOICES.
IN CALIFORNIA HOUSING SHORTAGES
HAVE REACHED CRISIS LEVELS.
THE ALLOWING OF BOYS FOR THE
RENTERS IS CRITICAL.
IT EMPOWERS INDIVIDUALS TO ACT
WITHOUT FEAR NOW WE FIGHT FOR
LANGUAGE AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT
OR AND WHISTLE BLOWER CASES.
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL.
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK UP ON
THEIR ISSUES IN THIS CASE.
LIVING STANDARDS TO PROTECT THE
FAMILY INSTABILITY OF THEIR
FAMILIES.
THE SAFETY AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WE ALL ARE USING THE TERM.
PRODUCTION WERE FOR PRODUCING
MORE HOUSING PRESERVATION LET'S
HOLD ON TO THE HOUSING THAT WE
HAVE.
BUT PROTECTION IS AS IS AS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE PRODUCTION IS
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN FOR SEVERAL
YEARS.
CENTRAL TO THE ABILITY OF
INDIVIDUALS IS TO JOIN TOGETHER.
ALLOW THEM TO DO THAT WITHOUT
THEM FEELING THAT THEY'RE TAKING
THE RISK OF HARM AND RETALIATION.
COLLEAGUES I KNOW WE MIGHT EACH
HAVE.
SOME STORIES ANECDOTAL STORIES
OF SOME BAD TENANT OR TEN AND
THAT DIDN'T BEHAVE.
THAT SHOULD NOT GET IN THE WAY
OF PROTECTING TENANTS WHEN THEY
COME TOGETHER AS NEIGHBORS TO
SAY.
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG HERE.
WE WANT TO FIX WE WANTED FIXED.
COLLEAGUES I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION A BIT ON THE SIDE OF
CENTER RUBIO.
YES THANK YOU FOR FOR SO I WANNA
AT I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR
BRINGING THIS UP I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS
BUT YOU KNOW AS WE KNOW.
I HOUSING IS AN ISSUE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THAT WE LOOK AT POLICIES
LIKE HERS AND I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
UP IN.
AND TAKING SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU KNOW SOME
FOLKS HAVE CONCERNS OF I KNOW
SOME.
PEOPLE ARE STILL CONFUSED ABOUT
THE WITH HOLDEN RENT AND SHE
MADE A VERY CLEAR THAT THAT'S
NOT PART OF THIS BILL.
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY AGAIN
THANK YOU AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER BORDERS.
WE WE WE DISCUSSED THIS ISSUE
YESTERDAY -- I'M NOT CERTAIN HOW
MUCH -- THE SENTIMENTS OF
CHANGED.
BUT ALL ABBREVIATE WHAT I'VE
MENTIONED BEFORE -- MY CONCERN
IS THAT THIS IS ONE STEP REMOVED
FROM RENT CONTROL.
WHICH THE VOTERS SOUNDLY
REJECTED -- AT THE THE VOTING
BOOTH -- IN THE REASON FOR THAT
IS WHEN YOU.
ARE CREATING A TENANT UNION IF
YOU WILL OR SO SEE ATION.
IT IS ONLY A MATTER OF TIME
BEFORE THAT ORGANIZATION IS
GOING TO COLLECTIVELY DEMANDS --
A REDUCTION IN RENT.
AND THAT IS ONE OF MY WHAT IS
ONE OF MY ONE OF MY CONCERNS.
AND I THINK I EXPRESS THAT TO
YOU BEFORE BUT IT'S ALSO YOU
KNOW VOTER INTEGRITY.
WE WE'VE ALREADY VOTED IS IS A
STATE ON THIS ISSUE RECENTLY.
AND THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
THAT WAS -- REJECTED.
BUT PROMOTE ANOTHER POINT WOULD
BEING.
WE HAVING CREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
TENANT PROTECTIONS.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I THINK THE NARRATIVE THAT HAS
BEEN PUT OUT THERE IS THAT THERE
IS A LIST.
OF BAD LANDLORDS AND YES THERE
ARE BAD LAND LANDLORDS IN FACT
DURING MY TIME ON AT THE CITY OF
FRESNO.
WE HAD INSTITUTE -- SLUM LORD --
RULES TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
PEOPLE WERE ABIDING BY
CALIFORNIA SAFE A HABITATION
STANDARDS.
ARE AND WE USED ALL THE HEROES
IN THE CORNER QUIVER TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT WE HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
OKAY I GUESS WHAT WHEN I'M
SAYING IS THAT THE NEAR THAT'S
PUT OUT THERE.
IS THAT INDIVIDUALS DON'T HAVE
THE RIGHT TO ASSOCIATE AND
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THAT INDIVIDUALS DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SEEK RECOURSE WITH
THE AUTHORITIES ARE AND THAT'S
NOT TRUE THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO SEEK REDRESS IN
THE COURTS AND THAT'S NOT TRUE.
STORE CREATING THIS THIS
NARRATIVE AYE I FRANKLY FIND.
INACCURATE.
ARMY AND I THINK WHAT THIS GOES
TO IS THAT.
THE IDEA OF ASSEMBLING
INDIVIDUALS INTO A UNION IS NOT
FOR SAFE HABITATION.
IT IS FOR RENT CONTROL AND
THAT'S WHERE THIS IS GOING I
FEAR AND THAT'S REASON I
RESPECTFULLY -- HAVE TO BE A NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN.
SPECIALIST JOURNALIST SENATE.
ANY TIME YOU TRY TO RESTRICT
SOMETHING.
THEN THE PRICE USUALLY WILL GO
OUT.
THAT'S BEEN PROVEN BY RENT
CONTROL MEASURES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
AND WOULD IT BE THE TENANTS THAT
PUT UP THE MONEY.
THE BILL THESE UNITS NOW.
IT'S SOME KIND OF INVESTOR.
AND SOMETIMES THESE AREN'T BIG
RICH PEOPLE THERE.
THE MOM AND POPS THAT HAVE FOR
FIVE TEN UNITS.
THE BILL ROPER PERIOD OF TIME
MANY FAMILIES.
HAVE THAT SIDE ENTERPRISE.
IN THIS IS IN FACT.
GOING TO MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT.
FOR US TO HAVE SECURE HOUSING.
FOR THE POPULATION.
JUST AN EXAMPLE [inaudible]
PARADISE [inaudible]
BURNED OUT.
WHERE DO ALL THOSE PEOPLE GO?
THERE'S NO HOUSING AVAILABLE.
AND IN TERMS OF ANYTHING BE IN.
FAST TO BUILD I I'M NOT.
STILL I OF AN INSEPARABLE
OPTIMISTIC WE CAN DO SOMETHING
IN CALIFORNIA.
EXPEDITE THE PERMITTING PROCESS
SEES LOCAL AND STATE.
THAT CHAU IMPEDE.
AN ADD TO THE COSTS.
I REMEMBER AN ADVOCATE OF THE
HOMELESS SPEAKING.
THE CZECHO TWO YEARS AGO.
CONDEMNING WHAT CALIFORNIA HAD
DONE TO MAKE HOUSING SO
EXPENSIVE.
SO EXPENSIVE THAT EVEN THE
HOMELESS COULD NOT FIND
FACILITIES.
THAT WERE BUILT. FOR THEM.
BECAUSE THEN WHAT THEY
COMPLAINED ABOUT SPECIFICALLY
WAS A SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
ADDED TO THE COST.
AND SHE ARGUED HOW MANY MORE.
HOMELESS PEOPLE COULD BE HOUSE
BUT FOR THE FREE HEARING AWAY.
OF THOSE DOLLARS [inaudible]
THIS.
I I THINK IT'S IT'S A A SOLUTION.
CHECKING A PROBLEM.
THAT DOESN'T EXIST.
I URGE A NO VOTE [inaudible]
WIENER GIRL.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE AGAIN I'M IN OPPOSITION
YESTERDAY AFTER WE HEARD THIS
BILL.
AND LEGALLY DEBATE THAT WENT
BACK AND FORTH IN WE GET EMAILS
CALLS TEXT MESSAGES.
I'M ON THE UNFAIRNESS A LOT OF
THE TIMES BETWEEN THE TENANT AND
THE LANDLORD.
I SHARED SOME STORIES YESTERDAY
WHERE WE HAVE LANDLORDS.
THAT -- IT TAKES MONTHS ALMOST
TWO YEARS SOMETIMES YEARS TO GET
SOMEBODY OUT OF AN APARTMENT.
AND THEN WHEN THEY LEAVE I HEARD
A STORY YESTERDAY AFTER THIS WAS
DEBATED ON THE FLOOR THEY RIPPED
OUT THE CABINETS TO THE
APPLIANCES.
AND THERE'S NOTHING THAT CAN BE
DONE -- TO THE TENANTS THAT DO
THESE THINGS SO I UNDERSTAND AND
I APPLAUD THE AUTHOR ABOUT
MAKING SURE AND LIKE THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LA TALKED ABOUT
YESTERDAY WERE AT A LADY WOULD
LIVED IN APARTMENT. FOR THIRTY
YEARS IS IS BEING A TRYING TO BE
EVICTED AND AND IT HAD YOU KNOW
INTERVIEW MENTION HAD TO TAKE
PLACE.
SO I GET THAT BUT THE LONG RULES
THAT THIS BODY HAS CREATED --
OVER THE LENGTH OF TIME -- OVER
THE OF THE LAST DECADE HAS
CREATED AN IMPACT OF COST AND
FEES WERE 53% OF THE STATE SAYS
THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE HERE
AND IF YOU TAKE THAT TO
MILLENNIALS AT 63%.
MOST OF THESE PEOPLE RENT --
HOUSING AND THESE FIVE
ORGANIZATIONS OR ASSOCIATIONS
THAT ARE TRYING TO BE FORMED.
IT'S ALL ABOUT REDUCING THE COST
OF HOUSING AND I GET IT BECAUSE
HOUSING IS EXPENSIVE.
BUT RENT CONTROL WAS VOTED ON
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO
SAID OVERWHELMINGLY BY THE
VOTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY VOTED TO NOT ALLOW RENT
CONTROL TO BE PART OF THE
PROCESS.
AND SO TO COME UP WITH BILLS
THEY HAVE AN END RUN AROUND THAT
AND THE ONE THAT'S ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE HOUSE -- TO
BLATANTLY JUST REINTRODUCE THAT
BILL AND GO AROUND THE VOTERS
IT'S JUST NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING SO I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR AT LEAST BRINGING UP
THE ISSUE -- ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW
THE HOUSING ISSUE WHEN THAT THE
RENTERS THAT NEED A PLACES TO
LIVE IN I AGREE IF IT WASN'T
SOMEONE AFFORDABLE I THINK
PEOPLE WOULD BE PURSUING THE
AMERICAN DREAM AND BUYING A HOME
AND YOU KNOW THERE'S BEEN BILLS
THAT WE'VE AUTHORED OR THEY HAVE
BEEN.
OFF THIS FLOOR THIS WEEK ABOUT
ALLOWING YOU KNOW RENTERS
CREDITS FOR YOU KNOW
ESTABLISHING CREDIT FOR THE RENT
PAYMENTS AND I THINK THAT'S
PRETTY PHENOMENAL AND WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE
REDUCTION OF COST OF HOUSING.
AND WE NEED TO WORK ON GOOD
POLICY IN THIS HOUSE THAT
GENERATES HOUSING -- FOR ALL OF
US AND AND OUR CONSTITUENTS TO
LIVE AND SO I WOULD I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
IN ADDITION DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM.
SHE JONES SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
I'LL START OFF BY SAYING THAT --
YOU KNOW CURRENTLY MY WIFE AND I
ARE RENTERS AND HAVE BEEN FOR
ABOUT TEN YEARS.
SO I AM -- PARTICULARLY
INTERESTED IN THIS BILL.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ASK A
QUESTION THE AUTHOR IF I MAY
MISTER PRESIDENT.
IN DRUGS ARE YOU TO QUESTION YES.
THANK YOU SIR -- I I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE OPERATION OF
THE ASSOCIATION.
AND SO -- CAN YOU SPEAK TO YOU
ON THE FUND RAISING CAPABILITIES
OF THIS SOCIALLY HOW WOULD THEY
FUNDRAISE.
POWER THE YOU KNOW PAY FOR THEIR
IF THEY'RE GOING TO HIRE A STAFF
MEMBER YOU KNOW TO BE TO OPERATE
THE ASSOCIATION -- YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT ARE THE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS BE BEHIND THAT YOU
KNOW POLITICAL ACTION CAN THEY
FORM A POLITICAL ACTION
COMMITTEE.
AND THEN BECOME POLITICALLY
ACTIVE IN THEIR COMMUNITY AS AN
ASSOCIATION.
AND SAUCER WITH THOSE TWO
QUESTIONS SO FUND RAISING AND
POLITICAL ACTION -- IN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY [inaudible]
SENATOR. ONE RESPONSE.
YES THIS DOES NOT ADDRESS.
THE FORMATION THE PARTICULARS
THAT TECHNICAL ISSUES.
THERE ARE OF RULES THAT.
SOME OF THE MMHM GO TO TENANT
ASSOCIATIONS BUT THIS IS NOT
INTENDED TO CREATE THE
OPERATIONS OF THE TENANT
ASSOCIATION TEN ASSOCIATIONS GET
FORM THEY HAVE THEIR BY LAWS.
WE DON'T GET INTO THAT WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS A
BONAFIDE ASSOCIATION.
WE'RE NOT IN THIS LAW MAKING ANY
REFERENCE TO HALL WHERE THE HOW
IT'S STRUCTURED OR WHAT IT HOW
IT.
FUNCTIONS THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT
THE PLACE OF THIS BILL THIS BILL
IS SIMPLY TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
OF RETALIATION.
IN CASE OF A TENANT IN VERY
LIMITED VERY NARROW
CIRCUMSTANCES IT'S NOT.
THE BIG YOU KNOW EVERYBODY IT'S
A VERY VERY NARROW CIRCUMSTANCE
ONLY HAS TO DO WITH RETALIATION.
IF IT'S A TENANT.
THAT HAS JOINED AN ASSOCIATION
AND AGAIN IT'S VERY SPECIFIC TO
THE NUMBER OF UNITS THREE A MORE
UNITS OF THE SAME LANDLORD.
YOU KNOW THIS IS THIS IS VERY
NARROW BUT IT'S NOT THE PRACTICE
THE THE STRUCTURAL -- DOESN'T
DICTATE THE STRUCTURAL WAYS INTO
AN ERA IN WHICH AN ASSOCIATION
IS GOING TO BE.
FORMED.
THANK YOU I'M ON MY OWN TIME IS
FOR THE ON YOUR OWN TIME THANK
YOU IN AT I I UNDERSTAND AND I
BELIEVE THE AUTHORS SINCERITY IN
THIS OP PROPOSAL -- I'VE HEARD
HER SPEAK PASSIONATELY -- BOTH
IN COMMITTEE IN HERE ON THE
FLOOR ON THESE PARTICULAR ISSUES.
I JUST BELIEVE THAT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL AND THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL -- HAS SOME
DEFICIENCIES IN IT DOESN'T SPELL
OUT THOSE THAT PROCESS OF HOW.
THE TENANTS CAN ORGANIZE.
WHAT THE LIMIT OF THEIR
ORGANIZATION IS?
WHAT OTHER ASSOCIATIONS CAN THEY
ASSOCIATE WITH -- THERE AS HAS
BEEN STATED ON THE FLOOR THERE'S
SOME CONCERNS THAT HE OF
UNIONIZING.
NO APARTMENT RENTERS I THINK
THAT'S A LEGITIMATE CONCERN AYE
AYE.
I WOULD THINK THAT THE THE
CURRENT LEGITIMATE LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS WOULD HAVE A
CONCERN ABOUT THIS AS WELL -- IS
ESPECIALLY THE POLITICAL ACTION
SIDE OF IT.
THERE'S NO THERE'S NOTHING IN
HERE THAT LIMITS OR ALLOWS OR
REGULATES.
WHAT THAT IS AND I JUST THINK
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF -- AND
ANSWERED QUESTIONS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE AND I WOULD
URGE A NO VOTE UNTIL WE'RE ABLE
TO WORK OUT SOME OF THOSE ISSUES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU IN ADDITION SENATOR
LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT I VOTED I
YESTERDAY ON THIS BILL -- I DID
NOT SEE ANYTHING IN THE BILL
THAT TALKED ABOUT RENT CONTROL I
ALSO DID NOT SEE ANYTHING IN THE
BILL ABOUT -- THE TENANTS BEING
ABLE TO FORM A UNION ALTHOUGH AS
A FORMER UNION LABOR LEADER I
LOVE THAT IDEA AND MAYBE WE CAN
AMEND THAT INTO THE BILL.
WHAT I REALLY WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT TODAY IS?
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE ON
THIS FLOOR HAVE VISITED SOME OF
THESE APARTMENT COMPLEXES WE
HAVE BEEN A GREGIS COMPANY.
IN SAN BERNADINO COUNTY WHO OWNS
OVER EIGHT THOUSAND APARTMENT
COMPLEXES AND IS PROUD OF THE
SLUM LORD CONDITIONS BUT HE
PROVIDESAS HE SAYS TO THAT
SEGMENT OF THE POPULATION.
SO THIS IS SOMEONE WHO IS TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF LOW INCOME POOR
PEOPLE AND IF PEOPLE WANT TO
ASSOCIATE A GET TOGETHER TO TRY
AND BETTER THEMSELVES AND BETTER
THEIR WAY OF LIFE.
I DON'T SEE THAT AS AN ISSUE WE
KIND OF FORMAL LITTLE
ASSOCIATION HERE RIGHT WE'RE ALL
IN THE STATE SENATE WERE ALL
SENATORS I GUESS THAT'S KIND OF
AN ASSOCIATION.
AS A CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON MOBILE HOMES.
I HAVE SEEN SOME OF THE MOST
DEPLORABLE CONDITIONS FOR MOBILE
HOME HOME PARK RENTERS.
MOST OF THOSE SLUMLORDS LIVE OUT
OF STATE SOME OF THEM LIVE OUT
OF COUNTRY SO I HEARD ON THE
FLOOR YESTERDAY THAT OWNING
APARTMENT COMPLEXES BUILDS
WEALTH THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT IT'S
BUILDING WEALTH FOR SLUMLORDS
NOT ALL ARE.
BUT THE ONES THAT I VISITED I
VISITED A LOT IN MY DISTRICT I
CAN'T SPEAK FOR EVERYONE'S
DISTRICT -- THERE ARE A LOT OF
SLUMLORDS OUT THERE THAT ARE%
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF POOR PEOPLE
AND YOU CAN CHARGE WHAT YOU WANT
TO CHARGE.
THESE KEEP YOUR PARK UP AT LEAST
KEEP YOUR APARTMENT BUILDING UP
MAKE SURE THE WATER IS CLEAN
MAKE SURE THAT THE TANKS ARE
CLEAN MAKE SURE THAT THE SEWAGE.
IS AN OVERFLOWING SO.
I'VE I FEEL LIKE I'VE HEARD A
LOT TODAY ABOUT THESE WONDERFUL
FOLKS THAT ARE JUST TRYING TO
RENT TO PEOPLE AND BUILD WEALTH
THAT HAS NOT BEEN MY EXPERIENCE
I'VE SEEN MORE ON THE OPPOSITE
END.
I WOULD URGE ANYONE WHO DIDN'T
VOTE I YESTERDAY TO PLEASE GO UP
ON THIS BILL BECAUSE THIS IS
JUST ABOUT MAKING SURE THE POOR
PEOPLE ARE NOT TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF AND AGAIN I DID NOT SEE
ANYTHING IN THE BILL.
ABOUT RENT CONTROL OR ABOUT FOUR
A UNION -- BUT I WOULD CERTAINLY
SUPPORT FORMING A UNION IRISH AN
AYE VOTE.
ANY ADDITIONAL DESCRIPTION OF IT
ON THIS ITEM.
KERN TEEN ON SENATOR ALSO TO
LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES AGAIN I JUST WANT TO REMIND
MY COLLEAGUES THIS BILL -- IS
ABOUT.
A VERY NARROW SITUATION WHERE
THERE ARE TENANTS WHO ARE
NEIGHBORS THESE ARE MEN AND
WOMEN THEY'RE TRYING TO YOU KNOW
HAVE A GOOD STABLE.
HOME OR APARTMENT.
IF THEY DECIDE TO JOIN THE HOTEL
ATTENDANT ASSOCIATION THAT THERE
WILL NOT BE RETALIATION THAT
THEY'LL BE BECAUSE PROVIDED AS
TO WHY THEY'RE BEING THE VICTIM.
REMEMBER THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
ENDING UP HOMELESS OR INVICTUS.
IF YOU COULD GIVE THEM THE
ABILITY TO STAY IN THEIR HOMES
WE WOULD HAVE LESS HOMELESS
PEOPLE THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING
EVERY SINGLE DAY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA COLLEAGUES I URGENT
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
NO ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL [inaudible]
I BRIDGES.
NO BRADFORD HI I CABALLERO
[inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
DODD.
NO THE RAZA [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
NO GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
BY HILL.
I WITH SO -- TADO [inaudible]
NO JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY.
BY MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN.
BY PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BLACK OWSKI.
BY WIENER.
AYE WILK.
NO.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
WITH SO [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER.
SENATOR RAZA MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WERE MOVING NOW TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY FOUR SENATOR WAY
SURE YOU'RE PREPARED FOR THAT
MEASURE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY SIX BUT
CENTER HUESO AN ACT RELATING TO
THE SAN DIEGO CORONADO BRIDGE
INCLUDING THERE'S THREATS TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY CENTER HUESO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
I HAVE RESIDENTS FLORIDA PERCENT.
HUNDREDS OF MEASURES OVER THE
YEARS.
BUT I'VE I'VE RARELY SEEN.
ONE THAT IS SO PERSONAL TO ME
AND TOO MANY PEOPLE IN THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO [inaudible]
THIS ISSUE [inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY [inaudible]
IS THE MORE ON SLIGHTLY SIDE.
OF OUR BELOVED AND BEAUTIFUL
SEND YOU ARE NOT A BRIDGE --
THIS YEAR THE CORONADO BRIDGE
AND I WILL TURN FIFTY YEARS OLD
[inaudible]
OF IN THE SAME MONTH
OF AND IN THOSE YEARS.
MANY PEOPLE HAVE USED THIS
BRIDGE TO END THEIR LIVES VERY
QUIETLY.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS
WITHOUT.
LOTS OF NEW STORIES.
CALLING ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
IN FACT.
ALL RIGHT CURRENTLY IT IS
RECOGNIZED.
AS THE SECOND MOST FREQUENTLY
USED BRIDGE FOR SUICIDES IN ALL
OF THE UNITED STATES.
WITNESSING IN AS MANY AS
NINETEEN DEATHS ANNUALLY.
IN RESPONSE THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL IS INCREASE THEIR
PRESENCE AND MONITORING.
ADDITIONALLY THIS SPRING
CALTRANS PLAY SPORTS BIKES ALONG
THE EDGES.
OF THE BRIDGE [inaudible]
HOWEVER.
THESE INITIATIVES.
ARE ONLY TEMPORARY AND I'M NOT
BEEN ABLE TO FULLY ADDRESS.
THIS ISSUE WITHIN WEEKS OF THEIR
INSTALLATION THREE SUICIDES
OCCURRED WITHIN A SINGLE TWENTY
FOUR HOUR PERIOD. ONE OF THE
GOVERNMENT ONE OF THE
GOVERNMENT'S ESSENTIAL DUTIES.
IS TO PROVIDE FOR THE PUBLIC'S
SAFETY.
NO WHERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IS OUR STATE'S GOVERNMENT
FAILING SO GRAVELY.
THEN HERE IN THIS ROADWAY IN THE
CORNER BRIDGE.
EVERYWHERE ELSE SOMETIMES A A
DEATH RESULTS IN A LOSS.
TO THE LIABILITY.
HERE WE ARE FAILING THE PEOPLE
OF OUR STATE.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE CALTRANS
TO ESTABLISH A DEVICE RE
COMMITTEE WHICH WILL PROVIDE
INPUT ON THE SELECTION OF A PER
PROPER SUICIDE DETERRENT SYSTEM.
THIS COMMITTEE WOULD BE
COMPRISED OF A VARIETY OF
REPRESENTATIVES FROM SENDING
COUNTY THE CITIES OF CORN OUT OF
ONE SAN DIEGO THE HIGHWAY PATROL
AND AND LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUICIDE PREVENTION ADVOCATES.
SB SIX FIVE SIX WILL ENSURE
INPUT.
PROVIDED BY A BROAD SELECTION OF
REGIONAL STAKEHOLDERS WILL HELP
INFORM THE SELECTION PROCESS AND
LEAD TO A DECISION.
THAT BEST MEETS THE NEEDS OF THE
COMMUNITY.
MORE IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL GETS
COMMUNITY STAKE HOLDERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK.
AS CO CALTRAIN CONTINUES TO
REVIEW POSSIBLE LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS TO HELP PREVENT THESE
LAMENTABLE DEATHS.
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
LET'S START.
WORKING HARD TO ELIMINATE.
THIS UNFORTUNATE SITUATION
FACING MY COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS PROPOSAL I THINK THE
AUTHOR. FOR THE MANY YEARS THAT
HE HAS SPENT WORKING ON THIS --
TRYING TO COME TO A SOLUTION.
THAT -- OBVIOUSLY IMPACTS HIS
DISTRICT BUT I BELIEVE IT
IMPACTS -- NOT JUST HIS DISTRICT
BUT ALL FORTY SENATE DISTRICTS
IN THE STATE.
AS HE STATED THAT THIS IS ONE OF
THE TOP -- BRIDGES IN THE
COUNTRY THAT IS USED FOR SUICIDE.
AND THOSE SUICIDES DON'T JUST
IMPACT THE INDIVIDUAL THAT HAS
GOTTEN TO SUCH A DESPAIR IN
THEIR LIFE THAT THE ONLY
SOLUTION THEY SEEK IS TO END
THEIR OWN LIFE.
BUT IT LEAVES BEHIND A RIPPLE
EFFECT OF DESPAIR.
AMONGST THEIR FAMILIES --
AMONGST THEIR FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUES.
AMONGST THEIR CO WORKERS AND
PEOPLE THAT KNEW THAT PERSON AND
PERSONALLY.
IT LEAVES A RIPPLE EFFECT ON
COUNSELORS.
THEY HAVE TRIED TO MISTER THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO PREVENT.
SUCH AN ACT OF DESPAIR.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
SOMETIMES IS OVERLOOKED AND NOT
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION.
IS EFFECTIVE THE HOUSE OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS.
AND THIS.
SITUATION HAS BECOME PERSONAL TO
ME MOST RECENTLY.
AS TWO OF MY BEST FRIENDS.
THEIR SONS HAVE JUSTRECENTLY
BEEN RECRUITED AND OBTAINED A
POSITION ON ON THE SAN DIEGO
HARBOR POLICE.
AND THEY'RE THE ONES THAT HAVE
TO RESPOND. TO THE SITUATIONS.
AND IT'S OUR POLICE OFFICERS OUR
FIREFIGHTERS ARE PARAMEDICS.
AND OTHER FIRST RESPONDERS THERE
ARE THE FIRST ON THE SCENE. TO
THE SITUATIONS [inaudible]
THAT -- HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF THE
OF THE OF THE SITUATION TAKE
CARE OF THE SCENE.
AND THEN AFTER THAT.
HAVE THE CONVERSATION WITH THE
FAMILY.
AND THE FRIENDS.
THAT ARE LEFT BEHIND.
SO I THINK THIS IS A SMALL STEP.
AT THE STATE GOVERNMENT CAN TAKE.
TO HELP PREVENT.
THOSE TRAGIC SITUATIONS.
AND THOSE ACTS OF DESPAIR.
AND I THINK THE AUTHOR AGAIN.
FOR HIS DILIGENT WORK ON THIS
AND ALSO ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE SIDE
OF SENATOR BILL.
JUST BRIEFLY -- OF SINCE THERE'S
BEEN -- SUICIDE BRIDGE JOB.
SUICIDE PREVENTION ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN THE LAST. TEN YEARS
THIS IS NOW.
THE THIRD RICH AND UNITED STATES.
AND I PLEDGE SIR WERE ALSO FOR
HIS EFFORTS -- HE'S BEEN.
WORKING ON US FOR QUITE SOME
TIME -- CALTRANS SHOULD
IMMEDIATELY.
PROCEED WITH URGENCY PROJECT AND
I AGREE WITH YOUR URGENCY CLAWS
ON THIS BILL -- WE NEED TO GET
THIS -- TO PREVENT FURTHER
SUICIDES -- THIS IS -- IT'S
GOING TO READ ABOUT TWENTY A
YEAR OR SO -- THE FASTER WE GET
THIS PROJECT DONE -- WE WILL
SAVE LIVES IF THIS PROJECT IS
DONE AND EXPEDITIOUS MANNER
ARJUN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OF IT ON THIS ITEM.
TUNING YOUR NINE CENTER WHICH
WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MATT MISTER PRESIDENT
OF MEMBERS.
PLEASE JOIN ME AND OVER FOUR
HUNDRED FAMILIES THAT HAVE.
TO LIVE WITH A VERY PAINFUL
MEMORY OF SOMEBODY THAT WE LOST
[inaudible]
AT THIS.
AT THE BRIDGE.
DOES YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE.
THE COMMEMORATION OF THIS THE
URGENCY ITEM AND REQUIRES TWO
THIRDS VOTE INSTRUCTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BILL.
I BRIDGES.
I BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL.
I CHIANG AYE DODD.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG BY HILL.
I WITH SO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL.
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE.
OUR COUNTY I WINNER.
BY WILK.
BY.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
MITCHELL [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER. THIRTY FIVE ON THE
URGENCY. THIRTY FIVE ON THE
MEASURE ZERO KNOWS MEASURE
PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE FILE ITEM TWENTY
FIVE CENTER Y. KASKI.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY THREE
BY SENATOR AYE CASKEY AND PACK
RELATED COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT.
SENATOR FOR JURORS THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT SENATE BILL --
THREE TWO THREE WILL STRENGTHEN
THE DEMOCRATIC GOVERNANCE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
PLUS OUR HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS
SOME HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS
FUNCTION WONDERFULLY VERY
DEMOCRATIC OTHERS NOT SO
UNFORTUNATELY CORRUPT AND
DYSFUNCTIONAL HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION BOARDS WILL
EXCLUDING DISENFRANCHISED.
OTHER HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION
MEMBERS IN THE COMMUNITY WHO
SEEK TO CHALLENGE THEIR EXISTING
REGIME.
H. AWAY BOARDS CONFINED
HOMEOWNERS TAKE THEM TO COURT
AND EVEN FOR CLOSE ON THEIR
HOMES FOR THE STATE TO A BOARD
MEMBER ELECTIONS ARE NO SMALL
MATTER.
FLOOR AMENDMENTS FOR THE
CLARIFIED THE BILL AND EVERY
MOVE THE OPPOSITION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND WITH THAT I
REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OF A ON THE SIDE OF HEARING AND
SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NOBEL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DOT.
I THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
HERTZBERG
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
IOWA CASKEY.
I WINNER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
NO.
SECTOR PLEASE CALLED OUT TO
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER.
SIR WHY BECAUSE HE MOVES CALL.
MOVING ON NOW TO FOLLOW ITEM.
TWENTY NINE ZERO AYE BECAUSE
GARY PREPARED.
THE SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL SIX SIXTEEN BY
SENATOR Y. CASKEY AND ACALANES
CIVIL ACTIONS -- WHY BECAUSE YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT SENATE BILL SIX
ONE SIX TAKES A SMALL STEP
TOWARD STEMMING THE HOMELESSNESS
EPIDEMIC AND PREVENTING EVEN
MORE PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA FROM
BEING PUSHED INTO POVERTY?
FLOOR AMENDMENTS WHICH I
RESEARCH RECENTLY -- TOOK OR
FILED REMOVE THE OPPOSITION FROM
THE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION.
AGAIN THE CALIFORNIA VEGAS
CESSATIONS NOW NEUTRAL ON THIS
BILL AND I THINK THEM FOR THEIR
EFFORTS.
SENATE BILL SIX ONE SIX WOULD
PROTECT TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
A PERSON'S CHECKING ACCOUNT FROM
BEING SEIZE BY DEBT COLLECTORS
WE KNOW THAT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE LIVING ON THE
EDGE.
BARELY COVERING THEIR BASIC
NEEDS A SUDDEN ARE WIPING OUT OF
THEIR CHECKING ACCOUNT PUSHES
PEOPLE OVER THAT EDGE NOTHING IN
SENATE BILL SIX ONE SIX HE RACES
THE DEBT OR STOPS A DEBT
COLLECTOR FROM SEEKING REPAYMENT.
THIS BILL WILL KEEP A ROOF OVER
HEADS THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
WHO MIGHT OTHERWISE BE THROWN
OUT.
OF ON THE STREET BECAUSE THEY
ARE UNABLE TO PAY.
THE RENT BECAUSE ALL THE MONEY
IN THE CHECKING ACCOUNT GOT LEVY.
MISTER PRESIDENT TODAY MENTION
THAT THE CALIFORNIA BAKER
CESSATION HAVE WITHDRAWN THEIR
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL AND WITH
THAT I REGION I VOTE.
IN ADDITION DISCUSSION -- DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM.
HERE IN SEEN ON THE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
HI PORGES.
BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
HI JANE [inaudible]
DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
[inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO --
TADA [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
HI MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL.
MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BURKE MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
I HAVE A COUNTY.
I WIENER AYE WILK.
VICTOR PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES.
NO FOR JUST [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
JANE [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO.
HUESO.
HI FOR TITLE BY [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER.
ICE.
TWENTY THREE KNOWS NINE MEASURE
PASSES
.
MEMBERS BEFORE WE LOOK THE CALL
IN THOSE OUTSTANDING ITEMS --
WE'RE GOING TO WAIT TO ALL THE
MEMBERS RETURNED TO THE FLOOR --
IN MEANTIME WE'RE GONNA MOVE
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
IF THERE'S ANY.
PRIVILEGED MOTIONS A RED
RESOLUTIONS AT THE START
[inaudible]
SENATOR DORADO -- YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR -- FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN SB SEVEN FIVE SIX I'D
LIKE TO MOVE TO INACTION
[inaudible]
INACTIVE FILE [inaudible]
COOLEY NOTE [inaudible]
IN -- MEMBERS WERE JUST KIND OF
A AND HOLDING PATTERN UNTIL THE
BUDGET CONFEREES COME BACK TO
THE FLOOR SO.
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO LOOK CALLS
ON THOSE OUTSTANDING ITEMS SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
INNER CHIANG FOR PURPOSE YOU
RISE.
UP.
UNDER MOTIONS IN I WOULD LIKE TO
GO BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS UNDER MOTIONS AND
RIGHT RESOLUTIONS I WOULD LIKE
TO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT. TO
ASK A QUESTION THE AUTHOR ON AS
THE FIFTY FOUR SENATE ALLERGY TO
QUESTION YES SIR [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION [inaudible]
SENATOR CHECK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS RESIDENT --
TO THE AUTHOR I HAVE -- THREE
THREE QUESTIONS -- WILL YOU BE
AMENDING THE SCOPING PLAN
DEADLINE -- TO TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR IS IT YOUR INTENT THAT THE
SCOPING PLAN COMES BEFORE
REGULATIONS AND THIS IS BILL
PROVIDED FEELS FORTY FOR POWER
CYCLE IN OTHER WORDS DO THEY
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE
PLEASE.
WITH YOUR PERMISSION MISTER
CHAIR.
YES YES -- ACTUALLY HAPPY TO
AGREE -- TO AMEND THE DATE OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS WILL BE
PLANET.
THE FIRST OF A JAN TWENTY FOUR
ON THE SECOND QUESTION THE
ANSWER IS YES AS WELL -- THE
THIRD QUESTION I TO DO WITH
YOUTH ALREADY AND THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS BILL AT ALL
ASSOCIATE WITH YOUR STORY THAT --
SO AND AND IN FACT THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY TRIGGER.
HIGHER VOTE THRESHOLD SO -- THE
NOTHING ABOUT THE BUDGET OR IN
THIS BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
THE BILL [inaudible]
PRESSING.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA LOOK TO CALL
ON ITEM [inaudible]
NINETEEN SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
RUBIO.
ICE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS A MEASURE
PASSES.
I REMEMBER WAS.
OUR MEMBERSHIP WE'RE GONNA LOOK
TO CALL FIRST ITEM UP IS FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN BY SENATOR MITCHELL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD HI HI -- TADO
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
SKINNER I PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS FOR JUST -- TADO
[inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES.
ICE TWENTY SIX NO DATE THE
MEASURE PASSES NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR ATKINS
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
NO.
PRICE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES NEXT UP IS FILE
ITEM.
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I GROVE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
I LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
STONE
.
YOUR BOARD IS YOUR OPTION IS TO
GO FROM NO THE I OR I DON'T KNOW
BUT SHE CANNOT STAY SO.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO REMAIN NO
[inaudible]
OUR ICE THIRTY TWO KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE FILE ITEM.
TWENTY SIX MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE -- TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY KELSEY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALLEN[inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
GROW BY -- TADO FIRE
[inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
BY KELSEY.
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS WILL
RETURN [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
CHIANG.
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
TALK ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
BATES AND CHIANG [inaudible]
GALGIANI.
GLAZER -- TADO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER STERN [inaudible]
WHY CASKEY [inaudible]
THE CALL [inaudible]
GROVE.
I TO KNOW.
MOVE THE CALL.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
NUMBER.
TEN PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
ROTH.
SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE.
MITCHELL AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
ROTH.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GLAZER [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
ROTH.
MOVE THE CALL.
MIX UPS FALL I'M.
TWENTY FIVE THE SECRETARY CALLED
UP TO MEMBERS [inaudible]
PORGES [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
MID JULY [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
HI.
YES PLEASE CALLED UP TO MEMBERS
FOR JUST [inaudible]
CHANGE
.
PRICE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS EIGHT
THE MEASURE PASSES
THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY SIX SENATOR BRADFORD
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER -- TADO [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
SKINNER STERN WHY CASKEY.
MITCHELL I TO KNOW.
MONNING I TO KNOW.
MONNING I DON'T KNOW.
DODD I DON'T KNOW.
PHONE NUMBER GUY NUMBER.
NUMBER GUARDINO. FIVE ELEVEN
KNOWS ELEVEN THE MEASURE FAILS.
THOROUGHBRED FOR REQUEST
RECONSIDERATION.
GREAT RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED
AYE AYES THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS.
ZERO WHAT ELSE DO WE HAVE
.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM TEN SENATOR
DORADO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
ROTH.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
ROTH.
MEASURE FAILS BUYS TWENTY KNOWS
[inaudible]
FIFTEEN SENATOR [inaudible]
MEASURE FAILS.
US CENTER DRAWS A REQUEST
RECONSIDERATION.
NO -- MEASURE FAILS
.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR WELLS THE DESK
IS CLEAR.
THE PT SUPPOSED TO DO THIS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THE SENATE WILL BE ADJOURNED WE
WILL RECONVENE BACK HRE
GREAT WORK MEMBERS.
THANK YOU CENTER WILK MEMBERS WE
ARE ADJOURNED WE WILL RECONVENE
TOMORROW AT NINE AM HAVE A GREAT
EVENING